>> APPARENTLY, SENATE COMMITTEE
ON
HEALTH WILL COME TO ORDER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US THIS AFTERNOON.
AS YOU KNOW, WE ALLOW SIX
MINUTES
OF TESTIMONY PER SIDE.
SO PLEASE DIVIDE IT UP, AND THIS
HEARING
WILL PROCEED EFFICIENTLY.
WE'VE HAD ONE BILL PULLED FROM
TODAY'S AGENDA.
AB 2376.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAINES CHEMICAL
DEPENDENCY RECOVERY HOSPITALS.
SO WE HAVE 22 BILLS ON THE
AGENDA,
WITH NINE OF THEM BEING ON
A PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR CONSISTS
OF THE FOLLOWING SJ R 18.
SENATOR PADILLA.
TIJUANA RIVER.
UH ITEM NUMBER THREE AB 869.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
WOOD AND GARCIA.
HOSPITALS.
UM, SEISMIC SAFETY COMPLIANCE
WITH
AMENDMENTS ITEM NUMBER SEVEN,
AB 1859 ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALANIS
CORONER'S ITEM NUMBER EIGHT
AB 1996 ASSEMBLY MEMBER, ALANIS
OPIOID ANTAGONISTS.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB 2098
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA,
CALIFORNIA HEALTH FACILITIES
FINANCING AUTHORITY ACT,
ITEM NUMBER 16, AB 2006 13.
SOME MEMBERS OF HER.
UM.
JACQUELINE MARIE ZUBER,
RARE DISEASE ADVISORY COUNCIL,
WITH AMENDMENTS ITEM NUMBER 17,
AB 2637.
SOME MEMBER SCHIAVO HEALTH
FACILITIES FINANCING
AUTHORITY ACT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EIGHT.
UH, ITEM NUMBER 18 AB 2756.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, BERNER PELVIC
FLOOR
AND CORE CONDITIONING PILOT
PROGRAM
AND ITEM NUMBER 21 AB 3045
ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TODD BIRTH CERTIFICATE.
LET'S PROCEED WITH OUR FIRST
ITEM ON THE HEARING.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB 236 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER,
HOLDEN HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
PROVIDER DIRECTORIES.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY, SIR.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIRMAN.
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU AND
THIS COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR ATTENTION TO CARE OVER
THIS PARTICULAR BILL AND FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT IT TODAY TO YOU.
AB 236 IS MY GHOST NETWORK
PREVENTION BILL,
WHICH WILL ADDRESS RAMPANT
INACCURACIES
IN HEALTH PLAN PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES.
I WANT TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE.
THE PROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS HELP GET THIS BILL
TO A BETTER PLACE BY ADDRESSING
RECENT CONCERNS.
AND I'M HAPPY, MORE THAN HAPPY,
TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS.
IN 2015, CALIFORNIA PASSED
SENATE BILL 137,
WHICH CREATED SOME OF THE
STRONGEST STANDARDS
FOR HEALTH PLANS IN THE NATION.
DESPITE THIS, WE'RE STILL SEEING
HEALTH PLANS MAINTAIN
INACCURATE PROVIDER REFERRAL
DIRECTORIES,
A PRACTICE THAT RESTRICTS
CONSUMERS ACCESS
TO PROMISE HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THESE INACCURATE LISTS ARE
OFTEN REFERRED TO AS GHOST
NETWORKS BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
ACTUALLY EXIST.
IN AN EFFORT TO ELIMINATE THESE
GHOST NETWORKS
AND ADDRESS RAMPANT DIRECTORY
INACCURACIES,
AB 236 WILL ENSURE ACCURATE
PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES SO PATIENTS CAN
EASILY
FIND CARE AND BETTER DECIDE
WHAT PLANS
MEET THEIR HEALTH CARE NEEDS.
TO STREAMLINE THE PROCESS OF
UPDATING PROVIDER
INFORMATION AND TO MAINTAIN
ACCURACY.
THE BILL GIVES DEPARTMENT OF
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH,
DMVS AND CDI THE AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS
AND INSURERS TO USE CENTRAL
PROVIDER
DIRECTORY UTILITIES.
AB 236 ALSO INCREASES
ACCOUNTABILITY
BY ANNUALLY INCREASING
ACCURACY BENCHMARKS WITH
EFFECTIVE
ENFORCEMENT METHODS.
WITH THESE BENCHMARKS, PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES WILL
BE REQUIRED TO HAVE A 95%
ACCURACY BY JULY 2028.
I WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE THAT
HEALTH
PLANS ARE ALREADY REQUIRED
TO MAINTAIN ACCURATE DIRECTORIES
UNDER CURRENT LAW,
SO EACH HEALTH PLAN SHOULD
STRIVE TO
CLOSE FOR CLOSE TO 100%
ACCURACY.
THE BILL WAS AMENDED TO ADDRESS
RECENT
CONCERNS AND TO DO THE
FOLLOWING.
DELETES REQUIREMENTS FOR
PROVIDERS
TO BE REMOVED FROM THE DIRECTORY
IF THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
FINANCIALLY
COMPENSATED BY THE PLAN.
THE BILL PROHIBITS PLANS AND
INSURERS
FROM USING PROVIDERS FOR
REPORTING TO DEPARTMENTS DATA
NECESSARY
FOR NETWORK ACCURACY,
ADEQUACY, TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE,
AND OTHER LAWS AND REGULATIONS.
AS A RESULT, THIS WILL ENSURE
THE STATE HAS THE INFORMATION
NECESSARY TO UNDERSTAND WHICH
PROVIDERS
ARE SEEING PATIENTS IN SPECIFIC
NETWORKS
AND WHERE GAPS IN NETWORK
ADEQUACY ARE.
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
CONCERNS WITH
THE USE OF UTILITIES TO MEET
BENCHMARKS,
AND CLARIFIES AN ERROR IN A
DIRECTORY
SHOULD ONLY BE CONSIDERED
WHEN IT IMPACTS A PATIENT'S
ACCESS TO CARE.
I WOULD LIKE TO STATE THAT I
REMAIN
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THIS
BILL IS IN A BETTER PLACE,
BUT I BELIEVE THESE AMENDMENTS
ARE
A STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IS SARAH SORKIN,
A LICENSED MARRIAGE AND FAMILY
THERAPIST,
AND CAITLIN VAN VAN VAN DUSEN.
DINE, POLICY ADVOCATE AND HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE WHEN YOU HAVE
A QUORUM.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
I WON'T TRY THE NAMES, BUT LET
ME
HAVE YOU IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD BEFORE YOU SPEAK,
AND PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
>> OH, I'M SARA SOROKIN.
I'M A LICENSED MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPIST.
AND AS A MENTAL HEALTH
THERAPIST,
I HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND HOW
INACCURATE
PROVIDER DIRECTORIES OR GHOST
NETWORKS HARM PATIENTS.
IN MY SIX YEARS AS A TRIAGE
AND CRISIS THERAPIST AT KAISER,
IT WAS A RARE DAY THAT I DID
NOT SPEAK
TO AT LEAST ONE PATIENT
REPORTING.
THEY HAD CALLED THROUGH LISTS
OF MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
IN AN ATTEMPT TO CONNECT TO
TREATMENT.
NONE OF THE PROVIDERS WERE
EITHER
RESPONSIVE OR AVAILABLE.
ALL THE WHILE, THE PATIENT'S
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION
HAD WORSENED WITHOUT THE NEEDED
CARE BEING PROVIDED.
THESE WERE PATIENTS EXPERIENCING
ANXIETY DISORDERS, DEPRESSION,
AND POST-TRAUMATIC STRESS,
AMONG OTHER MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS.
THEY WERE EXPECTED TO CALL
THROUGH
PROVIDER LISTS OF 2550
OR MORE IN AN ATTEMPT TO GET
CONNECTED TO TREATMENT,
EVEN THOUGH THEIR SYMPTOMS MADE
DOING SO EXTREMELY CHALLENGING.
WHEN I WORKED AT UCLA'S STUDENT
COUNSELING CENTER,
WE SPENT VALUABLE TIME THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN
USED TO PROVIDE ASSESSMENT OR
TREATMENT,
CALLING THROUGH LISTS OF
THERAPISTS IN
THE ANTHEM PROVIDER DIRECTORY
IN ORDER
TO CREATE A MORE ACCURATE LIST
OF AVAILABLE
THERAPISTS TO GIVE TO STUDENTS.
TO INCREASE STUDENTS LIKELIHOOD
OF GETTING CONNECTED TO NEEDED
CARE THROUGH THE STUDENT HEALTH
INSURANCE PROGRAM.
FREQUENTLY, PATIENTS WHO HAVE
THE MEANS END
UP PAYING OUT OF POCKET FOR
PSYCHOTHERAPY
WHEN THEY CANNOT FIND AN
AVAILABLE PROVIDER
COVERED BY THEIR INSURANCE,
AND THOSE UNABLE TO AFFORD
PRIVATE
PAY ARE LEFT WITHOUT TREATMENT.
DESPITE THE FACT THAT HEALTH
INSURERS MUST PROVIDE OUT OF
NETWORK COVERAGE WHEN THEIR
NETWORKS ARE INADEQUATE.
WHAT WE ARE LEFT WITH IS A TWO
TIER HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
IN WHICH INEQUITIES ARE
EXACERBATED AND REINFORCED.
SOME PATIENTS EXPERIENCE SEVERE
NEGATIVE OUTCOMES
AS A RESULT OF THESE GHOST
NETWORKS.
AS AN EXAMPLE, I HAVE EVALUATED
A PATIENT IN AN EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT WHO HAD ATTEMPTED
SUICIDE AFTER CALLING
THROUGH A LIST OF 50 PROVIDERS
WITHOUT SUCCESS,
LOSING HOPE AND SPIRALING DEEPER
INTO DEPRESSION.
THIS PATIENT NOW HAS THE TRAUMAS
OF A SUICIDE ATTEMPT,
AND HAVING BEEN HARMED BY OUR
HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM TO ADD TO THEIR TREATMENT
NEEDS,
WE WOULD BE NEGLIGENT IF WE
DIDN'T DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER TO ENSURE PATIENTS GET
THE HEALTH CARE THEY NEED,
PAY FOR, AND ARE LEGALLY
ENTITLED TO.
AB 236 WILL HOLD HEALTH
INSURANCE
COMPANIES ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE ACCURACY OF THEIR
PROVIDER NETWORK LISTS,
WHICH WILL GO FAR IN IMPROVING
ACCESS
TO ESSENTIAL HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
YES, MA'AM.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR AND SENATORS.
I'M KATIE VAN DINES WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA,
AND WE ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR AB
236 HEALTH PLANS.
AND INSURERS ARE REQUIRED TO
MAINTAIN
DIRECTORIES OF THEIR CONTRACTED
PROVIDERS IN ORDER TO FACILITATE
CARE FOR THEIR ENROLLEES.
AND CONSUMERS DESERVE ACCURATE
PROVIDER DIRECTORIES.
BUT AS YOU JUST HEARD,
THESE DIRECTORIES ARE FAILING
CONSUMERS IN INACCURACIES.
THEY ARE CREATING BARRIERS TO
CONSUMERS
ACCESSING THE CARE THAT THEY
NEED.
AS YOU HEARD FROM MR.
HOLDEN, CALIFORNIA HAS THE
STRONGEST LAW
IN THE NATION ON PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES.
YET RECENT STUDIES HAVE FOUND
THAT ONE OF
THESE DIRECTORIES WAS 80%
INACCURATE,
AND MOST HAD INACCURATE
INFORMATION FOR
A QUARTER OR A THIRD OF THEIR
PROVIDERS.
THESE INACCURACIES ARE THE WORST
FOR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROVIDERS
FOR SERVICES THAT ARE ALREADY
SO HARD TO REACH.
EB 236 TAKES IMPORTANT STEPS
TO IMPROVE
PROVIDER DIRECTORY ACCURACY.
FIRST, IT GIVES THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE AND CDI THE
AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE PLANS IN PROVIDERS TO
USE ESSENTIAL
UTILITY OR ESSENTIAL UTILITIES.
IN WITH CENTRAL UTILITIES,
WE CAN ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
WE'VE
BEEN HEARING FROM PROVIDERS
AROUND HOW TIME CONSUMING
IT IS FOR PROVIDERS TO UPDATE
INFORMATION WITH THEIR
HEALTH PLANS FOR THE PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES,
BECAUSE THEY'RE HEARING SO MANY
FROM
SO MANY DIFFERENT HEALTH PLANS
THAT
THEY'RE CONTRACTED WITH VIA
PHONE CALL,
VIA PHONE CALLS, MAIL, EMAIL.
SECOND, THIS BILL SETS CLEAR AND
ENFORCEABLE
STANDARDS FOR ACCURACY,
ANNUALLY INCREASING BENCHMARKS
STARTING AT 60%
AND INCREASING OVER THE NEXT
FIVE YEARS.
YOU MAY HEAR THAT DMHC AND CDI
HAVE EXISTING
AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE THESE
STEPS.
HOWEVER, IN REALITY THEY LACK
THE STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO DO
SO TO TAKE THESE CONCRETE STEPS
TOWARDS ACCOUNTABILITY.
YOU MAY ALSO HEAR THAT THERE ARE
PENDING REGULATIONS
AND WE SHOULD WAIT FOR THOSE
REGULATIONS.
THIS IS MISLEADING.
DMHC HAS ISSUED DETAILED
GUIDANCE ANNUALLY
SINCE THE EXISTING LAW WAS
PASSED IN 2016,
BUT THE DRAFT REGULATIONS ARE
LARGELY
CODIFYING EXISTING GUIDANCE
AND DO NOT TAKE THE CONCRETE
STEPS PROPOSED IN AB 236.
YOU MAY ALSO HEAR THAT HEALTH
PLANS
CANNOT MAINTAIN ACCURATE
DIRECTORIES WITHOUT PROVIDERS
UPDATING THEIR INFORMATION,
AND THIS IS SHARED IS A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY.
IT IS A HEALTH PLANS PROVIDER
DIRECTORY AND HEALTH
PLANS ARE NOT USING THE EXISTING
TOOLS THEY HAVE
UNDER EXISTING LAW TO
INCENTIVISE PROVIDERS TO
UPDATE THEIR INFORMATION AND
IMPROVE ACCURACY.
WHEN CONSUMERS GO TO CALL
PROVIDERS
LISTED IN THEIR DIRECTORIES,
THE PHONE NUMBER IS WRONG.
THE PROVIDER IS NOT TAKING NEW
PATIENTS.
THE PROVIDER SAYS THEY DO NOT
HAVE A CONTRACT WITH
THE HEALTH PLAN OR THEY'RE
NOT A PRIMARY CARE DOCTOR,
CONTRARY TO WHAT'S IN THEIR
HEALTH
PLAN PROVIDER DIRECTORY.
AND ON AND ON THE INACCURACIES
GO.
WE HAVE MET AND MET WITH THE
OPPOSITION
AND TAKEN MANY AMENDMENTS,
BUT THEY HAVE NEVER OFFERED
CONCRETE SUGGESTIONS ON
HOW TO IMPROVE THE ACCURACY OF
THE DIRECTORIES,
JUST EXCUSES ABOUT WHY THESE
INACCURACIES,
THESE DIRECTORIES ARE SO
INACCURATE.
BUT THE EXISTING LAW ON PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES
HAS BEEN ON THE BOOKS FOR NEARLY
A DECADE.
WE CAN, AND WE MUST DO BETTER
FOR CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS
SO THAT THEY CAN ACCESS THE CARE
THAT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE ON AB 236.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE.
>> CAP S WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
>> AUTUMN, OGDEN SMITH WITH
THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY,
CANCER ACTION NETWORK AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> WELL, LET'S GO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF ORTHODONTISTS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
>> SANDRA POOLE ON BEHALF OF
WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> ADAMSON, LEUKEMIA AND
LYMPHOMA
SOCIETY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> NORA LYNN, WITH CHILDREN NOW
IN SUPPORT.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, BETH
MANOLESCU,
THE SEO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, DONNA WOOD,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF NATIONAL COUNCIL
OF NEGRO WOMEN.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> JULIE NIELSEN WITH THE
NATIONAL UNION
OF HEALTH CARE WORKERS AND
SUPPORT.
>> LAUREN FINK WITH THE KENNEDY
FORUM AND SUPPORT.
>> GRACE HARRISON WITH THE
STEINBERG
INSTITUTION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE, LET'S TURN TO
WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION FIRST.
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES, IF
ANY.
PLEASE LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES.
FEEL FREE TO TAKE THE TABLE IF
YOU'D PREFER.
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD
AND PROCEED WHEN READY.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE, JED
HAMPTON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS HERE,
REGRETTABLY, IN OPPOSITION TO
AB 236.
UH, FIRST AND FOREMOST, WE WOULD
REALLY,
GENUINELY LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR
AND HIS STAFF AND THE SPONSORS.
WE HAVE HAD QUITE A FEW
CONVERSATIONS,
SUBSTANTIVE CONVERSATIONS OVER
THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF REGARDING THE
BILL.
UM, WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS WILLINGNESS TO
TO ENGAGE WITH US TO ADDRESS
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS.
AND WE DO FEEL LIKE WE HAVE MADE
SOME PROGRESS ON THE BILL.
SO, YOU KNOW, AGAIN, WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF OF THAT,
YOU KNOW, OF THE AUTHORS
WILLINGNESS
TO MEET WITH US.
AND WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
INTENT OF
THE BILL AND SHARE THE AUTHOR'S
CONCERNS
AROUND ACCURATE PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES
AND MAINTAINING THOSE PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES.
WE UNIQUELY UNDERSTAND THE
FRUSTRATION
THAT CAN ARISE FROM INACCURATE
INFORMATION BEING LISTED IN
THE PROVIDER DIRECTORIES,
AND AGAIN,
HAVE SPENT A SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT
OF
TIME NOT ONLY THROUGH THIS BILL,
BUT THROUGH OTHER AVENUES,
TO ENSURE THAT WE THAT WE CAN
FIX
THE PROBLEMS THAT THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST.
SO WE CERTAINLY ACKNOWLEDGE
THE, THE,
THE PROBLEM THAT THAT LIES
BEFORE US.
HOWEVER, REGRETTABLY, WE DO NOT
FEEL THAT AB 236 ADEQUATELY
ADDRESSES THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE
ISSUE.
UH, THE ACCURACY OF EACH
INDIVIDUAL
PROVIDER DIRECTORY IS RELIANT
UPON
PRACTITIONERS AND MEDICAL GROUPS
MAINTAINING ACCURATE RECORDS,
PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION TO
THE PLANS
AND INSURERS IN A TIMELY MANNER,
AND INFORMING PLANS AND INSURERS
IN REAL TIME
OF ANY RELEVANT CHANGES WHEN
THEY ARE MADE.
UM, YOU KNOW, I THINK CONTRARY
TO,
YOU KNOW, WHERE WE HAVE A I
GUESS,
A DISAGREEMENT WITH THE SPONSORS
IS THAT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A SHARED
RESPONSIBILITY.
WE CANNOT UPDATE OUR INFORMATION
IF WE ARE ONE NOT
RECEIVING THAT INFORMATION OR
RECEIVING IT TIMELY,
OR IF THERE IS A BROKEN LINE
OF COMMUNICATION BETWEEN,
YOU KNOW, THE PLANS AND OUR
CONTRACTED NETWORKS.
SO AGAIN, THIS IS FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE,
A A SHARED RESPONSIBILITY.
AND WE WOULD FUNDAMENTALLY
DISAGREE WITH,
WITH THE, YOU KNOW,
KIND OF THE SPONSOR'S
CHARACTERIZATION,
CHARACTERIZATION OF THAT.
UM, I WILL SAY WE CERTAINLY
BELIEVE
IN THE CONCEPT AND THE PROMISE
OF,
UH, OF OF A CENTRAL UTILITY
THAT'S LISTED IN THE BILL.
WE THINK THAT THERE IS, YOU
KNOW,
SOME SOME OPPORTUNITY THERE.
BUT AGAIN, WE DO NEED FULL
STAKEHOLDER
BUY IN, YOU KNOW,
AMONGST ALL PLANS AND ALL
PROVIDERS TO,
TO TO LEVERAGE THAT UTILITY.
SO WE'RE GETTING MEANINGFUL
INFORMATION
OUT OF THAT UTILITY.
WE'VE ALSO PROPOSED, YOU KNOW,
CONSIDERATIONS AROUND A SAFE
HARBOR WHEREBY
THE PLANS USE A CENTRAL UTILITY
THAT
THE PLANS WOULD BE PROTECTED
FROM
LIABILITY IF THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY'RE
PULLING FROM THIS CENTRAL
UTILITY IS,
IS INACCURATE, THAT WE WOULD
HAVE SOME PROTECTIONS THERE.
AND QUITE FRANKLY, WE HAVE
OFFERED WE OFFERED QUITE
A FEW SUGGESTIONS EARLIER ON IN
THE PROCESS AS WELL.
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, MUCH OF WHICH,
UM, YOU KNOW, WERE, I THINK,
NOT WILLING TO BE CONSIDERED
BY THE SPONSORS AT THE TIME.
SO AGAIN, WE WE ACKNOWLEDGE THE
ISSUE.
WE WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS FOR FOR
WORKING WITH US AND GETTING THIS
TO A BETTER PLACE.
BUT AS AS THE BILL IS DRAFTED
NOW,
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT'S GOING
TO,
UH, APPROPRIATELY RESOLVE THE
ISSUE.
SO FOR, FOR THE THE MEANTIME,
WE WE ARE OPPOSED TO AB 236
BUT WE DO CONTINUE TO HOPE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS MOVING
FORWARD TO ADDRESS SOME OF OUR
CONCERNS.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
BRANDON MARGIE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION,
REGRETTABLY HERE IN OPPOSITION
AS WELL,
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR,
UH,
HIS CONSTANT WORK ON THIS AND
MEETING
WITH US THROUGHOUT THE YEAR.
UM, UNFORTUNATELY, THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE IN PRINT
NOW AND THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS
PROPOSING,
UH, MAKE THE BILL WORSE FOR US,
UH, IN IN MANY RESPECTS,
UM, IT IS TRUE THAT THEY HAVE
REMOVED
THE FINANCIAL COMPENSATION PIECE
AND THE REMOVAL OF A PROVIDER
FOR NOT
BEING FINANCIALLY COMPENSATED.
WE DO APPRECIATE THAT.
HOWEVER, THAT LANGUAGE IS STILL
SCATTERED
THROUGHOUT THE BILL, UH,
IN AN ATTEMPT TO GET AT NETWORK
ACTIVITY OR WHETHER
A PROVIDER IS ACTIVE WITHIN A
NETWORK,
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT THAT IS
AN THE
THE ACTIVITY IS PROVEN THROUGH
A CONTRACT
AND A CONTRACTUAL RELATIONSHIP
THAT
CAN BE CALLED UP AT ANY TIME.
WE THINK THAT THE BEST WAY TO
APPROACH ACTIVITY AND THESE
GHOST NETWORKS OR INFLATED
NETWORKS IS THROUGH
INCREASED ENFORCEMENT AND BEEFED
UP ENFORCEMENT OF NETWORK
ADEQUACY STANDARDS AND TIMELY
ACCESS TO CARE,
SO THAT WE KNOW THAT HEALTH
PLANS
HAVE AN ACCURATE NETWORK, UH,
FOR PATIENTS TO USE THE THE A
LITTLE THING
ON A PROVIDER DIRECTORY THAT
SAYS,
UH, ACTIVE DOES NOT MEAN
ANYTHING TO A, AN ENROLLEE.
IT DOES NOT SHOW IT DOES NOT
GIVE THEM ANY INFORMATION
OUTSIDE OF WAS THE PHYSICIAN
PAID.
THAT DOESN'T PROVIDE THE
ENROLLEE
WITH ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT THEY WOULD NEED
THE OUT
OF NETWORK RATE PROVISIONS THAT
ARE IN THE BILL
AND THE PAYMENT RATE PROVISIONS
ABSOLVE,
UH, MY, UH, MY HEALTH PLAN
COLLEAGUES OF THEIR, UH,
REQUIREMENT TO MAINTAIN ACCURATE
DIRECTORIES
AS IT REMOVES THE AND STICK.
THAT IS THE EITHER INCENTIVE OR
DISINCENTIVE,
HOWEVER YOU WANT TO VIEW IT,
OF THEM MAINTAINING ACCURATE
INFORMATION
ON THEIR DIRECTORIES BY PAYING
NOT.
WHAT AN OUT-OF-NETWORK RATE
WOULD BE.
BUT WHATEVER THEY CHOOSE TO PAY
AT ANY GIVEN TIME,
WE'VE SEEN, UH,
SITUATIONS SIMILAR TO THIS IN
PREVIOUS
BILLS THROUGHOUT THE YEARS.
AND WE THAT IS THE, UM, THAT IS
THE ACTIVITY
THAT WE BELIEVE WILL HAPPEN.
UH DMHC DOESN'T NEED ANY
ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY
TO IMPROVE PROVIDER DIRECTORIES.
THEY HAVE THAT ABILITY THROUGH,
UH, ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES,
ENHANCED APPEALS,
AGAIN ENFORCING CURRENT LAWS
AROUND NETWORK
ADEQUACY AND TIMELY ACCESS
STANDARDS.
UM, AND FOR THOSE REASONS, UH,
WELL,
AND WHAT I WILL ALSO SAY IS THAT
THIS IS A VERY THIS IS A VERY
TECHNICAL
AND AND SENSITIVE SUBJECT.
THERE IS A LOT AT STAKE AS IT
RELATES TO WHETHER
OR NOT A PERSON IS IN-NETWORK
OUT OF NETWORK.
AND THIS THIS BILL GOES A TOO
FAR IN, IN, IN,
IN REGULATING THAT SPACE WITHOUT
THAT SENSITIVITY.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE WOULD
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE TODAY.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE ONLY.
THANK YOU.
>> MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
JOHN WINGER, ON BEHALF OF
AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS,
WE WOULD ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH CAP.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
>> MR.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS, JOHN
VALENCIA
REPRESENTING VSP VISION.
WE REMAIN OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED.
THANK YOU.
>> RAY SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OB GYN'S DISTRICT
NINE AND THE CALIFORNIA
PODIATRIC
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION.
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> CHLOE SHINN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
>> MR.
CHAIRMAN, MATT BACK,
REPRESENTING THE OSTEOPATHIC
PHYSICIANS
AND SURGEONS OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
>> CHAIR AND MEMBERS KATHY
MOSSBERG,
WITH THE LOCAL HEALTH PLANS OF
CALIFORNIA,
REGRETFULLY REMAINED IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
>> LISA ANN HURT FORSYTH WITH
THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF PAYORS,
ADMINISTRATORS AND NETWORKS,
AS WELL AS
THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
VISION CARE.
PLANS OPPOSE AS AS WRITTEN,
BUT LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR'S
OFFICE OVER THE SUMMER TO KIND
OF TWEAK THE LANGUAGE A BIT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> HI.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHRISTY WEISS,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF DENTAL PLANS AND
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPONENTS?
YOU KNOW, A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO,
I HAD A STAFF MEMBER COME UP
TO ME.
I GUESS THEY KNEW WE WERE GOING
TO DO THIS.
BILL AND THE STAFF MEMBER, UM.
TOLD ME A STORY IN.
THE STAFF MEMBER HAD A LOVED ONE
AND THE STAFF
MEMBER WAS ATTEMPTING TO HELP
THE LOVED
ONE FIND A PROVIDER AND GOT A
HOLD OF THE PLANS
DIRECTORY IN THE PARTICULAR
AREA THAT.
THAT THEY NEEDED A PROVIDER FOR,
AND WENT THROUGH 2 OR 3 PAGES
OF OF PROVIDERS
AND WASN'T ABLE TO SECURE ONE
THAT WAS
AVAILABLE TO PROVIDE ANY
SERVICE.
CALLED THE PLAN.
GOT THE PLAN ON THE PHONE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO.
WHAT PLAN?
WHO THEY SPOKE WITH, BUT THEY
GOT SOMEBODY WHO
PROFESSED TO KNOW WHAT THEY WERE
DOING.
PLAN WENT THROUGH THE LIST AND
COULDN'T FIND ANYBODY
TO PROVIDE THE HEALTH CARE THAT
WAS NEEDED.
AND I THINK IT WAS PRETTY
SERIOUS HEALTH CARE
OR THIS PERSON WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN INVOLVED.
NEXT THING THAT HAPPENED IS
THERE WERE.
THE PLAN DID ULTIMATELY PROVIDE
THREE NAMES
OF PROVIDERS THAT WEREN'T ON
THE LIST.
AND TO THE PLANT'S CREDIT.
PERSON WAS ABLE TO FIND A
PROVIDER
TO PROVIDE THIS LEVEL OF CARE.
I WAS REMINDED OF THIS AS
I LISTENED TO THE TWO OF YOU,
YOU KNOW, SPAT BACK AND FORTH
ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE.
AND I REALIZED YOU EACH HAVE
ISSUES AND YOU
HAVE CONSTITUENCIES THAT YOU
REPRESENT,
BUT NONE OF THAT DOES ANYTHING
TO
HELP THE HEALTH CARE CONSUMER
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FIND
A PROVIDER WHEN THEY NEED ONE.
SO I GUESS WHAT I WOULD ASK YOU
TO DO IS FIGURE OUT A WAY.
IF YOU PUT YOUR HEADS TOGETHER,
FIGURE OUT A WAY.
WHAT IS IT YOU DO YOU ALL NEED
TO DO?
YOUR CONSTITUENTS NEED TO DO
IN ORDER
TO TIMELY CREATE AND MAINTAIN.
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER DATA SO
THAT
PEOPLE WHO NEED ONE CAN FIND
ONE.
NOW, THAT CAN'T POSSIBLY BE
THAT HARD.
YOU KNOW, WE CAN HAVE ISSUES
WITH HEALTH CARE,
WITH NETWORK ADEQUACY RULES.
WE CAN HAVE ISSUES WITH, IF
YOU'RE A PROVIDER,
HOW MANY CONTRACTS YOU HAVE WITH
PLANS AND HOW MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS YOU HAVE TO
RESPOND TO THE DATA
CALLS AND THE DATA ELEMENTS AND
ALL OF THAT.
BUT THERE'S GOT TO BE A WAY TO
RESOLVE THAT.
THERE'S GOT TO BE A UNIFORM.
MAYBE GET EVERYBODY TO AGREE
ON A UNIFORM
WAY TO TO COLLECT DATA AND
REPORT DATA.
SO WE MAKE IT A LITTLE EASIER ON
PROVIDERS TO DO IT,
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND PROVIDERS
ARE UNDERPAID,
AT LEAST IN TERMS OF
REIMBURSEMENT RATES IN
MANY CASES AND OVERWORKED IN
SOME CASES.
AND WE'D ALL RATHER HAVE THEM
SPEND
TIME PROVIDING CARE AS OPPOSED
TO
SUBMITTING REPORTS AND RESPONSES
TO DATA CALLS FROM HEALTH PLANS.
SO THAT'S MY ASK OF YOU.
AND WE DON'T NEGOTIATE
AMENDMENTS
FROM THE DAIS IN THIS COMMITTEE.
UM.
BUT YOU KNOW, THIS ISN'T THE END
OF THE RODEO HERE THIS YEAR.
AND CERTAINLY I'LL BE GONE,
BUT IT MAY BE NOT THE END OF THE
RODEO NEXT YEAR.
I WOULD THINK WE COULD FIGURE
THIS THING
OUT BECAUSE THE CONVERSATION,
IF YOU WEREN'T A PARTY TO IT
AND YOU
WEREN'T ONE OF US SITTING HERE,
YOU WOULD THINK IT WOULD.
IT SOUNDED PRETTY RIDICULOUS.
THAT'S NOT A I'M NOT DENIGRATING
YOUR POSITIONS.
I'M JUST SAYING TO THE OUTSIDE
OBSERVER,
THEY WOULD NOT UNDERSTAND THIS
AROUND
THE KITCHEN TABLE OR THE KITCHEN
COUNTER.
THEY WOULDN'T UNDERSTAND ANY
OF THIS.
SO THAT'S MY SPEECH ON THE
ISSUE.
I'M COUNTING ON YOU TO FIX IT,
AND WE'LL BE HERE TO HELP.
BUT LET ME TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE DAIS
AND SEE IF ANYBODY HAS ANY
QUESTIONS,
COLLEAGUES, QUESTIONS?
COMMENT, COMMENTS, ANYONE?
>> THANK YOU.
UM.
>> I'M.
I AGREE WITH THE CHAIRMAN.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING.
UM, YOU'VE HEARD ME FOR SO MANY
YEARS
AS WELL UP HERE IS THAT, YOU
KNOW,
ONE, WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
PROVIDERS OUT THERE,
AND WE ALL KNOW THAT.
WE DON'T HAVE, YOU KNOW,
ACCESS TO DOCTORS, TO
PROFESSIONALS.
I'VE MENTIONED IT.
I WOULD TAKE MY KIDS TO THE
URGENT CARE INSTEAD
BECAUSE I CAN'T GET INTO A
DOCTOR'S OFFICE.
UM, I TAKE MYSELF TO THE URGENT
CARE.
I DON'T, I DON'T I CAN'T GET TO
A DOCTOR'S OFFICE.
AND, YOU KNOW, THE PROVIDER'S
LIST IS SO
IMPORTANT TO THE PATIENT NEEDING
THAT.
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS THE
RIGHT SOLUTION.
PENALIZING ONE PROVIDER.
THE HEALTH PLAN.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
THE INFORMATION IT NEEDS TO BE.
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO COME
TOGETHER.
AND WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT, I
MEAN,
DOES IT NEED TO BE A PORTAL THAT
YOU ALL JUST HAVE YOUR ADMIN
STAFF
SIGN IN MONTHLY OR QUARTERLY?
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT IS,
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT PROVIDERS
JUMP IN AND OUT OF NETWORKS
FREQUENTLY.
SO IT'S NOT JUST, YOU KNOW,
QUARTERLY,
IT'S NOT ANNUALLY.
IT HAPPENS QUITE A BIT.
UM, BECAUSE I'VE SEEN IT WITH
MY DOCTORS.
THEY MOVE IN AND OUT REALLY
QUICK AND YOU'RE LIKE,
OH, YOU'RE NOT THERE ANYMORE.
OKAY.
NEVER MIND.
I'M GOING TO ANOTHER DOCTOR.
SO I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE
A SOLUTION.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS IS THE
RIGHT ONE.
JUST PENALIZING FOLKS.
UM, THAT REALLY DOESN'T HAVE
THE FULL CONTROL OVER IT,
BUT ALSO INTERVENING BETWEEN
THE PROVIDER
AND THE HEALTH PLANS AND HAVING,
YOU KNOW,
YOU KNOW, SYMBOLS AND AND SHOWN
THAT
THEY ARE IN THE WITH THE HEALTH
PLAN DOESN'T NECESSARILY MEAN
THAT
THEY ARE AVAILABLE EITHER.
I DON'T THINK THAT HELPS WITH
THE PROVIDERS.
AND SO I THINK THERE NEEDS TO
BE A SOLUTION EVENTUALLY.
BUT I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT QUITE A BIT ALREADY UP
HERE.
UM, I THINK IT'S TIME WE GOT TO
FIND A SOLUTION.
I APPRECIATE THE ASSESSMENT,
ASSEMBLYMAN,
CONTINUOUSLY MAKING SURE THIS
IS THE FOREFRONT
AND THAT'S ALWAYS IN THE
CONVERSATION
AND THAT WE STRIVE TO GET THERE.
BUT I THINK IT'S GOING TO HAVE
TO BE AS EVERYBODY'S
GOT TO COME TOGETHER AND COME
A SOLUTION.
WE'RE IN.
TECHNOLOGY IS RIGHT IN FRONT
OF US.
I MEAN, WE WE CAN HAVE
EVERYTHING ON THE PHONE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE THAT WE CAN'T
GET.
THE YELLOW PAGES ON OUR PHONE.
WITH THE PROVIDERS, WE CAN HAVE
EVERYTHING ELSE.
SO I THINK THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY
AND I HOPE THAT, YOU KNOW, UM,
YOU CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR, UH,
BECAUSE AT THE END OF THE DAY,
YOU YOURSELF ALSO WANT.
THE INFORMATION ACCURATE FOR
YOUR FAMILY AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
>> ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR MAYBE THE
SPONSORS.
CAN YOU GIVE IT TO ME AS IF
WE WERE
AT A KITCHEN DINNER TABLE?
THE PROCESS.
I THINK WE ALL AGREE SOMETHING
HAS TO HAPPEN.
I THINK ALL OF US HAVE A
PERSONAL STORY WE CAN SHARE
BECAUSE WE ARE ENCOUNTERING THE
SAME THING.
UM, IF YOU CAN WALK ME THROUGH
BECAUSE
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE, UM,
UTILIZING SOME OF THE STUFF THAT
THE OPPOSITION
HAS MENTIONED REGARDING, UM,
DO YOU SEE IT DIFFERENTLY IN
THE STEPS THAT IF SOMEONE GOES
THROUGH OUT OF THE NETWORK
AND SEES SOMEBODY THAT THEY,
THAT PROVIDER WILL NOT GET
REIMBURSED
AT THE RATE THAT THEY
SHOULD BE POTENTIALLY DECREASING
THE RATES ALL AROUND THEM?
UM, AND HOW YOU SEE THE
ENFORCEMENT
PART IN LAYMAN'S TERMS,
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE FROM A TO
B, A TO Z, I GUESS.
YOU DO IT, AND I'LL GIVE MY
SPIN ON.
THE, UM, ON THE.
ENFORCEMENT PIECE.
UM, THE THE WAY THAT THIS WOULD
WORK
IS THAT WE HAVE ANNUAL
BENCHMARKS.
UM, AND SO THAT'S A REQUIREMENT
STARTING IN JULY OF 2025,
THAT THE HEALTH PLAN PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES
WOULD HAVE TO BE 60% ACCURATE,
AND THAT WOULD BE ANNUALLY
INCREASING
UP TO THAT 95% MARK IN 2028.
UM, AND THERE IS, UM,
SPECIFICATIONS IN THE BILL
AROUND, UM,
HOW THE DEPARTMENT WOULD
DETERMINE
THAT ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY
IF THERE WAS A FAILURE TO MEET
THOSE BENCHMARKS.
UM, WE FEEL THAT THAT,
LIKE THE 60% PLACE IS A IS A
PLACE TO START.
UM, AND BUT WE CAN HOLD FOLKS
ACCOUNTABLE TO,
UM, A WAY TO IMPROVE.
AND PENALTY TO THE HEALTH PLANS.
YES.
OKAY.
IT'S A PENALTY TO THE HEALTH
PLANS.
UM, IF THEY FAIL TO MEET THOSE
BENCHMARKS, UM,
AND THE WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, UM,
THEY THE INACCURACIES THAT WOULD
BE COUNTED AS NOT IN THAT,
UM, IN THAT PERCENTAGE OF
ACCURACY,
THEY WOULD HAVE TO HAVE AN
IMPACT ON PATIENT CARE.
AND SO IF WE'RE TALKING AND
THAT WOULD
BE DETERMINED BY THE DEPARTMENT,
WHICH KIND OF INACCURACIES WOULD
HAVE AN IMPACT ON PATIENT CARE.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT SOME
ERRORS,
LIKE A TYPO FOR ONE
OF THEM LIKE THAT COULD NOT
IMPACT PATIENT CARE.
LIKE, UM, LIKE MAYBE A
DIFFERENCE
IN SOMEONE'S NAME OR SOMETHING.
BUT IF THERE'S A TYPO IN THE
ADDRESS
AND THE PERSON CAN'T FIND THE
PLACE TO GO,
OR THE PHONE NUMBER IS WRONG
AND THEY'RE
CALLING AND THEY CAN'T REACH
THE DOCTOR,
LIKE THAT'S A TYPO THAT MATTERS,
UM,
FOR SOMEONE'S ACCESS TO CARE.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
APPRECIATE.
THE COMMITTEE, UM,
WORKING ON AND IS IN THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
UM, AND AS WELL, UM, FOR
PURPOSES
OF ENFORCEMENT, UM,
THERE IS LANGUAGE IN THE
COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AROUND IF
THE HEALTH PLANS ARE USING THE
CENTRAL
THE CENTRAL UTILITY THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT,
THE DATABASE, THAT WOULD BE, UM,
THAT THERE ARE THESE EXISTING
SYSTEMS
OR THAT WHERE A PROVIDER COULD
UPDATE THEIR INFORMATION FOR
THEIR
CONTRACTED HEALTH PLANS,
THAT THAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED BY
THE DEPARTMENT WHEN
THEY'RE DECIDING HOW MUCH IN THE
LEVYING THE FINES,
AND ALSO LIKE THEIR PROCESS
AND THE WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE.
UM, AND SO THEY CAN DOCUMENT
THIS IS THIS IS
THE WORK WE'VE DONE TO IMPROVE
ACCURACY.
IS THIS A POTENTIAL ACCURATE
POSSIBILITY
IF THE HEALTH PLANS GET THIS
FINE.
UM, THE CLIENT PATIENT GOES OUT
OF NETWORK,
THEN THE HEALTH PLAN HAS THE
ABILITY TO REIMBURSE
THAT PROVIDER AT ANY RATE THEY
CHOOSE.
AND BECAUSE THEY GOT A FINE,
THEY'RE GOING TO SAY,
HEY, I NEED TO OFFSET THAT.
FINE.
I'M GOING TO REIMBURSE THE
PROVIDER AT
A LOWER RATE TO MAKE MYSELF
WHOLE.
UM, THERE'S SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN
THE BILL THAT SAYS THAT THE
FINES
CANNOT BE PASSED ON TO THE
PROVIDERS,
UM, OR THE ENROLLEE.
MR.
CHAIR, CAN I HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITE?
OKAY.
UH.
THE LANGUAGE THAT IS CURRENTLY
IN
THE BILL SAYS THAT THE THAT THE
PROVIDER
CANNOT PAY THE THE FINE THAT IS
ASSESSED ON THE HEALTH PLAN,
AND THEN THE LANGUAGE THAT IS
BEING OFFERED
TODAY BY THE COMMITTEE SAYS THAT
THE CONTRACTS BETWEEN THE HEALTH
PLAN
AND THE PROVIDER CAN CONTAIN
FINES,
FEES, DISCIPLINARY ACTION OR
WHAT HAVE YOU IN ORDER TO,
UH, GET THAT INFORMATION FROM
THE,
FROM THE PROVIDER SO THAT THAT'S
AT
LEAST THAT'S WHAT I UNDERSTAND
THE,
THE THE LANGUAGE TO BE DOING
TODAY.
MR..
IF I COULD TO I YOU KNOW, WE
HAVE TO PUT
THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF THE FIRST
BILL
THAT WAS PUT FORWARD TO
ESTABLISH THESE
DIRECTORIES WAS OVER TEN YEARS
AGO.
RIGHT.
SO WHAT HAVE WE BEEN WAITING
FOR?
YOU KNOW, IT'S TO THE CHAIRMAN'S
POINT AND THE VICE CHAIRS POINT.
YOU KNOW, WHILE WE'RE WAITING,
PEOPLE ARE GETTING.
REFERRED TO GO OUT AND GET
ADDITIONAL HEALTH SUPPORT.
SO THEY TURN TO THIS DIRECTORY
THAT IN THEIR MIND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ACROSS THE
KITCHEN TABLE
THAT THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO
SPEND ALL DAY GOING
THROUGH IT BEFORE THEY GET
SOMEONE TO RESPOND.
IF THEY GO THROUGH A WHOLE DAY
AND GET SOMEONE TO RESPOND.
WHY IS IT THAT BAD?
NOW.
THE 60.
PERCENT.
UM, IS BASICALLY LOOKING AT THIS
FROM THE STANDPOINT
THAT WE'RE RECOGNIZING THAT MOST
OF THESE PROVIDERS,
MOST OF THESE PLANS ARE ALREADY
AT
THAT LEVEL FOR THE MOST PART.
THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE LOW,
AND THEN THERE ARE SOME THAT
ARE HIGHER.
AND SO IF I WERE THEM AND THIS
BILL WERE TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE BEFORE WE GET
TO 2025,
WHICH THEN THEY STILL HAVE THAT
PERIOD
OF TIME TO GET UP TO THAT 60%,
THAT THIS IS THE TIME THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE ALREADY BEEN AT 80,
BUT THEY STILL HAVE ENOUGH TIME
TO BE ABLE TO THEN ADD,
SAY YOU'RE AT 30 NOW.
SO BEFORE 2025, THAT MEANS YOU
HAVE
TO GET UP TO ANOTHER 30%
INCREASE.
WELL, WE HAVE IN THE BILL IF
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO.
ORGANIZE AND FIGURE THIS OUT
AMONGST THEMSELVES.
WE HAVE A CENTRAL UTILITY
OPTION.
THEY CAN USE IT OR THEY DON'T
HAVE TO USE IT,
BUT AT LEAST IT'S TESTED TO BE
ABLE TO SHOW THAT
IT CAN DO THE ACCURACY AT THE
LEVEL
THAT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE,
AND YOU START TO SEE PROGRESS.
AND SO WE DIDN'T PUT PENALTIES
ON TOP OF THEM AS
SOON AS THIS BILL IS PASSED AND
GOES INTO LAW.
THEY STILL HAVE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET TO JUST THAT,
THAT BASIC BASELINE 60.
REALLY, IT SHOULD BE 100.
AND EVEN THE TOP NUMBER IS 95%,
SO WE'RE NOT EVEN GRINDING THEM
TO 100.
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT THERE
MAY BE
SOME EBB AND FLOWS IN IN
DYNAMICS.
WE HAVE SET, WE'VE SET DOWN,
AS WE SAID, FOR OVER A YEAR.
AND THEN WE'VE ALSO IN RECENT
JUST IN THE LAST WEEK OR SO.
HAVE TAKEN A LITANY.
OF AMENDMENTS AND WE'RE NOT
STOPPING THERE.
IF THERE'S SOME FINE TUNING OR
TWEAKING
ON WORDS THAT WE NEED TO
EVALUATE,
WE'RE HAPPY TO DO THAT.
BUT THE WHOLE IDEA IS.
FAMILY MEMBERS ARE SITTING
AND TRYING TO COLLECTIVELY
FIGURE OUT FOR THEIR LOVED ONE
WHAT'S NEXT?
HOW DO WE HELP THEM GET TO A
PHYSICIAN TO
HELP THEM ADDRESS THEIR UNIQUE
ISSUES?
AND YOU CAN'T FIND ONE.
AND AS WAS POINTED OUT, THEY'RE
NOT FOLLOWING
THESE LEGISLATIVE DEBATES.
THEY'RE NOT FOLLOWING WHAT'S
GOING ON
HERE OR IN WASHINGTON OR
WHEREVER.
THEY ARE, JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND
HOW TO MEET A CRISIS MOMENT.
WITH A DIRECTORY THAT ON THE
FIRST CALL SHOULD
GIVE THEM THE ANSWERS THAT THEY
NEED.
THEY SHOULD BE GOING DOWN FIVE
AND HAVE FIVE CHOICES.
THAT'S NOT WHERE IT'S AT.
AND FROM THE TIME THAT THE
DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTH CARE.
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO EVALUATE
AND TO TO ENFORCE.
THERE WERE ONLY FIVE.
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS.
THAT PRODUCED VERY SMALL FINES.
SO THERE'S NO THERE'S NO
INCENTIVE.
THERE'S NO PRESSURE.
SO HERE WE ARE TEN YEARS LATER,
AND WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE
IT OUT TO CREATE URGENCY WITHOUT
BEING UNFAIR.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT
THIS
BILL IS ATTEMPTING TO DO.
AND WE CONTINUE TO BE OPEN TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS TO FIND
OUT WHAT ADDITIONAL LANGUAGE
CAN OR SHOULD BE TAKEN TO,
TO CAUSE THE PLANS TO FEEL
A LITTLE BIT MORE COMFORTABLE.
BUT WE'VE COME A LONG WAY.
AND SO.
THAT'S MY $0.02.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS, COLLEAGUES?
SARAH NGUYEN.
>> I HAVE A QUESTION TO THE
HEALTH PLANS.
IDEALLY, HOW WOULD THIS WORK?
BECAUSE YOU ULTIMATELY HOLD THAT
INFORMATION, RIGHT?
I MEAN, YOU'RE THE ONE WHO
PROVIDES THAT INFORMATION.
SO I'M GOING TO I'M GOING TO
ASSUME
PROVIDERS GIVE YOU THE
INFORMATION.
YOU PUT TOGETHER THE PACKAGE
AND IT'S DISPERSED ANNUALLY.
RIGHT.
UM, WHAT DOES IT NEED TO BE DONE
QUARTERLY?
WHAT WHAT CAN I MEAN, IDEALLY,
WHAT WOULD MAKE IT SO THAT IT
WOULD WORK?
YEAH.
THANK YOU, MADAM VICE CHAIR.
SO A COUPLE OF DIFFERENT PARTS
TO THAT ANSWER.
I WILL START BY SAYING YES.
AS THE HEALTH PLANS, WE ARE
THE HOLDER OF THE DIRECTORY.
THAT IS CORRECT.
NOW WE WE THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
PERIODICALLY
SEND OUT, YOU KNOW,
SURVEY DATA COLLECTION TO OUR
CONTRACTED
PROVIDERS TO TO RECEIVE THAT
INFORMATION BACK SO WE CAN
UPDATE
OUR DIRECTORIES ACCORDINGLY.
YOU KNOW, AGAIN, I THINK MY
MEMBER HEALTH
PLANS HAVE TOLD ME, YOU KNOW,
THE CHALLENGE OFTENTIMES IS
GETTING
DATA BACK FROM THE PROVIDERS.
SO IT'S ONE OF THOSE SITUATIONS,
RIGHT,
WHERE WE MAY ULTIMATELY HOLD
THE DIRECTORY
IF WE'RE NOT GETTING, YOU KNOW,
ACCURATE OR TIMELY INFORMATION
BACK
FROM OUR CONTRACTED PROVIDERS,
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO UPDATE
THE PROVIDER
DIRECTOR DIRECTORY ACCURATELY.
SO I MEAN THAT THAT HAS PROVEN
TO BE A CHALLENGE AGAIN,
TO TO TO THE AUTHOR'S POINT,
I THINK,
YOU KNOW, WE DO SEE PROMISE IN
THAT CENTRAL UTILITY,
YOU KNOW, AS A CLEARINGHOUSE
WHEREBY,
YOU KNOW, PLANS AND PROVIDERS
CAN PULL
AND UPDATE INFORMATION, UM,
YOU KNOW,
SO SO WE'RE ALL KIND OF FEEDING
INTO THE SAME MECHANISM, RIGHT?
AND BEING ABLE TO GET THAT
INFORMATION ACCURATELY.
SO I THINK, YOU KNOW, WE, I
THINK THAT THAT THAT
IS A POSITIVE STEP FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE.
UM, SO THAT WE'RE NOT INUNDATING
PROVIDERS WITH,
YOU KNOW, A VARIETY OF NOTICES,
EMAILS, PHONE CALLS, ETC., YOU
KNOW,
AND TRYING TO GET THAT
INFORMATION.
BECAUSE, AGAIN, THERE ARE A LOT
OF FACTORS THAT GO INTO THAT.
I MEAN, IT'S WHETHER THE NUMBER
CHANGES THAT'S
GOT TO BE UPDATED IN THE
DIRECTORY.
IF A NAME CHANGES, UPDATED IN
THE DIRECTORY,
ADDRESS CHANGES,
UPDATED IN THE DIRECTORY,
ARE THEY TAKING NEW PATIENTS,
ALL OF THOSE FACTORS YOU NEED
TO GET
ALL OF THAT INFORMATION YOU KNOW
EVERY 90 DAYS AND AN UPDATE
THE PROVIDER DIRECTORS
ACCORDINGLY.
SO AGAIN I THINK FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE
IT IS A CHALLENGE TO GET SOME OF
THAT INFORMATION CONSISTENTLY
AND TIMELY OR WHEN A CHANGE
IS MADE.
AND TO MY MY PROVIDER COLLEAGUES
POINT,
I MEAN I THINK I UNDERSTAND THAT
CAN BE CHALLENGING IF YOU'RE
HAVING
IF YOU'RE GETTING NOTICES FROM,
YOU KNOW, FIVE, TEN, 12 PLANTS
THAT
YOU'RE CONTRACTED WITH EVERY
TIME YOU CHANGE YOUR TELEPHONE
NUMBER OR CHANGE YOUR NAME.
SO I CERTAINLY THINK THERE'S A
PATHWAY THERE,
POTENTIALLY WITH THE CENTRAL
UTILITY WHEREBY PLANS
CAN DRAW FROM IT, PROVIDERS CAN
ENTER INTO IT.
AND WE'RE ALL KIND OF OPERATING
FROM THE SAME,
FROM THE SAME SYSTEM, I WOULD
SAY.
AND AGAIN, I THINK IN THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE AND
THE SPONSORS,
WE'VE BEEN, YOU KNOW,
FAIRLY SUPPORTIVE OF THAT
CONCEPT.
BUT WE DO NEED ALL STAKEHOLDER
BUY IN FOR THAT TO WORK.
AND AND WE DO NEED, AS THE
HEALTH PLANS,
SAFE HARBOR PROTECTIONS WHEREBY
IF WE PULL INFORMATION
FROM THAT CENTRAL DIRECTORY
AND THAT
INFORMATION WAS ENTERED
INCORRECTLY,
THAT THAT THAT WE ARE HELD
LIABLE BECAUSE
THE BILL ESSENTIALLY FINDS THE
PLANS,
WE ARE THE ONES THAT ARE BEING
FINED IN
THIS CURRENT ITERATION OF THE
BILL,
UM, FOR NOT MEETING THE
BENCHMARKS.
SO IF, IF WE'RE IN GOOD FAITH.
UPDATING OUR PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES,
GETTING THAT INFORMATION
AND THAT INFORMATION IS WRONG.
WE BELIEVE THAT WE NEED A SAFE
HARBOR PROTECTION
IN THERE TO ENSURE THAT, YOU
KNOW,
WE ARE ACTING IN GOOD FAITH IN
USING THE CENTRAL UTILITY TO
UPDATE OUR PROVIDER DIRECTORS
DIRECTORIES ACCORDINGLY.
AND.
TO THE PROVIDER.
I MEAN, HOW I MEAN, WHAT'S THE
IDEAL WAY
FOR YOU TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION?
I MEAN, IT REALLY ULTIMATELY
COMES
TO YOU BECAUSE YOU HAVE
THE INFORMATION AND YOU'RE THE
ONE
WHO WE WANT TO GET ACCESS TO.
YEAH.
UM, SO I WOULD AGREE WITH A LOT
OF THE POINTS FROM BOTH.
I MEAN, FROM BOTH THE SUPPORTERS
AND,
AND MY COLLEAGUE,
IT'S, IT IS BRINGING TECHNOLOGY
INTO THE SYSTEM.
RIGHT.
A LOT OF TIMES WE GET THESE
REQUESTS FOR INFORMATION
VIA SNAIL MAIL TO THE TO A SMALL
PRACTICE DOES HAVE UPWARDS OF
11 TO 12
CONTRACTS WITH DIFFERENT HEALTH
PLANS.
RIGHT.
SO WE'RE RECEIVING THOSE ON A
CONSTANTLY RIGHT NOW.
UM, WHAT WE BELIEVE IS THAT
THE CREDENTIALING PROCESS AND,
AND THE EXCHANGE OF INFORMATION
AND WHERE
THAT BULK EXCHANGE OF
INFORMATION
IS HAPPENING IS A GREAT WAY
TO GET
THAT INFORMATION IN THE DOOR.
A LOT OF MY PROVIDERS ARE USING
IT'S
NOT QUITE A CENTRAL UTILITY.
I THINK OF IT SORT OF AS A DATA
CLEARINGHOUSE IN WHICH
THEY UPLOAD THEIR INFORMATION
INTO THIS SYSTEM.
THEY HAVE TO GO IN AND ATTEST TO
ITS ACCURACY EVERY QUARTER.
WHY WE CAN'T START PULLING AND
ENCOURAGING
AND COLLABORATING ON THAT.
AND OPENING UP THOSE LINES OF
COMMUNICATION
IS IS EXTREMELY, UH,
IS THAT'S THE WAY THAT WE THINK
THAT
WE SHOULD GO ABOUT DOING THIS.
RIGHT.
BUT THE, THE THAT IS THE WAY
IN WHICH
WE THINK THAT THIS SHOULD WORK.
NOW, I MEAN, TO THE CHAIR STORY
I HAVE MY FORMER PRESIDENT
HASN'T HAS SINCE RETIRED FROM
PRACTICE.
HE, UH, CLOSED HIS PRACTICE.
HE HAS ASKED TO BE REMOVED FROM
HIS PROVIDER DIRECTORY FOR
SINCE HE LEFT FOR THREE YEARS,
AND HE IS STILL ON IT.
HE HAS ASKED THREE TIMES.
UH, AND HE IS STILL ON HIS
PROVIDER DIRECTORY.
SO THERE IS THERE IS A THERE'S
A PROBLEM HERE.
WE DO NOT DENY THAT.
BUT THERE IS AN EASIER WAY TO
FACILITATE THAT
EXCHANGE OF INFORMATION AND
ENCOURAGE IT.
UM, THAT'S HOW THAT'S HOW WE
WOULD SEE IT.
THANK YOU.
WELL, MY MY TAKE ON THIS IS
THERE'S
A LOT OF STUFF TO GO AROUND
HERE.
PLANS HAVE TO MAINTAIN ADEQUATE
NETWORKS.
SO THEY DON'T WANT TO FIRE YOUR
PROVIDERS
WHO DON'T PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION,
BECAUSE THEN THEY JUST
JEOPARDIZE THEIR STATUS
AS A PLAN BECAUSE THE NETWORK'S
INADEQUATE.
AND YOUR PROVIDERS, OF COURSE,
HAVE TO PROVIDE A BUNCH OF
INFORMATION
THROUGH A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
PORTALS
AND A VARIETY OF FORMATS.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE DATA
POINTS AREN'T
AREN'T THE SAME FROM PLAN TO
PLAN TO PLAN.
AND SO THAT CREATES A BURDEN.
SO THERE'S REALLY A LOT OF BLAME
TO GO AROUND.
AND THEN INSTEAD OF FIGURING
THIS THING OUT, I MEAN,
THE PROBLEM COMES HERE FOR US
TO SOLVE.
AND THAT'S WHAT'S GETTING TO ME
A LITTLE BIT.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT YOU ALL,
AS REPRESENTATIVES OF LARGE
ORGANIZATIONS
WITH A VARIETY OF MEMBERS,
COULD COME TOGETHER AT A TABLE
AND FIGURE THIS OUT,
AND YOU WOULDN'T NEED THE PEOPLE
TO YOUR RIGHT
BECAUSE YOU COULD DO IT
YOURSELVES.
MAKE IT EASY ON PROVIDERS.
GET THE INFORMATION TO THE PLANS
THAT THE PLANS NEED TO PROVIDE
TO CONSUMERS WHO DEPEND ON
NETWORK
NOT ONLY NETWORK ADEQUACY,
BUT THE ACCURACY OF THE
INFORMATION
REGARDING THE NETWORKS.
I DON'T QUITE SEE HOW YOU COULD
EVER HAVE TIMELY INFORMATION
ON WHETHER YOU'RE ACCEPTING NEW
PATIENTS,
BECAUSE I WOULD IMAGINE THAT
CHANGES
OR COULD CHANGE FROM DAY TO DAY,
FROM WEEK TO WEEK, CERTAINLY
FROM MONTH TO MONTH.
SO THAT INFORMATION AND THAT
DATA POINT.
MAY OR MAY NOT BE WORTHLESS,
DEPENDING ON WHO
YOU'RE TALKING TO AND WHAT
YOU'RE LOOKING AT.
SO I MEAN, THAT'S MY POINT.
I THINK YOU ALL OUGHT TO BE
GETTING TOGETHER
AND WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO DO
IT HERE.
BECAUSE IF WE HAD MORE TIME FOR
THIS HEARING LONGER
THAN WE'VE TAKEN ON THIS
PARTICULAR POINT,
WE COULD SIT HERE AND WE COULD
WORK
IT OUT FOR YOU AT THE TABLE.
AND OUR OUR SOLUTION MIGHT NOT
BE
THE OPTIMUM ONE FOR YOU ALL.
SO THAT'S SORT OF MY REQUEST.
DID YOU WANT TO SAY SOMETHING,
SIR?
NO.
WHAT I WILL SAY IS THAT HERE YOU
ARE SEEING THAT PLAY OUT.
YES, ABSOLUTELY.
BUT IN IN SINCE THE,
SINCE THE BILL IN 2015 HAS HAS
BEEN IMPLEMENTED
AND THESE PROVIDER DIRECTORIES
HAVE
BEEN A THING WE HAVE PARTNERS
WITH,
WE HAVE PARTNERED WITH OUR
HEALTH
PLANS INDIVIDUALLY AND WITH
THE ASSOCIATIONS IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE
WEBINARS IN ORDER TO PROVIDE.
WE'VE EVEN DONE IT AS PART OF
A CME PROGRAM.
WE HAVE BEEN DOING THESE TYPES
OF THINGS AND ENCOURAGING BOTH
PROVIDERS AND THE HEALTH PLANS
TO WORK COLLECTIVELY.
THIS IS WHAT YOU'RE SEEING AHEAD
IS IS MY POINT, RIGHT?
AND WHAT I'M SEEING IS, I MEAN,
I DON'T KNOW THE CENTRAL
UTILITY,
BUT YOU COULD YOU COULD ARRIVE
ON ON A PORTAL,
YOU COULD ARRIVE ON AGREED UPON
DATA POINTS.
THERE'S A BUNCH OF PLANS
LIMITING THOSE
DATA POINTS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE,
AND THEN THEY COULD TURN TO
THEIR
CONTRACTED PROVIDERS AND SAY,
HERE'S THE DEAL, HERE'S WHAT
WE WANT,
AND WE WANT IT EVERY 90 DAYS
OR WHATEVER THE RULE IS.
AND BY THE WAY, MY THE BRAINS
OF THE OPERATION,
MY COMMITTEE STAFF PROVIDED
ME WITH
THE SOME LANGUAGE ON ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS.
AND I'M SURE YOU ALL SAW IT,
WHICH ESSENTIALLY SAYS THE
DEPARTMENT OF DIRECTOR
SHALL TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES THAT HAVE BEEN
ESTABLISHED TO OBTAIN ACCURATE
PROVIDER
INFORMATION AND THE INSURERS USE
OF A CENTRAL UTILITY IN
ASSESSING PENALTIES
PURSUANT TO THE SECTION.
SO USE A CENTRAL UTILITY THAT
WE CALL IT CENTRAL UTILITY.
AND YOU HAVE POLICIES THAT ARE
DESIGNED
FOR LIMITED DATA POINTS,
INFORMATION TO PROVIDERS.
UM, YOU'RE PROBABLY NOT GOING
TO BE PENALIZED.
SO WHY DON'T YOU ALL GET TO WORK
ON IT AFTER THIS HEARING?
AND I WON'T BE HERE AFTER
DECEMBER 1ST,
BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU I WILL
TUNE IN TO
SEE THE NEXT TIME THIS ISSUE
COMES UP.
IF YOU FIX THE PROBLEM.
ANYTHING ELSE?
COLLEAGUES?
OTHERWISE, UH, CHAIRMAN.
I DON'T RECOMMEND THAT YOU TUNE
IN.
SIMILAR.
I DON'T SEE ANY OTHER.
HANDS UP.
SO MAYBE YOU SHOULD CLOSE TO.
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
I DON'T THINK I COULD ARCHITECT
A BETTER CLOSE THAN THE ONE THAT
YOU'VE LAID OUT.
UM, I WAS TALKING TO MY STAFF
BEFORE THIS HEARING BEGAN.
I SAID THERE SHOULD NOT BE
A NEED FOR A BILL LIKE THIS.
UM, THERE HAS BEEN ENOUGH TIME,
ENOUGH UNDERSTANDING OF HOW IT'S
FLAWED TO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PUT
SOMETHING TOGETHER BY NOW.
THAT WORKS.
UH, FROM THE TIME THAT THE BILL
CAME OUT TO NOW, UH, WE'VE HAD,
UH, A ROVER LAUNCHED ACROSS
THE THE GALAXY LANDING ON MARS,
SENDING BACK PICTURES, TELLING
US
ABOUT WHAT'S ON THE MARS PLANET.
AND WE CAN'T FIGURE OUT A
DIRECTORY.
IT'S HARD TO TO IMAGINE THAT,
BUT, WELL.
MAYBE THE ROVER CAN DO IT FOR
US.
TOUCHE.
UM, THE BOTTOM LINE TO THIS BILL
IS ACCESS TO CARE.
AND WHEN YOU HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE
WHO ARE CAUGHT IN THIS WEB,
UH, IT'S NOT THEIR FAULT.
AND I'M NOT GOING TO SAY IT'S
FULLY
THE FAULT OF THOSE WHO ARE
TRYING
TO FIGURE IT OUT ON THEIR AND IN
THEIR WAY OF OF DOING THAT.
UM, BUT IN THE GAP OF ALL THAT.
IS A BILL HERE THAT I THINK CAN
SET SOME PARAMETERS,
ESTABLISH EFFECTIVE URGENCY.
AND WITH THE MECHANISM OUT THERE
TO BE UTILIZED,
START TO SEE SOME PROGRESS.
AND SO WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE WHEN YOU GET A
QUORUM.
AS SOON AS WE ESTABLISH A
QUORUM,
WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND WE'LL
DO JUST THAT.
FOR THOSE OF YOU AT THE TABLE,
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
THANKS FOR PUTTING UP WITH ME.
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY.
WELL, LET'S NOW TURN TO
SOMETHING EASY.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB 3129.
SOME MEMBER WOULD.
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION.
PROCEED WHEN READY, SIR.
MAYBE MY COLLEAGUES WILL COME
DOWN FOR THIS.
>> OR HOPEFULLY SOMEBODY'S
LISTENING SOMEWHERE.
HOPE SO.
APPRECIATE YOUR OPTIMISM ON THIS
TOO AS WELL.
APPRECIATE THAT.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, AND GOOD
AFTERNOON.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
FOR HIS
THOUGHTFUL ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND FOR THE
COMMITTEE
STAFF'S SIGNIFICANT EFFORT.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY.
ALSO, WHILE SHE'S NOT HERE,
I WANT TO THANK SENATOR HURTADO.
I'M PROUD TO ADD HER AS A
PRINCIPAL
CO-AUTHOR TO THE BILL.
WHAT IS BEFORE YOU TODAY IS A
PRODUCT OF MANY HOURS
OF DISCUSSION WITH COMMITTEES
AND STAKEHOLDERS.
AB 3001 29 IS A BILL TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES,
OUR PATIENTS AND ALL HEALTH CARE
CONSUMERS
FROM POTENTIALLY NEGATIVE
IMPACTS OF PRIVATE
EQUITY TRANSACTIONS IN HEALTH
CARE.
THE GOAL OF THIS BILL IS TO
PROTECT
THE PUBLIC BY ENSURING
COMPATIBLE ACCESS.
HEALTH MARKETS.
HEALTH CARE MARKETS.
PRIVATE EQUITY INVESTMENT IN
HEALTH CARE HAS INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE PAST TWO
DECADES.
PRIVATE EQUITY INVESTMENT IN
HEALTH
CARE IN 2021 TOTALED $83
BILLION,
AND $20 BILLION OF THAT WAS IN
CALIFORNIA.
COMPARED THAT TO 12,000,000,001
BILLION, RESPECTIVELY, IN 2005.
THERE IS SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE
THAT PRIVATE EQUITY
INVESTMENT ACROSS ALL OUTCOME
MEASURES HAS MOST
OFTEN INCREASED COST TO PATIENTS
OR PAYERS,
AND HAD MIXED TO HARMFUL IMPACTS
ON QUALITY.
PRIVATE EQUITIES TIMELINES ARE
SHORT,
OFTEN 3 TO 7 YEARS.
THE TRANSACTIONS OFTEN USE 60
TO 80% DEBT TO FINANCE THESE,
WHICH THEN SHIFTS THE BURDEN
SHIFTS
AS A BURDEN TO THE ENTITY.
FOLLOWED BY THE INVESTORS
PROCESS
OF RESTRUCTURING IN
ORDER TO MAKE IT MORE ATTRACTIVE
FOR FUTURE BUYERS.
THAT RESTRUCTURING CAN INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE NEGATIVELY
IMPACT PATIENTS AND HEALTH CARE
WORKERS,
INCLUDING REDUCING STAFF,
REPLACING STAFF WITH LOWER COST
STAFF,
SELLING ASSETS AND LIMITING
SERVICES
PROVIDED SUCH AS MATERNITY,
LABOR AND DELIVERY, AND
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE.
IN MAY OF THIS YEAR.
STEWARD HEALTH CARE, THE
STRUGGLING HEALTH
CARE PROVIDER PROVIDER THAT
RELIED ON
PRIVATE EQUITY TO ACQUIRE ITS
HOSPITALS IN TEXAS,
FLORIDA AND MASSACHUSETTS.
I BELIEVE THERE ARE 22 HOSPITALS
IN ALL,
MOST OF THEM IN SMALL HOSPITALS
AND RURAL COMMUNITIES FILED
FOR CHAPTER 11 BANKRUPTCY.
THEY WERE IN TREMENDOUS DEBT,
ABOUT $1.2 BILLION.
STEWARD HEALTH CARE WAS FOUNDED
IN 2010 WHEN
THE PRIVATE EQUITY FIRM CERBERUS
CAPITAL MANAGEMENT
BOUGHT OUT THE FAILING CARITAS
CHRISTI
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM IN
MASSACHUSETTS.
CERBERUS.
EXCUSE ME.
OWNED THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
FROM
ABOUT 2010 TO TO ABOUT 2020.
IT'S TEN YEAR IN ITS TEN YEAR
OWNERSHIP.
THEY MADE ABOUT $800 MILLION OFF
ITS INVESTMENT IN STEWART
WHILE THE HOSPITAL SYSTEM FELL
FURTHER INTO DEBT.
THOSE HOSPITALS ARE NOW AT RISK
FOR CLOSURE AND EVEN
MORE THAN THEY WERE BEFORE THE
ACQUISITION.
THIS IS JUST ONE TROUBLING
EXAMPLE.
IS MAKING SOMETHING MORE
EFFICIENT BAD?
NO, BUT WHEN PRIVATE EQUITY
EQUITY PURCHASES
SEVERAL PRACTICES OR HOSPITALS
IN A REGION,
ESPECIALLY IN MORE RURAL AREAS,
IT CAN CREATE A MONOPOLY.
THAT USES LEVERAGE TO NEGOTIATE
HIGHER FEES WITH HEALTH PLANS,
IN TURN INCREASES HEALTH CARE
PREMIUMS TO EMPLOYERS
AND EMPLOYEES AND TO THE COST
OF HEALTH CARE.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT PREVENT THESE
TRANSACTIONS.
BUT IT ALLOWS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO REVIEW
THEM FOR WHAT HAS BECOME WELL
DOCUMENTED.
DISADVANTAGES OF PRIVATE EQUITY
IN HEALTH CARE.
YOU KNOW ME, I HOPE I'M A HEALTH
CARE
PROVIDER WHO HAS FOUGHT FOR
INCREASED
ACCESS TO QUALITY AND AFFORDABLE
HEALTH
CARE FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS,
AND I'VE DUG INTO THESE ISSUES
DEEPLY,
WHICH WHICH WAS MUCH THOUGHT AND
COMMITMENT.
I'VE TAKEN ON TOUGH ISSUES,
AND I'M WILLING TO FIGHT FOR
WHAT I BELIEVE IS IN THE
PATIENT'S BEST INTEREST.
I'M DATA DRIVEN, AND THE DATA
SHOWS
THAT OVERSIGHT IS NEEDED.
WHY?
BECAUSE THERE CURRENTLY IS NONE.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THAT
OVERSIGHT,
AND I'VE WORKED CLOSELY WITH
ATTORNEY GENERAL BONTA,
THE CHAIR, AND MANY
STAKEHOLDERS,
INCLUDING THOSE OPPOSED, TO MAKE
THIS A GOOD BILL.
MANY HANDS IN THE POT CAN BE
FRUSTRATING AT TIMES,
BUT IN THE PAST TEN YEARS,
I'VE SEEN IT RESULT IN GOOD
LEGISLATION THAT
OTHERWISE MAY NOT HAVE THOUGHT
ABOUT.
WE MAY NOT HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT
IT AT ALL.
UM, YOU HAVE, YOU HAVE BEFORE
YOU WHAT?
I HOPE YOU WILL CONSIDER A
THOUGHTFUL BILL.
WE'RE WORKING THROUGH A COMPLEX
ISSUE AND REMAIN
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE WORKING
THROUGH IT.
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME TO TESTIFY
DEPUTY DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
TIFFANY BROKAW FROM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE,
JOINED BY EMILIO VARANINI, WHO
WILL BE AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
AND KATIE VAN DINE'S, POLICY AND
LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR HEALTH CARE, HEALTH
ACCESS.
CALIFORNIA IS OUR SECOND
WITNESS.
THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
UH, PLEASE PROCEED.
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FIRST FOR
THE RECORD.
IT WANTS TO GO FIRST.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
UM.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TIFFANY BROKAW,
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB BONTA,
WHO IS THE PROUD SPONSOR OF
AB 3129.
AND I'D FIRST JUST LIKE TO THANK
YOU,
THE CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING
WITH US ON THESE AMENDMENTS.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'VE HAD TO GET US TO WHERE
WE ARE NOW.
UM, AS DOCTOR WOOD HAS, YOU
KNOW,
STATED IN HIS OPENING REMARKS,
AB 3129 AUTHORIZES THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO REVIEW HEALTH CARE
TRANSACTIONS INVOLVING PRIVATE
EQUITY AND HEDGE FUND GROUPS.
AND IT ALSO REINFORCES THE
EXISTING BAR
ON THE CORPORATE PRACTICE OF
MEDICINE,
AS IT APPLIES TO THE
INTERFERENCE
OF PRIVATE EQUITY GROUPS
OR HEDGE FUNDS IN THE MEDICAL
CARE OF PATIENTS.
THE BILL FOCUSES ON PRIVATE
EQUITY BECAUSE
THE PRIVATE EQUITY BUSINESS
MODEL,
WHICH IS DESIGNED DESIGNED TO
BUY AN ASSET,
MAXIMIZE PROFIT PROFITS AND THEN
SELL THAT ASSET,
HAS CONCERNING EFFECTS WHEN
APPLIED
TO OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
AND THESE TRANSACTIONS HAVE BEEN
HAPPENING
HAVE DOUBLED IN THE PAST DECADE.
SO IN THE HEALTH CARE CONTEXT,
WHAT THIS LOOKS LIKE IS THAT
A PRIVATE
EQUITY GROUP WILL COME IN
AND THEY WILL MAKE CUTS TO
STAFF,
THEY WILL CUT SERVICES, ALL TO
MAXIMIZE PROFITS.
AND THEN WHEN THAT FACILITY
OR PROVIDER GROUP IS SOLD,
THEY ARE OFTENTIMES SUSCEPTIBLE
TO BANKRUPTCY,
FURTHER CONSOLIDATION OR
SHUTTING DOWN,
WHICH JEOPARDIZES THE
COMMUNITY'S ACCESS TO CARE.
AB 3129 WOULD SET UP OVERSIGHT
OVER THESE TRANSACTIONS,
WHERE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WOULD
HAVE AUTHORITY TO APPROVE,
DENY OR APPROVE WITH CONDITIONS
THESE TRANSACTIONS BASED
ON WHETHER THEY WOULD BE IN THE
PUBLIC INTEREST.
THE CONDITIONS THAT THE AG WOULD
PLACE ON A TRANSACTION
ARE DESIGNED TO KEEP SERVICES
OPEN AND AFFORDABLE.
SO, FOR EXAMPLE, A CONDITION
THAT
THE AG USES IN HIS CURRENT
ROLE REVIEWING NONPROFIT
HOSPITAL
TRANSACTIONS AND THAT
WOULD BE USED IN THIS CONTEXT OF
PRIVATE EQUITY TRANSACTIONS,
WOULD BE THAT SERVICES WOULD
NEED TO BE MAINTAINED.
SO YES, THIS TRANSACTION CAN
HAPPEN,
BUT THE HOSPITAL WOULD NEED TO
CONTINUE SERVING
MEDI-CAL PATIENTS AND WOULD NEED
TO KEEP
THEIR LABOR AND DELIVERY UNIT
OPEN.
A CONDITION THAT ALSO COULD
COME IN
THE FORM OF PRICE INCREASE CAPS.
SO YES, THE TRANSACTION CAN
HAPPEN,
BUT PRICES FOR SERVICES CAN'T
SKYROCKET
AND BECOME UNAFFORDABLE.
THIS REVIEW PROCESS IS NOT AN
AUTOMATIC DENIAL.
THE OVERSIGHT IS TO HELP ENSURE
THAT CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE HEALTH
CARE,
AND THAT SERVICES REMAIN
AVAILABLE
TO THOSE WHO NEED IT.
AND FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN, MR.
CHAIR AND SENATORS.
I'M KATIE VAN DINES WITH HEALTH
ACCESS CALIFORNIA,
THE STATEWIDE HEALTH CARE
CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION,
AND WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT AB
3129 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOOD.
FOR MORE THAN 30 YEARS,
ATTORNEYS GENERAL OF BOTH
PARTIES HAVE HAD THE AUTHORITY
TO APPROVE,
DENY OR APPROVE WITH CONDITIONS
MERGERS RELATED TO
NONPROFIT HOSPITALS AND IN THESE
LAST 30 YEARS,
BETWEEN 80 AND 90% OF THESE
PROPOSED
MERGERS HAVE BEEN APPROVED,
MOSTLY WITH CONDITIONS TO
PROTECT CONSUMERS.
IN WHAT CONDITIONS HAVE AG'S
ASKED
FOR TO KEEP EMERGENCY ROOMS
OPEN,
TO KEEP LABOR AND DELIVERY OPEN,
TO KEEP CARDIAC CARE AND MORE
SERVICES OPEN.
TO NOT HIKE UP PRICES ON
CONSUMERS.
TO NOT DROP MEDI-CAL MANAGED
CARE CONTRACTS,
TO NOT CLOSE HOSPITALS.
EXACTLY THE SORT OF CONDITIONS
NEEDED TO PROTECT ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE CARE IN THE
AFFECTED COMMUNITY.
THIS PROCESS IS NOT NEW.
WHAT IS NEW IS THAT PRIVATE
EQUITY
IS TAKING OVER HOSPITALS,
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES AND
DOCTORS GROUPS,
AND RESEARCH IS SHOWING THAT
THIS
CAN LEAD TO PRICE INCREASES,
DANGEROUS IMPACTS ON QUALITY
AND RISKS FOR
ACCESS TO CARE AND LOSS OF
SERVICES.
AB 3129 WOULD SUBJECT PRIVATE
EQUITY TRANSACTIONS
IN HEALTH CARE TO THE SAME SORT
OF SCRUTINY THAT,
AND OVERSIGHT THAT NONPROFIT
HOSPITALS
HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO FOR
DECADES,
WHILE THE OFFICE OF HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY,
OR OHCA, WILL BE REVIEWING
ACQUISITIONS,
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO DENY OR CONDITION
THESE ACQUISITIONS TO PROTECT
CONSUMERS.
AND WHILE AN AG COULD ENGAGE IN
ANTITRUST LITIGATION
AFTER AN OCA REVIEW, THIS
LITIGATION TAKES TIME.
THE LANDMARK SUTTER SETTLEMENT
TOOK MORE THAN 14 YEARS,
FAR LONGER THAN THE 60 DAYS
THE AG
WOULD HAVE AFTER AN OCA REVIEW.
WE NEED THE AG TO HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO
ACT BEFORE AN ACQUISITION
HAPPENS,
TO PREVENT HARMFUL IMPACTS ON
COMMUNITIES
AND PROTECT AFFORDABLE ACCESS
TO CARE.
WHEN THERE IS A MERGER OR
ACQUISITION
IN HEALTH CARE,
WE HEAR A LOT OF PROMISES ABOUT
THE WONDERFUL THINGS THAT WILL
HAPPEN
FOR THE COMMUNITY INNOVATION,
EFFICIENCY AND MORE.
AND WE WANT THOSE THINGS TO
HAPPEN FOR
THE COMMUNITY AND FOR HEALTH
CARE.
BUT WE WANT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO HOLD PRIVATE EQUITY
ACCOUNTABLE TO
THESE PROMISES AND PREVENT THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS
THAT WE'RE WORRIED ABOUT FOR
COMMUNITIES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
ON AB 3129.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE?
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE.
>> DYLAN ELLIOTT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ADAM ZARIN, LEUKEMIA AND
LYMPHOMA
SOCIETY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> TIM MADDEN, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> MARTIN RADOVICH ON BEHALF OF
REPRODUCTIVE
FREEDOM FOR ALL.
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BRANDON MARKEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION,
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSOR
FOR WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
JESSICA MORAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION,
ALSO IN SUPPORT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
BETH MADORSKY WITH SCA
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANKS.
>> HI, TASHA.
WHAT'S WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> KATRINA DUNN IN CALIFORNIA
BLACK HEALTH NETWORK,
ALSO CO-OWNER OF A PRIVATE
PRACTICE
IN RURAL CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
>> BENJAMIN ECKERT WITH THE
NATIONAL UNION
OF HEALTHCARE WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR..
MR.
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
BRIAN MIRAMONTEZ WITH THE
AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE,
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS
MARTY LOPEZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
YES, SIR.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHARLIE DONLON WITH STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ORTHOPAEDIC
ASSOCIATION.
WE NO LONGER OPPOSE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
NOW, LET'S HEAR FROM WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
IF THERE ARE ANY FIRST LEAD
WITNESSES,
IF YOU HAVE LEAD WITNESSES,
PLEASE TAKE SEATS AT THE TABLE
IF YOU PREFER.
WE'LL CALL ON OTHER WITNESSES
LATER.
WELCOME.
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD AND PROCEED.
WHEN READY, I'LL LET YOU FLIP
A COIN.
>> MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MEGAN LOPER,
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
AND AS A NON-LAWYER, I AM
PLEASED
TO BE JOINED BY LOIS
RICHARDSON OF COUNSEL AND VICE
PRESIDENT AT CCIA.
SHOULD THERE BE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS,
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS
OF THE CHAIR,
REMAINS OPPOSED TO 3129 PATIENTS
NEED ACCESS
TO EFFECTIVE AND RELIABLE HEALTH
CARE,
AND THESE SERVICES DO DEPEND
ON CONSTANT
INNOVATION AND INVESTMENT.
THE STATE SHOULD CONTINUE TO
ENCOURAGE
INVESTMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
FRAGILE HEALTH CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM
RATHER THAN DESTABILIZE IT.
IN RECENT YEARS, CALIFORNIA
HOSPITALS
HAVE PARTNERED WITH PRIVATE
ENTITIES TO BRING NEW AND
EXPANDED SERVICES ONLINE.
AS A RESULT, FOR EXAMPLE,
INPATIENT REHABILITATION
HOSPITALS HAVE BEEN BUILT
IN COMMUNITIES INCLUDING
SACRAMENTO,
IRVINE, ESCONDIDO, AND CENTURY
CITY.
THIS BILL WOULD CREATE BARRIERS
TO SUCCESSFUL NEW INVESTMENTS
SUCH AS THESE WHEN EXACTLY THE
OPPOSITE IS NEEDED.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE'S EXISTING AUTHORITY
OVER NONPROFIT HOSPITAL
TRANSACTIONS
HAS SERVED AS A BARRIER
FOR INVESTMENT THAT HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY DELAYED
OR CURTAILED CRITICAL
ACQUISITIONS,
PUTTING SERVICES IN JEOPARDY.
ACCESS TO ALL FINANCIAL TOOLS
IS CRITICAL,
PARTICULARLY IN VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES,
WHERE INVESTMENTS ARE NEEDED
TO SUPPORT UNDER-RESOURCED
PROVIDERS SO THAT THEY CAN
BETTER
SERVE THEIR PATIENTS.
AS AN EXAMPLE OF THE CONCERNS
THAT REMAIN,
THE PROCESS TO ALLOW
DISTRESSED ENTITIES TO REQUEST
A WAIVER FROM THE FULL
REVIEW IS FLAWED AND USE
CRITERIA
THAT GO BEYOND OBJECTIVE
MEASURES USED BY LENDERS TO
ADDRESS FINANCIAL DISTRESS.
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR A WAIVER,
AN ENTITY MUST PROVE THAT IT'S
BEEN UNABLE TO PAY ITS BILLS
FOR THREE YEARS OR MORE,
AND THAT IT IS AT SUBSTANTIAL
RISK OF LIQUIDATION
UNDER CHAPTER SEVEN BANKRUPTCY,
AND THAT IT IS FACING CHAPTER
11 BANKRUPTCY,
AMONG OTHER CRITERIA.
THROUGH COVID, WE'VE SEEN JUST
HOW QUICKLY
HOSPITAL FINANCES CAN CHANGE,
AND WE QUESTION WHETHER THIS
MULTILAYER WAIVER
TEST WOULD APPLY ONLY WHEN IT'S
TOO LATE
TO HELP SAVE THE FINANCIALLY
STRUGGLING ENTITY
AND PRESERVE ACCESS FOR
PATIENTS.
ADDITIONALLY, THE STANDARDS
FOR REVIEW REMAIN UNCLEAR,
AND THE JUNE 19TH AMENDMENTS DO
NOT RESOLVE QUESTIONS RELATED
TO THE APPLICATION OF THE PUBLIC
INTEREST STANDARD.
WITHOUT CLEAR STANDARDS, WE
WORRY THAT
ENTITIES WILL STRUGGLE TO
DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT DOJ APPROVAL IS
LIKELY
TO BE REQUIRED OR GRANTED.
PARTNERING HEALTH CARE ENTITIES
THAT
MAY BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE
EXPANDING
AND PRESERVING PATIENT ACCESS
MAY CONTINUE
TO FAIL TO RECEIVE APPROVAL.
AS THE BILL CONTINUES TO ALLOW
THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO CONSIDER, QUOTE,
ANY OTHER FACTORS THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL
DETERMINES TO BE OF PUBLIC
BENEFIT.
WHILE 3129 PUTS AT RISK
INNOVATION
AND ADDITIONAL INVESTMENT IN
PATIENT CARE.
FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
MR.
CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
MARK OPREA.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN
INVESTMENT COUNCIL.
WE WANT TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE
FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS MEASURE,
AND WE WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR,
AS WELL AS THE SPONSORS,
FOR MEETING WITH US TO REVIEW.
>> OUR OBJECTIONS TO THE MEASURE
EARLIER THIS WEEK.
I THINK IT IS FAIR TO SAY THAT
HEALTH CARE IN CALIFORNIA
IS UNDERFUNDED AND REDUCING
CAPITAL,
AS WE BELIEVE THIS MEASURE WILL
DO,
REDUCES ACCESS AND QUALITY
CONTRARY TO THE OBJECTIVE,
THE OBJECTIVES OF THE BILL.
GIVEN THE RECENT PASSAGE OF
SENATE BILL 184 IN 2022
TO CREATE THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3192 ESTABLISHES
AN UNNECESSARY
PARALLEL REGULATORY NOTIFICATION
PROCESS.
THE AMERICAN INVESTMENT COUNCIL
HAS SUPPORTED
AND CONTINUES TO SUPPORT THE
STATE
OF CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO
ENHANCE
AND OVERSIGHT OVER
ANTICOMPETITIVE
TRANSACTIONS AND BAD ACTORS IN
THE HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY THAT
POSE
A DEMONSTRABLE THREAT TO HEALTH
CARE ACCESS,
PRICES, AND COMPETITION.
FOR EXAMPLE, AIC WAS SUPPORTED
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
REGULATIONS
TO IMPLEMENT SENATE BILL 184,
WHICH, AMONG OTHER THINGS,
ESTABLISHED THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
CARE AFFORDABILITY TO SUPPORT
HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY
THROUGH THE COLLECTION,
ANALYSIS AND PUBLICLY REPORTING
OF DATA OF TOTAL HEALTH
CARE EXPENDITURES AND
TRANSACTIONS UNDER AB 3129,
PRIVATE EQUITY GROUPS AND HEDGE
FUNDS
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO SUBMIT
HEALTH
CARE TRANSACTION NOTIFICATIONS
TO THE AG RATHER THAN TO OCA.
THIS IS UNNECESSARY, AS OCA IS
EMPOWERED
TO REFER TRANSACTIONS
THAT THEY FIND PROBLEMATIC TO
THE AG FOR REVIEW.
IN PARTICULAR, SB 184 PROVIDES
A CLEAR STATEMENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE'S INTENT IN
ESTABLISHING
OCA AS FOLLOWS.
IT IS THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ESTABLISH
A SINGLE ENTITY WITHIN STATE
GOVERNMENT,
CHARGED WITH REFERRING
TRANSACTIONS THAT
MAY REDUCE MARKET COMPETITION OR
INCREASE COST TO THE ATTORNEY TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR FURTHER
REVIEW.
HOWEVER, AB 3129 MATERIALLY
UNDERCUTS OCA'S MANDATE
BY CREATING AN UNNECESSARY
PARALLEL PROCESS
BY REQUIRING CERTAIN HEALTH CARE
ENTITIES TO
FILE NOTICE WITH THE AG RATHER
THAN OCA,
AND AB 3129 EFFECTIVELY PREVENTS
OCA FROM COLLECTING
AND REPORTING DATA INFORMATION
BECAUSE IT WILL NO LONGER
RECEIVE THAT DATA TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE PUBLIC
REGARDING HEALTH CARE
EXPENDITURES AND COST TRENDS.
IF WE LOOK AT THE DEFINITION OF
PRIVATE EQUITY,
IT IS SO BROAD THAT THE THAT THE
THAT THE MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE WHO SIT ON
THE DAIS,
WHO WOULD POOL THEIR MONEY,
WOULD BE CONSIDERED A PRIVATE
EQUITY GROUP.
FURTHERMORE, IT EXEMPTS AN
INDIVIDUAL
SO A SINGLE INDIVIDUAL COULD BUY
A HOSPITAL AND WOULD NOT BE
REQUIRED
TO TO GO THROUGH THE PROCESS.
THE DEFINITION OF TRANSACTION
SUBJECT TO REVIEW ALSO
COVERS MINOR EVENTS SUCH AS
CHANGES TO THE BOARD.
WE THINK THIS ADDS AN
UNNECESSARY
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS,
AND WE WOULD SUGGEST THAT IT
DOES NOTHING TO SATISFY
THE INTENT OF THE OF THE OF THE
MEASURE.
AND FINALLY, TO REITERATE
AND TO SUPPORT THE TESTIMONY
OF THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS MEASURE
CREATES
AN OVERLY OVERBROAD, UH,
CONSENT REQUIREMENT AND POSES
DUE PROCESS ISSUES THAT, UH.
IN OUR VIEW, IS.
IS A BLUNT INSTRUMENT AND NOT A
SURGICAL INSTRUMENT
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS.
FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY MUST
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE.
>> THANK YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
RYAN PERRINE,
ON BEHALF OF ETA ACTION,
THE ADVOCACY ARM FOR THE
AMERICAN
TELEMEDICINE ASSOCIATION.
I WANT TO QUICKLY THANK THE
STAFF FOR THEIR
THOROUGH ANALYSIS AND WANT TO
THANK
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF FOR
WORKING
CLOSELY TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
I THINK WITH THE COMMITMENT
MADE TO,
UM, UH, ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS,
INCLUDING THE ANALYSIS WILL BE
REMOVING
OUR OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, DAVID KRIEGER
FOR
THE UNITED HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND SENATORS.
MY NAME IS FRED KNITWEAR,
REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATION
OF DENTAL SUPPORT ORGANIZATIONS.
WHILE WE DO REMAIN OPPOSED,
WE'RE REVIEWING THE LANGUAGE
AND WANT TO EXPRESS A SINCERE
APPRECIATION
FOR THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE TAKEN AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS
AND NEGOTIATION WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS WITH AN OPPOSING,
LESS LIMITED POSITION.
WE APOLOGIZE FOR THE LATE NOTICE
ON THAT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE, SIR.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
EDUARDO MARTINEZ, ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN DENTAL SERVICES,
WE HAVE AN OPPOSING LAST AMENDED
POSITION,
AND WE'RE REQUESTING AN
AMENDMENT TO
EXEMPT KNOX KEANE RELATED
ENTITIES,
THOSE SUBJECT TO THE DMHC FROM
FROM
THE AG'S OVERSIGHT PROVISIONS.
THANK YOU.
>> JON STEINBERG.
I'M WITH CHILDREN'S CHOICE
DENTAL CARE.
WE ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU, PRESTON YOUNG FROM
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
>> JENNIFER SNYDER WITH CAPITAL
ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH FACILITIES
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
>> CONNIE DELGADO ON BEHALF OF
NEWPORT HEALTH
CARE WITH A POSITION OF
CONCERNS.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES?
SEEING NONE, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DESK.
COLLEAGUES.
QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS?
OKAY, WELL, I JUST HAVE A
COMMENT
TO MAKE FOR THE RECORD.
YOU KNOW, I'VE, UM, MY STAFF,
ACTUALLY, UM,
SINCE THEY'RE THE BRAINS BEHIND
THIS OPERATION,
SPENT MORE TIME ON THIS BILL
PROBABLY THAN ANY OTHER
THAT WE'VE HAD AT LEAST SINCE
I'VE BEEN THE CHAIR,
WHICH I REALIZE IS A
MICROSECOND.
UM, BUT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OBVIOUSLY
HAS BEEN INVOLVED IN REVIEWING,
UH,
NONPROFIT TRANSACTIONS IN THE
HEALTH CARE ARENA FOR
AS LONG AS I CAN REMEMBER,
CERTAINLY SOME TIME.
AND AS SOME OF YOU MAY RECALL,
I'VE HAD CONCERNS OVER
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S ENTRY
INTO THE PRIVATE,
FOR PROFIT SEGMENT OF THE HEALTH
CARE MARKET FOR SEVERAL YEARS,
DATING BACK TO I THINK IT WAS
SENATOR
MANNING'S EFFORT IN, IN 2020.
AND FRANKLY, THE IRONY OF THE
TIMING
OF THIS EFFORT IS NOT LOST ON
ME.
AS YOU KNOW, WE'RE IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND ELSEWHERE.
WE'RE PUSHING OUR HOSPITALS TO
COMPLY WITH SEISMIC STANDARDS
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN COMPLIED
WITH A LONG TIME AGO.
AND AS A RESULT, THERE'S A
SCRAMBLE
TO TRY TO FIND FINANCING
AND FUNDING TO ACCOMPLISH THOSE
RETROFIT OPERATIONS.
AND AT THE SAME TIME, WE MAY
BE LIMITING
FUNDING SOURCES BY POTENTIALLY
RESTRICTING PRIVATE EQUITY
INVOLVEMENT IN THE MARKET.
BUT I'M ALSO FAIRLY CERTAIN
THAT THERE
ARE TRANSACTIONS THAT ARE
OCCURRING
EVERY DAY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA
WITH REGARD TO PRIVATE EQUITY,
THAT DO REQUIRE OVERSIGHT AND
OVERSIGHT
BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
MY CONCERNS HAVE RELATED AND
CONTINUE TO RELATE
TO THE DEFINITION OF PRIVATE
EQUITY,
THE APPLICATION OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S REVIEW,
AND THE APPROVAL PROCESS TO
TRANSACTIONS IN
THE COMMERCIAL SPACE INVOLVING
MEDICAL GROUPS
AND OTHER GROUPS OF HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS,
PSYCHOLOGISTS, AND SOCIAL
WORKERS.
THE OVERALL BREADTH OF THE
REVIEW PROCESS,
AND AS WAS MENTIONED BY ONE
WITNESS,
ISSUES REGARDING THE RESTRICTIVE
WAIVER PROVISIONS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY EMBEDDED IN
IN THE BILL.
BUT BEYOND ALL THAT, ONE OF
MY MOST
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS SINCE
I FIRST EXAMINED THE SIMILAR
PROPOSAL
IN 2020 WAS THE LACK,
AND HAS BEEN THE LACK OF DUE
PROCESS
AND THE EFFECTIVE REVIEW AND
OVERSIGHT
OVER THE EXERCISE OF THE
ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S AUTHORITY IN THIS
AREA.
AFTER REVIEWING SOME AMENDMENTS
WHICH I REQUESTED THAT
WERE PROPOSED BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE,
TO THAT PROCESS THAT'S SET FORTH
IN,
I THINK, SECTION 1190 .30.
UM, WE DECIDED TO REDRAFT
THE DECISION MAKING PROCESS
HERE,
AND THE PROCESS AS REDRAFTED NOW
INCLUDES AN INITIAL
DETERMINATION BY THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL,
AN OPPORTUNITY BY THE IMPACTED
PARTY
TO ELECT A FULL EVIDENTIARY
HEARING
ON THE ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH
THAT INITIAL DETERMINATION,
A HEARING BEFORE AN
ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE ASSIGNED
TO THE STATE'S OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE HEARINGS,
A REQUIREMENT THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ISSUE A FINAL
DETERMINATION BASED ON THAT
HEARING RECORD AND,
IF DESIRED, AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE IMPACTED PARTY TO APPEAL
THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL'S FINAL
DETERMINATION TO THE COURTS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL ACCEPTED
OUR DUE PROCESS REVISION
AND THE AMENDMENT TO THAT
PARTICULAR SECTION,
ALONG WITH SOME OTHER SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS
TO THE DEFINITION OF HEDGE FUND
AND OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE SET
FORTH IN
IN THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE
BILL.
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THAT LEVEL OF COOPERATION AND
THE HELP THAT
WE RECEIVED FROM THE OFFICE OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IN TRYING TO ACHIEVE THOSE
OBJECTIVES.
AND WHILE ISSUES CERTAINLY
REMAIN
WITH REGARD TO THE OTHER AREAS
I IDENTIFIED AND AREAS THAT
SOME OF
THE WITNESSES HAVE IDENTIFIED,
GIVEN THE REVISIONS TO THE
DECISION
MAKING AND APPEAL PROCESS,
WHICH I CONSIDER TO BE
EXTRAORDINARILY SIGNIFICANT,
I WILL BE VOTING TO MOVE THE
BILL
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE TODAY.
HOWEVER, HAVING SAID THAT, AND
GIVEN THE ISSUES
REMAINING WITH REGARD TO THE
BILL,
I DO RECOGNISE AND I'M SAYING
THIS FOR THOSE
WHO WERE HERE AND THOSE WHO WERE
LISTENING,
I HOPE I DO RECOGNISE THAT
COMMITTEE
MEMBERS ALL HAVE HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS IN YOUR DISTRICTS AND
CONSTITUENTS
WHO DEPEND ON THEM,
BOTH OF WHOM MAY HAVE STRONG
FEELINGS
ON THIS SUBJECT ONE WAY OR THE
OTHER.
AND I WANT TO ASSURE THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
NOTWITHSTANDING MY VOTE,
THAT YOU ARE FREE TO VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE AS
YOU AND YOUR CONSTITUENTS DEEM
APPROPRIATE.
BUT I WILL BE VOTING I IF THIS
MEASURE
MOVES OUT OF THE COMMITTEE
TODAY,
I WANT TO ASSURE ALL WHO ARE
LISTENING
THAT I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
TO FURTHER IMPROVE THIS MEASURE
IN THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
WHICH I SIT ON WHICH WITH ITS
CHAIR.
HAVING SAID THAT.
DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION, SENATOR
SCHWAB?
PLEASE PROCEED.
WE'LL TURN TO SENATOR MENGIBAR
FOR A QUESTION.
I DO WANT TO.
CUT YOU OFF, MR.
CHAIR.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU WERE DONE
OR NOT.
I THINK I'VE FULLY DONE.
THANK YOU.
UM, I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY,
BECAUSE I THOUGHT
THE ISSUE THAT THE OPPOSITION
BROUGHT UP IN TERMS OF,
UM, PULLING TOGETHER LIKE FIVE
PHYSICIANS THAT WAS ADDRESSED.
SO I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT
THAT HASN'T BEEN ADDRESSED.
THAT.
TECHNICALLY, IF TWO PHYSICIANS
COME TOGETHER, UM,
TO BUY OUT TO CREATE, THAT WOULD
BE CONSIDERED PRIVATE EQUITY.
IT IT IT DEPENDS AND I WILL
DEFER TO THEM.
BUT I WILL SAY THIS THAT THE
FIRST
TRANSACTION BY A GROUP.
SO IF A GROUP OF PHYSICIANS
DECIDED
THEY WANTED TO DO THIS,
THAT FIRST TRANSACTION WOULD NOT
BE REVIEWABLE.
IT IS SUBSEQUENT TRANSACTIONS
WITHIN A SEVEN
YEAR PERIOD THAT WOULD BE
REVIEWABLE.
SO IF A GROUP OF PHYSICIANS GET
TOGETHER AND SAY,
HEY, WE WANT TO BAIL THIS OUT,
WE WANT TO DO THIS, THEY COULD
DO THAT
AND THERE WOULD NOT BE A REVIEW.
WHAT WOULD BE?
IF THEY GO ON TO BUY SOMETHING
ELSE,
IT WOULD BE OKAY.
YEAH, EXACTLY.
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS TO
TRY TO ENSURE THAT
THE FURTHER ACQUISITIONS DO NOT
CONSOLIDATE IN A REGION,
THE, THE CONTROL OF, OF THAT
PARTICULAR ENTITY,
FOR EXAMPLE,
SURGERY BY MULTIPLE SURGERY
CENTERS.
AND SUDDENLY THE PRIVATE EQUITY
FIRM OWNS
MORE THAN HALF OF THOSE SURGERY
CENTERS.
UM, I DEFINITELY DOCTOR, WOULD
YOU AND
I HAVE SPOKEN I AGREE WITH THE
PREMISE.
FIND A WAY TO STOP IT.
I ALSO HAVE A HOSPITAL IN MY
DISTRICT THAT
WAS BOUGHT OFF BY PRIVATE
EQUITY,
AND IT SURVIVED THAT WAY.
AND I'M JUST TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN APPROACH THAT.
AND I'VE HEARD I THINK I HEARD
AND YOU GAVE SOME EXAMPLES.
YOU WRITE YOU READ THROUGH SOME
EXAMPLES OF YOU CAN
STILL DO THIS IF THERE'S A
LAUNDRY LIST OF THINGS.
BUT THEN I HEARD THE OPPOSITION
SAID THAT
THERE'S NO THERE ISN'T ROOM
FOR THAT.
SO I JUST WANTED TO CLARIFY IF
DISTRESS
HOSPITAL IS DISTRESSED,
THEY STILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
USE THIS AS A SAVING GRACE.
THEY DO.
THERE ARE THERE THERE IS A
PROCESS.
AND I'M SURE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S
OFFICE COULD LAY THAT OUT FOR
YOU.
BUT IF THIS HOSPITAL HAS
EXHAUSTED
ALL OTHER OPPORTUNITIES,
AND THE ONLY OPPORTUNITY
AVAILABLE
TO THEM IS PRIVATE EQUITY,
THEY COULD DO THAT WITHOUT
REVIEW.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO PROVE THAT
THEY ARE TRULY DISTRESSED,
WHICH MEANS OPENING THEIR BOOKS
MORE THAN LIKELY.
AND ARE WE CREATING A DIFFERENT
KIND OF SYSTEM OF PROOF?
AND BECAUSE WHAT I'VE HEARD
SOMETIMES,
WHAT I'VE HEARD
THROUGHOUT THIS DISCUSSION IN
THE PAST COUPLE WEEKS,
THAT POTENTIALLY IN THAT REVIEW,
THERE'S TWO DIFFERENT TIERS THAT
WE'RE CREATING NOW.
IS THAT CORRECT?
I DON'T BELIEVE SO.
ARE YOU REFERRING TO THE OFFICE
OF HEALTH CARE AFFORDABILITY?
TWO TIERS IN TERMS OF PROOF OF
DISTRESS,
IS IT STILL THE SAME WAY AS WE
APPROACH OUR DISTRESSED LOANS?
WHO'S ELIGIBLE FOR THAT?
IS THIS A DIFFERENT KIND OF
PROOF
THAT WE'RE SETTING FORWARD?
I'D HAVE TO SEE THEM SIDE BY
SIDE.
SO.
BUT I'M HAPPY TO LOOK.
THIS IS THE FIRST THIS HAS COME
UP FROM ANY, ANY,
ANY QUESTIONING FROM ANYBODY
ALONG THE WAY.
SO I AM HAPPY TO LOOK INTO THAT
AND AND WORK TO.
YOU FEEL CONFIDENT THAT THERE'S
STILL
AN APPROACH FOR DISTRESSED
HOSPITALS.
IT IS NOT MY DESIRE TO CLOSE A
HOSPITAL, OKAY?
NOT AT ALL.
WELL, LET ME JUST LET ME LET
ME ASK THE.
WE HAVE THE GURUS SITTING HERE
AT THE TABLE.
HE AND I HAVE SPARRED ON THIS
ISSUE FOR SEVERAL YEARS,
BUT I RESPECT HIS ABILITIES.
WOULD NOT THE PRIVATE EQUITY
GROUP IN THE HOSPITAL
SITUATION HAVE TO APPLY FROM
FOR A WAIVER?
>> THEY CAN APPLY FOR A WAIVER.
MR.
CHAIR.
SENATORS IT'S A IT'S A PLEASURE
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS YOU ALL.
I'M EMILIO VANINI I SHOULD
IDENTIFY MYSELF
FROM THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, FOR THE KIND WORDS.
AND OF COURSE, I APPRECIATED
THE DUE PROCESS AMENDMENTS,
WHICH WE COMPLETELY SUPPORT.
AS TO THE QUESTION, FIRST OF
ALL.
ANY HOSPITAL THAT COMES IN AND
SAYS,
WE'RE BEING ACQUIRED,
WE'RE GOING TO LOOK AT THEIR
FINANCIAL
CONDITION IN OUR EXISTING REGS.
FOR THE NONPROFIT HOSPITAL
TRANSACTION CENTER.
WE ASK FOR THE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS.
WE WANT TO LOOK AT THAT.
WE WANT TO UNDERSTAND THE
HOSPITAL.
IF THE HOSPITAL IS HAVING
FINANCIAL PROBLEMS NOW,
WE'RE NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT
THE WAIVER.
WE WILL LOOK AT THAT TO
DETERMINE HOW WHAT
WE SHOULD RECOMMEND TO THE
GENERAL.
WE HAVE AN INDEPENDENT EXPERT
WHO WILL ALSO LOOK AT THAT
AND DETERMINE WHAT TO RECOMMEND
TO US AND TO THE GENERAL.
AND WE HAVE A PUBLIC HEARING
WHERE
THESE ISSUES CAN COME UP.
SO EVEN IF AN ENTITY DOESN'T
QUALIFY FOR THE WAIVER,
WE STILL WILL CONSIDER THE
FINANCIAL CONDITION.
HOWEVER, WE HAVE A WAIVER
PROCESS.
WHY?
BECAUSE OVER THE YEARS PEOPLE
HAVE ASKED US,
WHY DON'T YOU HAVE A WAIVER
PROCESS FOR FAILING FIRMS?
THAT'S THE TECHNICAL TERM OF ART
FROM ANTITRUST LAW.
FAILING FIRM DEFENSE AND
ANTITRUST
LAW SAYS THIS IS A BAD MERGER.
IT'S GOING TO INCREASE PRICES.
BUT.
WE HAVE TO TOLERATE IT BECAUSE
THE THE END RESULT IS GOING TO
BE THE HOSPITAL IS GOING TO BE
GONE AND NOBODY WANTS THAT.
SO WE LOOK TO FEDERAL ANTITRUST
LAW AND WE MODIFIED IT.
WE MADE IT.
WELL, AT LEAST WHAT WE PROPOSED.
AND THEN WE WORKED WITH THE
CHAIR
ON FURTHER PROPOSALS TO MAKE IT
EASIER TO MEET THAN YOU CAN MEET
UNDER FEDERAL ANTITRUST LAWS.
SO WE SAID YOU HAVE TO HAVE
THREE
YEARS OF FINANCIAL PERFORMANCE
WHERE YOU'RE SUFFERING FROM
DEFICITS, OKAY.
THAT IS YOUR NET PATIENT
REVENUE, AS IT WERE,
ISN'T COVERING THE COSTS FOR
THREE YEARS.
WE PICKED THREE YEARS BECAUSE
EVERY HOSPITAL WE'VE
EVER REVIEWED HAS A BAD YEAR
NOW AND THEN.
THAT IS TRUE IN MANY BUSINESSES.
IT IS TRUE HERE.
SO WE FIGURED THREE YEARS MADE
SENSE.
IT'S WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN COVID,
RIGHT?
THERE WERE HOSPITALS WHO HAD
GOOD
YEARS AND BAD YEARS IN COVID,
AND THERE WERE OTHER HOSPITALS
THAT HAD BAD YEARS.
SO WE PICKED THAT.
AND THEN THE QUESTION COMES
UP, WELL,
OKAY, WHAT MORE DO YOU NEED?
WELL, UNDER FEDERAL ANTITRUST
LAW,
YOU BASICALLY HAVE TO SHOW
THAT YOU'RE NOT ONLY GOING
TO HAVE TO FILE FOR CHAPTER 11
REORGANIZATION,
BUT THAT YOU CAN'T BE
REORGANIZED.
THAT IS A VERY DIFFICULT, IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE STANDARD TO MEET.
BUT THAT'S FEDERAL ANTITRUST
LAW.
THAT IS NOT WHAT WE ARE
PROPOSING.
WHAT WE ARE PROPOSING HERE,
SENATOR,
IS THAT YOU ARE AT SUBSTANTIAL
RISK OF HAVING TO FILE FOR
CHAPTER
11 AND THAT YOU THINK.
I THINK I GOT IT, OKAY.
SORRY, SENATOR.
IT'S OKAY.
UM.
LET ME ASK SO THAT WE HAVE
PRIVATE EQUITY HERE.
YES, SIR.
LET ME JUST LET THE OTHER SIDE
GIVE THEIR SPIEL.
THROUGH THE CHAIR.
IF I CAN ANSWER SENATOR MENGER'S
QUESTION
REGARDING THE DEFINITION
OF PRIVATE EQUITY GROUP, LET ME
READ FROM THE BILL.
A PRIVATE EQUITY GROUP MEANS AN
INVESTOR OR
GROUP OF INVESTORS WHO PRIMARILY
ENGAGE IN
THE RAISING OR RETURNING OF
CAPITAL AND WHO INVEST,
DEVELOPS OR DISPOSES OF
SPECIFIED ASSETS.
SPECIFIED ASSETS, BY THE WAY,
IS NOT DEFINED IN THE BILL.
PRIVATE EQUITY GROUP DOES NOT
INCLUDE NATURAL
PERSONS OR OTHER ENTITY ENTITIES
THAT CONTRIBUTE OR PROMISE TO
CONTRIBUTE
FUNDS TO THE PRIVATE EQUITY
GROUP,
BUT OTHERWISE DO NOT PARTICIPATE
IN THE MANAGEMENT
OF PRIVATE EQUITY OR THE GROUP'S
ASSETS,
OR IN ANY CHANGE IN CONTROL OF
THE PRIVATE EQUITY GROUP.
SO, UH, AS I MENTIONED,
THE MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE
THAT SIT ON THE DAIS COULD POOL
THEIR MONEY,
AND THEY WOULD BE THEY WOULD
FIND THEMSELVES
UNDER THE DEFINITION OF PRIVATE
EQUITY.
SIMILARLY, IT EXEMPTS AN
INDIVIDUAL.
SO THE BILL IS CREATING SOME
WINNERS AND LOSERS, RIGHT?
A WEALTHY INDIVIDUAL CAN GO AND
BUY A HOSPITAL
AND NOT BE SUBJECT TO THIS
REVIEW.
BUT IF TWO OR MORE INDIVIDUALS
POOL THEIR CAPITAL TO PURCHASE
A HOSPITAL OR SOME OTHER MEDICAL
FACILITY OR OR PRACTICE,
THEY WOULD HAVE TO GO THROUGH
THIS PROCESS.
SO WE THINK THAT THERE IS A
FUNDAMENTAL
LACK OF FAIRNESS
AND EQUALITY IN TERMS OF WHO IS
COVERED BY THE BILL.
MR.
CHAIR.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S ACCURATE
AND MAY BE THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE CAN CORRECT ME
IF I'M WRONG.
WELL, I DON'T BELIEVE THAT'S.
ACCURATE AT ALL.
THERE IS A SECTION B HERE THAT
I THAT THAT
I THINK WAS ADDED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
UM.
PRIVATE EQUITY GROUP DOES NOT
INCLUDE NATURAL
PERSONS OR OTHER ENTITIES THAT
CONTRIBUTE OR PROMISE TO
CONTRIBUTE
FUNDS TO THE PRIVATE EQUITY
GROUP,
BUT OTHERWISE DO NOT PARTICIPATE
IN THE MANAGEMENT OF
THE PRIVATE EQUITY GROUP OR
THE GROUP'S ASSETS, ETC..
SO LATE ADD.
BUT YOU KNOW, AND I READ THAT,
SENATOR,
SO I DON'T I DON'T I'M NOT BEING
CONTRADICTORY,
BUT IT SAYS IT'S NOT INCLUDING
A NATURAL PERSON.
RIGHT?
RIGHT.
ANYTHING ELSE.
THIS IS THE KIND OF HEARING
I LIKE.
SO THAT'S A APOLOGIZE FOR THE
TIME AUDIENCE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS?
SENATOR MENGIBAR.
ARE YOU DONE TO?
OKAY.
UM, SEEING NONE.
SO REMEMBER, YOU SHOULD CLOSE.
WITH WITH, UM.
WITH THE CHAIR'S PERMISSION,
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION'S POINTS.
ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE PROCEED.
UM, FIRST OF ALL, WITH REGARDS
TO
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION, UM,
WE THE FIRST AND ONLY TIME WE
HEARD
FROM THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION WAS RIGHT AFTER
THE BILL
WAS INTRODUCED IN FEBRUARY.
WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED ANY
REQUESTS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION SINCE THEN TO TALK
ABOUT THIS BILL.
AND SO THE CONCERNS THAT ARE
COMING UP FROM
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION,
IN MANY CASES, ARE NEW TO US.
AND THAT IS CONTRARY TO THE WAY
I WORK IN MY OFFICE.
IF YOU LISTEN TO THE NUMBER
OF WITNESSES THAT CAME UP,
EVEN THOSE IN OPPOSITION, UM,
THEY TALK ABOUT AMENDMENTS.
AND THERE HAD BEEN A HUGE NUMBER
OF
PEOPLE COMING THROUGH MY OFFICE,
AND WE HAVE WORKED THROUGH
AMENDMENTS.
IT IS DIFFICULT IT IS IMPOSSIBLE
TO ADDRESS THE THE CONCERNS
OF AN ENTITY THAT DOES NOT
CHOOSE TO ENGAGE WITH US.
THAT I BELIEVE IS IS NOT A NOT
FAIR.
THE IDEA THAT THIS WOULD SOMEHOW
DESTABILIZE THE MARKETPLACE IS,
I THINK, DISINGENUOUS AS WELL.
AS I WAS LISTENING TO THE
OPPOSITION,
I ALMOST FELT LIKE I WAS
HEARING THEM TALK ABOUT A
DIFFERENT BILL,
QUITE FRANKLY.
I DO NOT OPPOSE THE INVESTMENT.
OF PRIVATE EQUITY FUNDS INTO
HEALTH CARE.
WHAT I OPPOSE IS THE ACQUISITION
AND CONTROL BY A PRIVATE EQUITY
ENTITY.
SO IF PRIVATE EQUITY WANTS TO
INVEST IN
A HOSPITAL AND DOESN'T MAINTAIN
CONTROL,
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
IF PRIVATE EQUITY WANTS TO BUILD
A SERIES
OF MEDICAL PRACTICES ALONG THE
WAY,
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT.
WHAT I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IS
THE ACQUISITION AND CONTROL.
MANY OF THESE ARE ROLL UP TYPE
SITUATIONS,
CLASSIC PRIVATE EQUITY
ACQUISITIONS,
AND THAT IS WHAT I OBJECT TO.
SO I'M VERY DISAPPOINTED THAT
THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION SITS HERE WITH
THESE,
UM, THESE AMENDMENTS AND
CONCERNS
THAT THEY NEVER BROUGHT TO US.
THAT'S NOT FAIR.
UM.
WITH REGARDS TO THE AMERICAN
INVESTMENT COUNCIL FOLKS.
OKA.
THIS ISSUE WAS A BIG TIME
NEGOTIATION DURING OKA.
WE NEVER RESOLVED THIS ISSUE
DURING OKA.
IT WAS NEVER RESOLVED.
AND THE REALITY IS THAT OKA.
I KNOW I WORKED ON IT, MY TEAM
WORKED ON IT FOR TWO
AND A HALF YEARS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
WE KNOW WHAT OKAY CAN AND CANNOT
DO.
THIS IS ABOUT THEY'RE ABOUT
COLLECTING
DATA AND LOOKING AT MARKET
IMPACTS.
THEY HAVE NO AUTHORITY, NO
AUTHORITY
TO AFFECT A TRANSACTION.
ZERO.
AND SO I SIT HERE AND LISTEN
AND I GO,
I FEEL LIKE I'M LISTENING TO TWO
DIFFERENT SETS OF BILLS HERE.
AND I'M AND I FIND THAT I FIND
THAT REALLY,
REALLY CHALLENGING AS A,
AS A LEGISLATOR WHO HAS WORKED
ON A NUMBER
OF ISSUES AND ALWAYS HAD AN
OPEN DOOR.
SO MY DOOR REMAINS OPEN, I HOPE
THAT MEMBERS
GIVE ME THE BENEFIT OF THE
DOUBT,
UNDERSTAND THAT I AM CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH
EVERYBODY WHO HAS AN INTEREST
IN THIS,
AND WILL CONTINUE IF I CAN,
IF THIS BILL MOVES ON TODAY.
BUT THAT IS A TWO WAY STREET.
AND THE AMERICAN INVESTMENT
COUNCIL.
YOU KNOW, THEY WHAT WHAT WHAT
WASN'T SAID,
I DON'T BELIEVE.
AND IF I MISSED IT, I APOLOGIZE,
MR.
MAYOR, IS THAT WE ADDRESSED SOME
OF THEIR CONCERNS.
WE HAD AN EIGHT PAGE LETTER OF
OPPOSITION.
WE NOW HAVE A THREE PAGE LETTER
OF OPPOSITION.
I THINK WE'VE MADE SOME PROGRESS
THERE.
AND WE DON'T HAVE HAVEN'T HAD
THAT OPPORTUNITY
WITH THE HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
AND I THINK THAT'S I THINK
THAT'S A DISSERVICE
TO THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE.
AND TO THIS AND TO THIS AND TO
CONSTITUENTS OUT THERE THAT,
THAT WE HAVEN'T BEEN ENGAGED
WITH IN A MEANINGFUL MANNER.
AND IT'S DISAPPOINTING TO HEAR
THESE THESE CONCERNS TODAY.
SO WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE.
WELL, I WILL SAY THIS.
UM, DOCTOR, WOULD YOU HAVE TO BE
CONGRATULATION CONGRATULATED
AND COMMENDED ON A HERCULEAN
EFFORT ON A SUBJECT?
YOU'VE HEARD WHAT I SAID DURING
MY STATEMENT.
I'M CONVINCED THAT WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA,
THERE ARE SOME PRIVATE EQUITY
TRANSACTIONS
GOING ON EVERY DAY THAT,
UH, PROBABLY DEMAND THE
OVERSIGHT
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
AND WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE,
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD, UM,
THAT WE GET THE LANGUAGE RIGHT,
SO WE FOCUS THE EFFORT TO THE
EXTENT WE CAN
ON THE TRANSACTIONS THAT NEED
OVERSIGHT,
DEMAND OVERSIGHT AND REVIEW.
AND WHILE WE DON'T STIFLE
INVESTMENT IN HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES WHERE IT'S
NEEDED,
I THINK WE CAN DO THAT.
I DIDN'T SEE VERY MANY
AMENDMENTS IN TERMS
OF LANGUAGE TO THAT EFFECT
EITHER,
AND THAT'S MY COMMITMENT TO
WORK WITH
YOU IF THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
AND THE CHAIR OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE,
WHEN I HEAR IT NEXT TO TRY TO
GET THIS RIGHT, UM,
AND TO THE EXTENT NOTHING'S
PERFECT
IN SACRAMENTO AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT WE STUMBLE AND MAKE A FEW
MISTAKES,
I WON'T BE HERE NEXT YEAR.
BUT I'M CONFIDENT THAT YOU WILL
RISE FROM YOUR PROFESSIONAL
ENDEAVORS AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE FIX IT.
SO I WON'T BE HERE NEXT YEAR
EITHER.
YOU'LL.
THE LONG ARM OF DOCTOR WOOD WILL
REACH OUT AND MAKE SURE.
PROBABLY NOT GOING AWAY.
THIS RIGHT.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL.
AS SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM,
WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND WE WILL
TAKE A VOTE.
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU AT THE
TABLE,
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
CONTINUING TO PARTICIPATE,
FOR BEING HERE TODAY, FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY,
AND FOR WHAT I ANTICIPATE WILL
BE
YOUR CONTINUED EFFORT TO HELP US
TRY TO GET THIS RIGHT AS IT
MOVES
FORWARD IN THE LEGISLATURE.
SO THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK
YOU, THANK YOU.
DON'T GO ANYWHERE.
DOCTOR.
WOULD I HAVE ANOTHER EASY BILL?
PARDON ME.
YOU HAVE ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB
UNFLAVORED TOBACCO LIST.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I'D FIRST LIKE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF
FOR THEIR EFFORTS ON THIS
MEASURE,
AND I WILL BE ACCEPTING
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
STATE LAW PROHIBITS FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS
IN CALIFORNIA, BUT
UNFORTUNATELY,
THEY REMAIN READILY AVAILABLE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THE HIGH RATE OF FLAVORED
TOBACCO USE
AMONG YOUTH IS ESPECIALLY
CONCERNING.
A 2023 STUDY BY THE CDC
INDICATES THAT AMONG MIDDLE
AND HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO
USE TOBACCO,
NEARLY 90% USE FLAVORED
PRODUCTS.
AB 3218 CREATES A PATHWAY TO
ENSURING
FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS
THAT ARE NO LONGER AVAILABLE
ON THE SHELVES OF RETAILERS
AND IN OUR COMMUNITIES BY
CREATING
AN AFFIRMATIVE LISTING
OF UNFLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCTS
LEGAL IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS APPROACH WILL HELP
RETAILERS
DETERMINE AT A GLANCE WHETHER
A PRODUCT DELIVERED TO THEIR
STORES IS LEGAL OR NOT.
ADDITIONALLY, THE BILL
AUTHORIZES
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
PENALIZE DISTRIBUTORS THAT SELL
ILLEGAL TOBACCO PRODUCTS,
AND MANUFACTURERS THAT FALSELY
CERTIFY
THEIR PRODUCTS ARE UNFLAVORED.
AND FINALLY, THE BILL AUTHORIZES
LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO SEIZE ILLEGAL TOBACCO
PRODUCTS.
THESE COMPREHENSIVE ENFORCEMENT
STEPS WILL HELP IMPLEMENT
THE FLAVORED TOBACCO BAN THE WAY
IT WAS INTENDED.
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT AGAIN,
IS TIFFANY BROKAW WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE AND THE SPONSOR OF THE
BILL.
BYRON MILLER IS WITH THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE,
IS ALSO HERE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
GREETINGS.
PLEASE PROCEED.
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD FIRST.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN, TIFFANY
BROKAW,
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
HERE ON BEHALF OF ATTORNEY
GENERAL ROB BONTA,
WHO IS A PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL,
ALONG WITH CAMPAIGN FOR TOBACCO
FREE KIDS,
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION,
THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY,
AND THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL WOULD LIKE
TO THANK DOCTOR
WOOD FOR CARRYING THIS IMPORTANT
PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WILL ENSURE
THE SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE FLAVORED
TOBACCO BAN.
WHEN THE BAN WENT INTO EFFECT,
OUR OFFICE RECEIVED A NUMBER
OF INQUIRIES
ASKING FOR GUIDANCE AND
ASSISTANCE
WITH EFFECTUATING THE LAW.
OUR OFFICE DRAFTED AB 3218.
IN RESPONSE TO THESE INQUIRIES,
AND AS A NEXT
STEP IN ACCOMPLISHING THE BAND'S
POLICY
GOALS OF GETTING THESE FLAVORED
TOBACCO
PRODUCTS OUT OF THE HANDS OF
OUR YOUTH.
AB 3218 WILL ESTABLISH A
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE LIST
OF ALL TOBACCO PRODUCTS THAT ARE
PERMISSIBLY,
UNFLAVORED AND ALLOWED TO BE
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
THE DEVELOPMENT OF SUCH A LIST
HAS LONG BEEN
A RECOMMENDATION OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES,
WHO HAVE LOOKED TO OUR OFFICE'S
TOBACCO DIRECTORY LIST
AS A LEADING EXAMPLE OF HOW
A PUBLICIZED CURATED LIST
CAN PROVIDE CLARITY TO INDUSTRY
PARTICIPANTS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT ON WHAT PRODUCTS CAN
AND CANNOT BE SOLD.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO RENDER
ILLEGAL FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS CONTRABAND,
SO THAT SUCH PRODUCTS CAN
QUICKLY BE REMOVED
FROM COMMERCE AND NEVER REACH
OUR KIDS.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO HOLD THE
DISTRIBUTION
CHAIN ACCOUNTABLE AT A HIGHER
LEVEL.
IT WILL CLARIFY THE DEFINITION
OF CHARACTERIZING
FLAVOR TO SPECIFICALLY
PROHIBIT PRODUCTS THAT IMPART
MENTHOL
LIKE COOLING SENSATIONS.
OUR OFFICE SAW THAT AFTER
THE FLAVOR BAN WENT INTO EFFECT,
NEW TOBACCO PRODUCTS WERE
INTRODUCED TO THE MARKET,
AIMED TO WORK AROUND THE BAN BY
CLARIFYING THIS DEFINITION.
THE BAN WILL ENCOMPASS THESE
EDGE PRODUCTS AND WORKAROUND
PRODUCTS THAT HAVE BEEN SUBJECT
TO DEBATE AND LITIGATION.
AND AB 3218 WILL ALSO AUTHORIZE
THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO OMIT FROM THE
UNFLAVORED
LIST TOBACCO PRODUCTS LACKING
THE REQUIRED FDA AUTHORIZATION.
AB 3218 WOULD HOLD SELLERS OF
ILLEGAL
TOBACCO PRODUCTS ACCOUNTABLE
AND REDUCE ACCESS TO FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS,
PARTICULARLY AMONG YOUTH WHO
GRAVITATE
TOWARDS THESE TYPES OF PRODUCTS,
PREVENTING THEM FROM ENTERING
A LIFETIME OF ADDICTION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
AND WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> UH, BYRON MILLER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
I'M JUST HERE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
AH, OKAY.
ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE?
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS JAMIE MORGAN.
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION,
A PROUD CO-SPONSOR HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL,
I'D ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS THE
SUPPORT OF
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> CHAIR AND MEMBERS ADAM OGDEN
SMITH
WITH THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY,
CANCER ACTION NETWORK, ALSO
PROUD CO-SPONSOR.
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> TIM GIBBS CAMPAIGN FOR
TOBACCO FREE KIDS.
ALSO A PROUD CO-SPONSOR.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
JESSICA MORAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
>> NEXT.
CELESTE WICKS WITH CLEAN EARTH
FOR KIDS IN SUPPORT.
ALSO IN SUPPORT NORTH COUNTY
EQUITY AND JUSTICE.
ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEEPS FACTS
GRANDPARENTS TAKING ACTION,
MOMS ADVOCATING SUSTAINABILITY
AND CALIFORNIA
NURSES FOR ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
AND JUSTICE.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
AND THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI, TASHA.
WHAT'S WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS AND
SUPPORT?
THANK YOU.
>> RYAN VERDUGO HERE ON BEHALF
OF
KAISER PERMANENTE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
BRANDON MARKEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NOW, LET'S TAKE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION FIRST.
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES, IF
ANY.
YOU MAY TAKE THE TABLE AND WE'LL
TAKE OTHER
OPPOSITION WITNESSES AFTER THAT.
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD.
PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN.
MEMBERS JOHN WINGER, HERE ON
BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FUELS AND
CONVENIENCE ALLIANCE,
WE REPRESENT THE MAJORITY OF
GAS STATIONS
AND CONVENIENCE STORES IN THE
STATE.
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE SPONSORS
FOR THE ONGOING DIALOGUE ON
THE BILL?
I THINK, UM, THE THE DIRECTORY
IS SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE SUPPORTED IN
CONCEPT.
WE WOULD LOVE TO HAVE SOME
STATEWIDE, UH,
GUIDANCE ON WHAT CAN BE SOLD AND
WHAT CAN'T BE SOLD.
WE'VE SEEN A PATCHWORK OF
REGULATORY WORK,
UH, OVER THE YEARS ON THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
AND SO HAVING SOME CERTAINTY
THERE IS SOMETHING
THAT WE WOULD DEFINITELY
ENCOURAGE.
I THINK WE CONTINUE TO HAVE AN
OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THE
BILL.
UH, RELATED TO TWO, UH, THINGS
IN THE BILL.
ONE IS AROUND THE CHARACTERIZING
FLAVOR AND THE CHANGES TO THAT.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS,
WHICH I BELIEVE IS REMOVING
NUMBING
FROM THAT DEFINITION.
BUT WE STILL DO THINK THAT
COOLING
IS A OVERLY SUBJECTIVE
TERM THAT COULD POTENTIALLY
PUSH MORE
PRODUCTS OFF THE SHELF AND PUSH
IT MORE TO THE ILLICIT MARKET,
WHICH WE'VE SEEN OVER THE YEARS.
SO WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS
AROUND THAT.
WE ALSO HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
CONCERNS
AROUND THE AMOUNT OF DISCRETION
THAT
THE AG HAS ON REMOVING LEGAL
TOBACCO
PRODUCTS FROM THE LIST ITSELF.
AND I THINK MY COLLEAGUE TO
THE LEFT
WILL GET A LITTLE MORE INTO
THAT.
BUT FOR THOSE TWO REASONS,
WE DO STILL HAVE AN AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL.
HAVE YOU SUBMITTED LANGUAGE WITH
RESPECT TO COOLING?
UH, I THINK WE'VE JUST ASKED FOR
THAT TO BE REMOVED
FROM THE CHARACTERIZING FLAVOR
DEFINITION.
WE WERE COMFORTABLE OR WE HAVE
ACCEPTED THE THE DEFINITION
THAT WAS WITHIN THE ORIGINAL
BILL, SB 739.
UM, AND SO THE EXPANSION, I
THINK,
IS SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE
OBJECTED TO,
UM, AND CONTINUE TO.
DOES THAT RELATE TO MENTHOL?
NO, I THINK MENTHOL WAS PRETTY
CLEARLY, UM,
BANNED IN THE CHARACTERIZING
FLAVOR.
I THINK COOLING GETS A LITTLE
BIT,
IS A LITTLE BIT MORE SUBJECTIVE.
AND, UM.
COULD BE USED IN A DISCRETIONARY
WAY TO
REMOVE PRODUCTS OFF THE SHELF
THAT
WE DON'T BELIEVE FALL WITHIN
THE DEFINITION
OF A FLAVORED TOBACCO PRODUCT.
THANK YOU.
YES, SIR.
>> MR.
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS, JAMES
JACK,
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CIGAR
ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA.
UM, FIRST, I WANT TO THANK YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK WITH US OVER THIS
PAST WEEK.
AND I ALSO WANT TO EXTEND MY
APPRECIATION TO THE AUTHOR,
HIS STAFF AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE.
WE HAVE HAD EXCELLENT AND
ONGOING DIALOGUE
WITH ALL OF THOSE PARTIES,
AND WE'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF THAT.
UH, FIRST, MR.
CHAIRMAN, I WANT TO STATE FOR
THE RECORD THAT THE CIGAR
ASSOCIATION
STRONGLY SUPPORTS THE CREATION
OF AN UNFLAVORED
TOBACCO LIST TO ADDRESS THE
ENORMOUS
SURGE IN ILLEGAL FLAVORED
TOBACCO PRODUCTS WE'VE SEEN
ACROSS THE STATE.
OUR ISSUE REALLY BOILS DOWN
TO JUST
ONE SINGLE WORD IN THE BILL,
AND THAT WORD IS ADULTERATED.
THE BILL USES A FEDERAL
DEFINITION OF
ADULTERATED AS ONE OF THE
REASONS
THAT THE AG COULD BLOCK A
TOBACCO
PRODUCT FROM THIS LIST.
ADULTERATED MEANS A TOBACCO
PRODUCT THAT REQUIRES
FDA APPROVAL AND HAS NOT
RECEIVED IT.
UM, PROBLEM IS ADULTERATED IS
THE WRONG STANDARD
TO USE BECAUSE THE FDA ITSELF
ALLOWS CERTAIN
TOBACCO PRODUCTS TO BE LEGALLY
SOLD IN THE UNITED STATES,
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE
ADULTERATED.
SPECIFICALLY, THE FDA HAS TOLD
MANUFACTURERS
THAT IF A PRODUCT WAS ON THE
MARKET
PRIOR TO AUGUST 2016 AND APPLIED
FOR
FDA APPROVAL BY SEPTEMBER 2020,
IT MAY CONTINUE TO BE LEGALLY
SOLD IN THE US
UNTIL THE FDA DECIDES ON ITS
APPLICATION.
NOW, THE FDA REPORTS THAT IT
HAS ACTED
ON OVER 99% OF THE WAIT FOR
IT 2.6
MILLION APPLICATIONS THAT IT
HAS RECEIVED.
BUT HERE'S THE PROBLEM THERE ARE
STILL OVER 3000 APPLICATIONS
FOR CIGAR PRODUCTS THAT ARE
STILL PENDING FDA REVIEW.
ALL OF THESE PRODUCTS ARE
ADULTERATED NOT BECAUSE
THERE'S SOMETHING WRONG WITH
THE PRODUCT,
NOT BECAUSE THEY'RE BAD ACTORS,
BUT SIMPLY BECAUSE THE FDA
HASN'T
APPROVED THEIR APPLICATION YET.
THE FDA'S RECOGNIZED THAT THESE
MANUFACTURERS HAVE
DONE EVERYTHING ASKED OF THEM
UNDER THE LAW,
AND IS THEREFORE USING ITS
ENFORCEMENT DISCRETION
TO ALLOW THESE ADULTERATED
PRODUCTS
TO CONTINUE TO BE LEGALLY SOLD
UNTIL
THE FDA DECIDES ON THEIR
APPLICATION.
THAT'S WHY IT'S THE WRONG
STANDARD
TO USE IN THE BILL.
ADULTERATED IS NOT THE STANDARD
THE FDA USES FOR THESE PRODUCTS.
IN FACT, USING THIS STANDARD IN
THE BILL WILL PUT CALIFORNIA IN
DIRECT CONFLICT WITH HOW THE FDA
IS REGULATING THESE PRODUCTS.
SO IN CLOSING, THERE ARE
POTENTIALLY THOUSANDS
OF CIGAR PRODUCTS THAT CANNOT
MEET THIS DEFINITION AND WOULD
BE AT
RISK OF BEING BANNED IN
CALIFORNIA,
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE UNFLAVORED,
HAVE DONE EVERYTHING REQUIRED
OF THEM UNDER THE LAW, AND ARE
LEGAL TO SELL TODAY.
SO WE STRONGLY URGE THE MEMBERS
TO REMEDY THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE BEFORE THE BILL LEAVES
THE SENATE.
THANK YOU.
WELL, IT'S NOT ADULTERATED.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM THEN.
IT'S IF YOU'RE SAYING THERE'S
THERE ARE
THESE ARE UNFLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
UNFLAVORED
VERSUS CHARACTERIZING FLAVOR.
ARE THESE UNFLAVORED TOBACCO
PRODUCTS
THAT ARE PENDING AN APPROVAL?
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN.
BECAUSE WHY DO YOU SAY THEY'RE
ADULTERATED?
WHAT DO WE PUT IN THEM?
I THINK THAT'S A COMMON
MISCONCEPTION.
SO ADULTERATED JUST MEANS THAT
THEY HAVE TO BE APPROVED
BY THE FDA AND THEY HAVE NOT
RECEIVED THAT APPROVAL.
TO YOUR QUESTION, SIR, THAT'S
NOT.
THE COMMON UNDERSTANDING OF
ADULTERATED BECAUSE.
CORRECT.
WE DEAL WITH THAT IN A VARIETY
OF PLACES AND SPOTS
IN WHAT WE DO IN THIS COMMITTEE
AND ELSEWHERE.
YES, ULCERATED MEANS YOU PUT
SOMETHING
IN IT THAT'S NOT NATURALLY
OCCURRING.
CORRECT.
BUT IN THIS CASE, IT JUST MEANS
IT IS
NOT RECEIVED THE REQUIRED
FEDERAL
APPROVAL AND THEREFORE IT IS
ADULTERATED
UNDER THE TOBACCO CONTROL ACT.
THE FEDERAL LAW.
UM, BUT AS I MENTIONED,
THE FDA IS USING ITS ENFORCEMENT
DISCRETION TO ALLOW THESE
PRODUCTS
TO STAY ON THE MARKET
BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE
MANUFACTURER'S
FAULT THAT THE FDA
HASN'T GOTTEN TO ALL OF THESE
APPLICATIONS YET.
AND SO THEY'RE STAYING ON THE
MARKET.
AND AND SO OUR ONLY REQUEST
IS THAT
IF A PRODUCT IS UNFLAVORED
NUMBER ONE AND IS LEGAL TO SELL
UNDER THE FDA,
THAT IT WOULDN'T BE REMOVED FROM
THIS PROPOSED LIST.
WELL, THAT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT,
BECAUSE WHEN YOU IF YOU
PROPOSE LANGUAGE THAT INCLUDES
THE WORD ADULTERATED,
THEN THAT COULD THAT COULD
INCLUDE A LOT OF THINGS,
BUT UNFLAVORED PENDING APPROVAL.
THAT'S YOUR REQUEST OKAY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
YOU SEE?
NONE.
OKAY, BACK TO THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES, COLLEAGUE.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS?
DOCTOR, WOULD THE CIGAR PEOPLE
HAVE AN ISSUE
WITH UNFLAVORED CIGARS THAT ARE
PENDING
APPROVAL OF THE FDA AT THE FDA
LEVEL,
THAT DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
INJECTED IN THEM?
THAT.
COULD, IN THE NORMAL PARLANCE
WOULD WE
WOULD CONSIDER TO BE
ADULTERATED.
HOW DO WE DEAL WITH THAT?
WELL, WE'RE WAITING FOR THE
FDA TO
ACTUALLY DEEM THAT THAT'S
CORRECT.
AND I RECOGNIZE THAT THE FDA
IS BEHIND ON THEIR PROCESS.
BUT I WOULD DISAGREE WITH THE
WITNESS THAT
THAT THESE ARE BEING LEGALLY
SOLD.
THERE ARE ONLY 27 PRODUCTS THAT
I'M AWARE OF.
I THOUGHT THERE WERE LESS,
BUT THERE APPARENTLY THERE ARE
27,
ACCORDING TO OUR FOLKS AT
THE AG THAT ARE DEEMED LEGAL.
WHAT THE WHAT HAS HAPPENED HERE.
IS WHICH MEANS THEY'RE APPROVED
BY THE APPROVED.
THERE AND SO THEY CAN BE LEGALLY
SOLD.
THE FDA HAS CHOSEN NOT TO
ENFORCE.
AGAINST THESE OTHER PRODUCTS.
SO THAT TO TO SAY THAT THEY
ARE BEING
LEGALLY SOLD IS NOT CORRECT.
AND THE OTHER PRODUCTS ARE NOT
INCLUDED ON.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE INCLUDED
ON THIS LIST.
SO I THINK THAT FROM MY
UNDERSTANDING,
I THINK THERE IS SOME THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL
WOULD HAVE DISCRETION TO DECIDE
WHAT
PRODUCTS COULD OR COULD NOT
BE SOLD.
AND I WOULD IMAGINE, ALTHOUGH I
DON'T KNOW FOR SURE,
THAT THEY WOULD BE LOOKING AT,
YOU KNOW, WHAT PRODUCTS ARE
BEFORE THE
THE FDA AND HOW THEY'RE
CHARACTERIZED AND,
AND USE THAT AS A, AS A WAY TO
HELP DECIDE
WHAT THE WHAT'S ON ON THE LIST
OR NOT.
UM, AND I GUESS FOR ME,
PART OF PART OF THIS IS A TRUST
ISSUE.
UH, WE TRUST THAT THIS WE TRUST
THAT THESE ARE UNFLAVORED.
UH, TRUST ME, THEY'RE
UNFLAVORED.
REMEMBER, TRUST ME, IT WAS GOOD
FOR
PREGNANT WOMEN TO SMOKE IN THE
50S.
TRUST ME, TOBACCO DOESN'T CAUSE
CANCER.
AND SO, YES, WHILE THEY HAVE
GONE THROUGH A PROCESS
AND AND HAVE SUBMITTED FOR FDA
APPROVAL,
UNTIL THE FDA ACTUALLY APPROVES
THESE PRODUCTS,
THEY'RE NOT LEGAL TO SELL.
THEY'VE JUST CHOSEN NOT TO
ENFORCE.
AND THE AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
COULD DO LIKEWISE GOING FORWARD.
IN MY IN MY CORRECT IN THE WAY
I READ THE THE BILL PROVISION
AND THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IN THIS CASE, UM,
RECEIVES A SUBMISSION BY A
PRODUCER
MANUFACTURER OF A PRODUCT THAT
INCLUDES A VARIETY OF
CERTIFICATIONS
IN TERMS OF BEING UNFLAVORED
AND DESCRIBES WHETHER OR NOT FDA
APPROVAL HAS BEEN REQUESTED,
CERTIFIES THAT THE BRAND LACKS
A CHARACTERIZING FLAVOR.
THAT HAVING RECEIVED THAT
SUBMISSION,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL COULD
INCLUDE
THE PRODUCT ON THE LIST.
I BELIEVE THAT IS CORRECT.
OKAY.
ANY.
WELL, THERE ARE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS, DOCTOR WOODS.
SO I GUESS YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR INDULGENCE
WITH ME HERE TODAY.
I HAVE BEEN A LONG ADVOCATE FOR
PROTECTING YOUTH FROM TOBACCO.
MY ENTIRE PROFESSIONAL CAREER,
AND I JUST WANT TO BE SURE THAT
IF PRODUCTS ARE ON A LIST,
THAT THEY ARE CERTIFIED AND THEY
ARE NOT FLAVORED.
AND WITH THAT, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE WHEN YOU GET
A QUORUM.
AS SOON AS I FIND A FEW MORE
COLLEAGUES,
WE'LL DO JUST THAT.
WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND WE'LL
TAKE A VOTE.
DOCTOR WOOD, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
OKAY.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB 1830.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA, CORN, MASA,
FLOUR, ETC..
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
>> THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND SENATORS.
I WANT TO START BY THANKING THE
COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL.
SINCE EXPANDING THE BILL, WE'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS,
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS AND
INDUSTRY PARTNERS.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE
TAKEN OVER THIS PAST
MONTH ADDRESS CONCERNS AND
IMPROVE THE BILL.
ALL PREGNANCIES SHOULD BE
SUPPORTED
BY CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE MEANS.
ASSEMBLY BILL 1830 SUPPORTS
HEALTHY
PREGNANCIES BY EXPANDING
MANDATORY
FOLIC ACID FORTIFICATION TO CORN
MASA TO PREVENT BIRTH DEFECTS.
DAILY CONSUMPTION OF FOLIC ACID
DECREASES
THE RISK OF NEURAL TUBE DEFECTS
SUCH AS SPINA BIFIDA AND
ANISOPHYLLEA
BY MORE THAN HALF OF
BABIES WITH SPINA BIFIDA CAN
EXPERIENCE
SYMPTOMS RANGING FROM MILD
NERVE DAMAGE TO SEVERE
PARAPLEGIA
AND CEFALY IS FATAL IN INFANTS.
SINCE NEURAL TUBE DEFECTS OCCUR
IN
THE EARLIEST STAGES OF FETAL
DEVELOPMENT,
IT CAN BE TOO LATE TO TAKE FOLIC
ACID SUPPLEMENTS BY
THE TIME A PERSON KNOWS THAT
THEY ARE PREGNANT.
TO ADDRESS THE HIGH RATE OF
NEURAL TUBE DEFECTS,
THE FDA REQUIRED THAT ALL
ENRICHED CEREAL GRAIN
PRODUCTS BE FORTIFIED WITH FOLIC
ACID IN 1998.
WHILE MASA IS A STAPLE IN MANY
LATINO CUISINES,
MASA WAS ADMITTED FROM THE 1998
MANDATE.
AS A RESULT, LATINOS WERE LEFT
WITHOUT
A CULTURALLY APPROPRIATE WAY
FOR OBTAINING FOLIC ACID IN
THEIR
DIETS THROUGH FORTIFICATION.
UNFORTUNATELY, LATINO
COMMUNITIES
REMAIN AT A DISPROPORTIONATELY
HIGH RISK FOR NEURAL TUBE
DEFECTS.
THE HIGHER RATE OF NEURAL TUBE
DEFECTS IN LATINO COMMUNITIES
IS A SYMPTOM IN THE BROADER
DISEASE OF HEALTH INEQUITY.
MANDATORY FORTIFICATION OF MASA
THROUGH ASSEMBLY
BILL 1830 WILL RIGHT THIS WRONG
AND PREVENT NEW MOTHERS AND
PARENTS FROM
LOSING CHILDREN TO NEURAL TUBE
DEFECTS.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL
1830 IS DOCTOR CLAUDIA LYNN
LOPEZ,
A BOARD CERTIFIED OB GYN AND A
MATERNAL
FETAL MEDICINE SUBSPECIALIST.
DOCTOR.
PLEASE PROCEED.
>> MR.
CHAIR, AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE,
UM, DOCTOR CLAUDIA LOPEZ,
ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE
OF OB GYN'S DISTRICT NINE,
THE SPONSORS OF AB 1830 FOLIC
ACID FORTIFICATION OF CORN,
MASA, FLOUR AND WET CORN MASA
PRODUCTS.
I AM A MATERNAL FETAL MEDICINE
FELLOW AND PRACTICING
OB GYN AT A TERTIARY REFERRAL
CENTER,
WHERE WE SERVE WOMEN FROM THE
CENTRAL VALLEY
OF CALIFORNIA UP TO THE OREGON
BORDER.
MANY OF OUR PATIENTS LIVE IN
RURAL AREAS
WITH LIMITED ACCESS TO HEALTH
CARE,
AND MANY IDENTIFY AS MEMBERS
OF THE LATINO COMMUNITY.
THESE PATIENTS OFTEN DRIVE OVER
THREE HOURS FOR AN ULTRASOUND
APPOINTMENT OR TO SEE A
SPECIALIST SUCH AS MYSELF.
UNFORTUNATELY, MANY OF THE
CONSULTS
WE RECEIVE ARE FOR PATIENTS
WHOSE
BABIES ARE DIAGNOSED WITH A
NEURAL TUBE DEFECT,
SUCH AS SPINA BIFIDA.
TO HELP DECREASE THE INCIDENCE
OF NEURAL TUBE DEFECTS,
THE FDA MANDATED FLOUR TO BE
FORTIFIED
WITH FOLIC ACID IN 1998.
HOWEVER, MASA, A MAJOR STAPLE
OF LATINO AND HISPANIC DIETS,
WAS OMITTED FROM THE MANDATE
WITHOUT JUSTIFICATION.
THIS MANDATE RESULTED IN A 35%
DECREASE IN
THE OCCURRENCE OF NEURAL TUBE
DEFECTS.
HOWEVER, HISPANICS STILL HAVE
A THREE AND A HALF TIMES
HIGHER INCIDENCE THAN THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN.
IMAGINE TELLING SOMEONE WHO
LOOKS LIKE YOU
AND COULD EASILY BE YOUR FAMILY
MEMBER,
OR SOMEONE YOU GREW UP WITH,
THAT THEIR BABY HAS A NEURAL
TUBE
DEFECT THAT THEIR BABY MIGHT
NOT WALK OR EVER CONTROL WHEN
THEY GO TO THE BATHROOM,
THAT THEIR BABY MIGHT NEED A
SHUNT TO
HELP DRAIN FLUID FROM THE BRAIN,
WHICH CARRIES A COMPLICATION
RATE OF UP TO 40%.
EVEN IF THEY'RE A CANDIDATE
AND CAN AFFORD IN UTERO SURGERY,
THE PATH AHEAD IS NOT EASY,
AND UNFORTUNATELY, THESE BABIES
HAVE
MANY OF THE SAME COMPLICATIONS.
YOU SEE THE REALIZATION IN YOUR
PATIENT'S
EYES AS THEY CONTEMPLATE
THE IMPOSSIBLE DECISION OF WHAT
THEIR NEXT STEPS WILL BE.
HOW DO THEY CARE FOR THE KIDS
THEY ALREADY
HAVE AND A NEW SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILD?
DO THEY TERMINATE THE PREGNANCY?
HOW CAN THEY MAKE THIS
IMPOSSIBLE DECISION ALL
THE WHILE KNOWING THAT THIS WAS
PREVENTABLE?
HOW DO I TELL THEM WHY SOMEONE
FROM OUR COMMUNITY HAS
A HIGHER RISK FOR THIS LIFE
ALTERING DIAGNOSIS?
IN THE US, HALF OF ALL
PREGNANCIES ARE UNPLANNED,
AND THE KEY TO NEURAL TUBE
DEFECT PREVENTION
IS HAVING ENOUGH FOLIC ACID IN
YOUR DIET.
FOR MOST MOST PEOPLE, THEY
AREN'T TAKING A PRENATAL
VITAMIN OR TAKING A FOLIC ACID
SUPPLEMENT.
BECAUSE THE PREGNANCY IS NOT
PLANNED
BY FORTIFYING CORN MASA FLOUR,
WE CAN HELP DECREASE THE RISK OF
NEURAL TUBE DEFECTS
AND IMPROVE PERINATAL NUTRITION
IN THIS POPULATION.
WE CAN SHOW THAT WE VALUE AND
PRIORITIZE EQUITABLE
PREVENTATIVE HEALTH CARE FOR
THESE REASONS.
ACOG IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT AND
SPONSOR
AB 1830 AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE.
>> WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND SOME
OF THEM AROUND.
I HAVE ALLERGIES AND MY HEAD IS
FULL OF COTTON.
I'M ROXANNE GOULD, REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN NURSES ASSOCIATION.
MAYBE I SHOULD GO SEE ONE OF
THOSE NURSES ABOUT THIS,
BUT WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
ZYRTEC.
THANK YOU.
YES, MA'AM.
HELLO.
>> ISABELLA ARGUETA WITH THE
HEALTH OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
HI THERE.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
KAREN AMIGONE, ON BEHALF OF
A VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY,
WE WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER
AND HIS STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US IN REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION,
UNLESS AMENDED STANCE.
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
KELLY BROOKS, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
AND THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MA'AM.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, KELLY
MCMILLAN.
ON BEHALF OF MARCH OF DIMES, A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR,
AND THE CHILDREN'S SPECIALTY
CARE COALITION.
THANK YOU.
>> HELLO, HELLO.
>> CHAIR MEMBERS CATHY MOSS WITH
THE FIRST
FIVE ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
HOW ABOUT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION?
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION?
ANY OPPOSITION, WITNESS, LEAD
OR OTHERWISE?
SEEING NONE.
COLLEAGUES.
NO QUESTIONS.
DOCTOR.
THIS IS YOUR LUCKY DAY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT.
WHEN A QUORUM IS PRESENT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN.
I VOTE.
AS SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM,
WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND WE WILL
DO JUST THAT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 9AB
3059.
DOCTOR WEBER, HUMAN MILK.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU, CHAIR ROTH AND
MEMBERS,
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB 3059,
WHICH WILL IMPROVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES
FOR PREMATURE INFANTS.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL.
THIS BILL WILL REQUIRE THAT
COMMERCIAL
HEALTH PLANS INCLUDE COVERAGE
FOR MEDICALLY NECESSARY
PASTEURIZED
DONOR HUMAN MILK,
WHICH IS COMMONLY REFERRED TO
AS DONOR MILK.
IF THE DONOR MILK IS SOURCED
FROM A MILK BANK
WITH AN EXISTING TISSUE BANK
LICENSE,
THE BILL WAIVES THE REQUIREMENT
FOR HOSPITALS
TO ACQUIRE THE SAME LICENSE TO
PROVIDE DONOR MILK TO INFANTS
IN NEONATAL
INTENSIVE CARE UNITS, OR NICUS.
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS RECOMMENDS THAT
WHEN A MOTHER'S OWN MILK IS NOT
AVAILABLE,
THAT DONOR MILK BE PROVIDED TO
VERY LOW BIRTH WEIGHT INFANTS.
THESE ARE VERY SMALL INFANTS
THAT WEIGH £3.3
OR LESS AT BIRTH.
DONOR MILK IS USED IN NICUS TO
SUPPORT THE HEALTH
AND SURVIVAL OF VERY LOW BIRTH
WEIGHT INFANTS,
AND HAS BEEN SHOWN TO REDUCE
THE INCIDENCE OF A DEVASTATING
BOWEL DISEASE KNOWN AS
NECROTIZING
ENTEROCOLITIS OR NEC.
THE INCIDENCE OF NEC IS AROUND
60% HIGHER FOR HISPANIC
AND BLACK INFANTS WHEN COMPARED
TO WHITE INFANTS.
BLACK AND HISPANIC MOTHERS HAVE
LOWER RATES OF PROVIDING MILK
TO THEIR BABIES IN THE NICU DUE
TO A VARIETY OF FACTORS,
INCLUDING HAVING TO RETURN TO
WORK, SIBLING CARE,
LACK OF TRANSPORTATION,
LESS LACTATION SUPPORT OR
RECEIVING LESS CARE,
AND LESS RESOURCE USE.
BY PASSING AB 3059, WE'RE HOPING
TO CLOSE
HEALTH DISPARITIES BEGINNING
AT BIRTH.
>> SORRY.
IT'S OKAY.
DONOR MILK IS A COVERED BENEFIT
UNDER MEDI-CAL,
BUT EXISTING LAW DOES NOT
CLEARLY DEFINE IT AS
A COVERED BENEFIT UNDER
COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLANS.
AB 3059 WOULD ENSURE PARITY AND
REQUIRE
THAT ALL COMMERCIAL HEALTH
PLANS PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR
MEDICALLY
NECESSARY DONOR MILK.
AB 3059 WOULD ALSO ADDRESS A
CHALLENGE
TO ESTABLISHING A DONOR MILK
PROGRAM.
ABOUT 12% OF NICUS IN CALIFORNIA
DO NOT USE DONOR MILK,
AND ONE OF THE MAIN BARRIERS TO
ESTABLISHING
A DONOR MILK PROGRAM
IS THE REQUIREMENT THAT
HOSPITALS
OBTAIN A TISSUE BANK
LICENSE IN ORDER TO STORE AND
DISTRIBUTE THIS MILK.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL
TODAY IS DOCTOR LISA STELLWAGEN,
MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF THE UC
HEALTH MILK BANK,
AND NICOLA DRURY,
A BOARD MEMBER OF THE NEXT
SOCIETY.
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR.
PLEASE PROCEED.
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD FIRST.
>> MY NAME IS DOCTOR LISA
STELLWAGEN.
AND GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR ROTH
AND MEMBERS.
I'M A PEDIATRICIAN AND THE
MEDICAL
DIRECTOR OF THE UC HEALTH
MILK BANK ON BEHALF OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE AS A PROUD SPONSOR TO
EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR AB 3059.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTH
MILK BANK PROVIDES SAFE,
PASTEURIZED HUMAN MILK DONATED
BY BREASTFEEDING PARENTS
TO SUPPORT NICUS AND FAMILIES
STATEWIDE.
OUR MILK BANK OPENED IN 2020 AND
ADDRESSES SHORTAGES
IN DONOR MILK FOR SICK OR SMALL
NEWBORNS,
ENSURING LIFE SAVING MEDICAL
NUTRITION
IN LINE WITH THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRIC PEDIATRICS
RECOMMENDATIONS.
HUMAN MILK CAN BE LIFE SAVING
FOR
THE SMALLEST PREMATURE INFANTS,
REDUCING THE RISK OF NECROTIZING
ENTEROCOLITIS,
ALSO KNOWN AS NEC, A LIFE
THREATENING
AND CATASTROPHIC BOWEL
CONDITION,
AS YOU WILL BE HEARING.
NEC IS EXPENSIVE IN EVERY SENSE
OF THE WORD
TO ALL INVOLVED THE CHILD, THE
FAMILY,
THE HEALTH CARE WORKERS, THE
HOSPITAL,
INSURANCE COMPANIES AND SOCIETY.
THROUGH OUR WORK, WE'VE
IDENTIFIED
SEVERAL BARRIERS THAT PREVENT
CRITICALLY ILL INFANTS FROM
ACCESSING DONOR MILK.
AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM DOCTOR
WEBBER,
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL TO HER FOR
AUTHORING THIS.
BILL TO ADDRESS BARRIERS IN
ACCESS AND TO
HELP IMPROVE SURVIVAL OF BABIES
IN NEED.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I VOTE.
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR.
NEXT PLEASE.
>> CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS NICOLA JURY.
I'M A DOCTORATE EDUCATED
PHYSICIAN
ASSISTANT AND ALSO A MOTHER.
AND TODAY, AS BOTH, I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT
AB 3059 TO PROVIDE MEDICALLY
FRAGILE
INFANTS WITH A LIFE SAVING
PROTECTION
THEY NEED FROM HUMAN MILK.
MY SON RONAN, PICTURED HERE, WAS
BORN AT 28 WEEKS
GESTATION WEIGHING JUST £1, TWO
OUNCES.
HE WAS IMMEDIATELY TAKEN TO
THE NICU
AND BEGAN BEGAN FIGHTING FOR
HIS LIFE.
I FOCUSED ALL MY EFFORTS INTO
ANYTHING
I COULD DO TO HELP HIM,
WHICH AT THE TIME WAS PUMPING
BREAST MILK AFTER SUFFERING
LIFE THREATENING PREGNANCY
COMPLICATIONS.
MYSELF.
MY BODY UNFORTUNATELY PRODUCED
LITTLE TO NONE.
FEEDING AND GROWING IS A HUGE
CHALLENGE AS A MICRO PREEMIES
UNDERDEVELOPED GI SYSTEM IS
EXTREMELY FRAGILE.
I WAS FORTUNATE ENOUGH TO BE
AT A NICU
THAT HAD ACCESS TO DONOR MILK,
WHICH RONAN GOT AS SOON AS HE
WAS ABLE.
CLINICALLY, I KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF HUMAN MILK.
I WAS THANKFUL FOR THIS CRUCIAL
BUT LIMITED RESOURCE.
EVENTUALLY, HE WAS TRANSITIONED
TO FORMULA.
WE FACED TYPICAL UPS AND DOWNS
OF THE NICU,
AND DESPITE PROGRESS,
AFTER SEVEN WEEKS INTO OUR
JOURNEY,
RONAN TOOK A TURN.
HE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
NECROTIZING
ENTEROCOLITIS OR NECK AND NECK,
A DEVASTATING INTESTINAL
INFLAMMATION.
HE HAD TWO SURGERIES WITH SOME
OF THE BEST SURGEONS
IN THE FIELD TO ATTEMPT TO SAVE
HIS LIFE,
BUT SADLY DEVELOPED A FULLY
NECROTIC BOWEL,
LEADING TO SEPSIS.
ON DECEMBER 20TH, 2020,
RONAN TOOK HIS LAST BREATH IN.
MY ARMS.
NECK COMES ON FAST AND
AGGRESSIVELY.
I WENT FROM DREAMING OF THE DAY
I WOULD BRING
RONAN HOME TO PLANNING HIS
FUNERAL.
THE SINGLE GREATEST PREDICTOR
AGAINST
NECK IS MOTHER'S MILK,
AND WHEN NOT AVAILABLE,
DONOR BREAST MILK IS THE NEXT
BEST OPTION.
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT THIS
CAN DECREASE
NECK THE RISK OF NECK BY AS MUCH
AS 50%.
AFTER RONAN'S DEATH, I CONNECTED
WITH THE NEXT
SOCIETY A NONPROFIT FOUNDED BY
ANOTHER MOTHER
WHO LOST A CHILD FROM THIS
DEVASTATING DISEASE
AND FOCUSED ON BUILDING A WORLD
WITHOUT IT.
THIS IS HOW I PARENT MY SON.
I HAVE READ NUMEROUS RESEARCH
ARTICLES
PUBLISHED ABOUT THIS DISEASE.
I HAVE LIVED THROUGH THE
DEVASTATION
AND DONOR BREAST MILK MAKES A
DIFFERENCE.
ALL BABIES IN THE NICU NEED
ACCESS TO BREAST MILK,
REGARDLESS OF LOCATION OR
SOCIOECONOMIC STATUS,
AND MOTHER'S MILK IS NOT ALWAYS
AN OPTION.
LIKE IN MY CASE, AB 3059 WILL
PROTECT FAMILIES
FROM SAYING GOODBYE TO THEIR
BABIES.
I BEG YOU TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA
HAVE ACCESS TO THIS VITALLY
IMPORTANT RESOURCE,
AND THAT YOU JOIN ME IN TAKING
A STEP TOWARD BUILDING
A WORLD WITHOUT THIS HORRENDOUS
DISEASE.
WE ARE SO SORRY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE, PLEASE.
UH, THANK YOU, MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS, DAVID GONZALEZ,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> MARGARET GLADSTONE SPOKE ON
BEHALF
OF PROLACTA BIOSCIENCE.
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR,
THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS FOR
WORKING WITH US TO REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION
WILL NOW GLADLY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS AND THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
YES, SIR.
>> RYAN SPENCER ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OB GYN'S DISTRICT NINE, IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BRANDON MARKEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANKS.
KELLY MACMILLAN ON BEHALF OF
CHILDREN'S
SPECIALTY CARE COALITION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> VANESA GONZALEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MA'AM.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
ANY OTHER WITNESSES?
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION,
LEAD OR OTHERWISE?
SEEING NONE.
I'LL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS?
SEEING NONE, DOCTOR, YOU MAY
CLOSE.
WELL, THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN TO
THE COMMITTEE.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK BOTH OF
MY WITNESSES
WHO CAME HERE TO TESTIFY.
UM, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TELLING YOUR STORY.
THE REALITY IS, IS THAT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT VERY LOW BIRTH WEIGHT
INFANTS,
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON THAT THE
MOTHER
IS UNABLE TO TO ACTUALLY
LACTATE,
BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BABIES
THAT HAVE BEEN BORN VERY,
VERY EARLY AND OFTENTIMES IN
EMERGENT SITUATIONS.
AND SO YOU DON'T HAVE THE THE
HORMONES
THAT ACTUALLY BRING ON LABOR,
WHICH ALSO ALLOW YOU TO LACTATE.
AND SO MANY MOST OF THESE BABIES
REQUIRE DONOR MILK.
AND SO IN ORDER TO DECREASE THE
CHANCES THAT THEY
DEVELOP NECK AND HAVE TO GO
THROUGH SURGERIES.
UM.
WHETHER THEY ARE ABLE TO SURVIVE
OR NOT,
THEN WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS VERY PREVENTABLE,
UM, FORM OF TREATMENT.
AND WITH THAT,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I VOTE
ON AB 3059.
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR, FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
AS SOON AS WE SECURE A QUORUM,
WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND WE'LL
DO JUST THAT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US, BOTH
OF YOU.
LET'S.
YEAH.
OKAY, LET'S TURN TO ITEM NUMBER
22.
AB 3260.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN.
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE, REVIEWS
AND GRIEVANCES.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
>> THANK YOU, CHAIR AND
SENATORS,
I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS
AND SINCERELY THANK THE
CONSULTANT FOR
ALL OF HER HARD WORK ON THIS
BILL.
FAR TOO OFTEN, CALIFORNIANS
DON'T RECEIVE THE CARE
THEY NEED IN A TIMELY AND
APPROPRIATE MANNER,
AND HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS
DO NOT CONSISTENTLY DECIDE OR
PROVIDE PROPER NOTICE OF THEIR
DECISIONS CONCERNING CLAIMS.
THIS LEADS CONSUMERS TO BEAR
THE FINANCIAL COSTS OF
PRESCRIBED
CARE WHILE WAITING FOR A
RESPONSE
FROM THEIR HEALTH PLAN,
OR TO FOREGO TREATMENT
ALTOGETHER
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT
AFFORD TO PAY FOR THEIR CARE
OUT OF POCKET.
THIS BILL ADDRESSES TWO PROBLEMS
FIRST,
THE UNTIMELY RESOLUTION OF
CLAIMS AND GRIEVANCES
BY HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS,
AND SECOND, A LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY IN DUE PROCESS.
WHEN CONSUMERS FILE REGULATORY
COMPLAINTS.
TO ADDRESS THE FIRST CONCERN,
THIS BILL WILL HARMONIZE
STATE LAW WITH FEDERAL LAW
REGARDING THE TIMELINE
FOR RESPONDING TO CLAIMS FOR
COVERAGE AND HOW
CLAIMS FOR URGENT CONDITIONS
ARE TREATED.
THE BILL ALSO ADDS AN IMPORTANT
PROTECTION FOR THOSE
WITH DEGENERATIVE CONDITIONS,
SUCH AS MS.,
PRIORITIZING TREATMENT THAT CAN
MINIMIZE THE LOSS OF FUNCTION,
INSTEAD OF ONLY THOSE TREATMENTS
WHICH CAN
RESTORE THE PATIENT TO FULL
FUNCTION.
THIS ENSURES THAT THESE PATIENTS
RECEIVE THE CARE THEY NEED,
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THEY WILL
LIKELY
NEVER RETURN TO FULL CARE.
FULL HEALTH CARE DELAYED IS CARE
DENIED.
THEREFORE, WHEN HEALTH PLANS
DON'T RESPOND
TO REQUESTS FOR CARE IN A TIMELY
MANNER,
THIS BILL PROVIDES AN INTERNAL
GRIEVANCE WILL AUTOMATICALLY
BE INITIATED INITIATED ON A
CONSUMER'S BEHALF.
THE BILL THEN CLARIFIES
THE TIMELINE AND NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR GRIEVANCES,
AGAIN BRINGING STATE LAW INTO
ACCORDANCE WITH FEDERAL LAW.
IF A HEALTH PLAN ALSO FAILS TO
RESPOND TO
A GRIEVANCE WITHIN THE REQUIRED
TIMELINES,
THAT GRIEVANCE WILL
AUTOMATICALLY
RESOLVE IN FAVOR OF THE
CONSUMER,
MEANING THEY CAN GET CARE WITH
THE ASSURANCE THAT IT WILL BE
COVERED.
THIS PROVISION FOLLOWS THE LEAD
OF 12 OTHER STATES,
RANGING RANGING FROM ARKANSAS
TO GEORGIA TO NEW YORK,
WHICH HAVE EQUIVALENT
PROVISIONS.
THIS DOES NOT APPLY IN THE CASE
OF
INCOMPLETE GRIEVANCE REQUESTS,
OR WHERE A REQUEST IS FOR
EXPERIMENTAL TREATMENT,
WHERE MORE RESEARCH MAY BE
NEEDED.
LAST YEAR, DMHC FOUND THAT OUR
STATE'S
LARGEST HEALTH PLAN HAD FAILED
TO
RESOLVE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
GRIEVANCES
WITHIN THE REQUIRED TIME FRAME.
THIS BILL PROVIDES A STRONG
INCENTIVE FOR THESE
DISPUTES TO BE RESOLVED IN A
TIMELY MANNER,
REDUCING THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
PATIENT CONDITIONS WORSEN
AND SUBSEQUENTLY REQUIRE MORE
INTENSIVE
AND COSTLY TREATMENT.
WHILE THEY ARE STUCK IN LIMBO
WAITING
FOR A HEALTH PLAN RESPONSE.
TO ADDRESS THE SECOND CONCERN,
THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
AND DUE PROCESS IN REGULATORY
COMPLAINTS,
THIS BILL REQUIRES THAT PLANS
OR INSURERS OFFER COPIES OF
ALL COMMUNICATIONS WITH DMHC
TO THE ENROLLEE OR INSURED,
AND PROMPTLY PROVIDE THOSE
RECORDS
IF THE ENROLLEE OR INSURED WANTS
THEM.
AB 3260 WILL IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY BY
ALLOWING THE CONSUMER TO KNOW
WHAT
INFORMATION HAS BEEN SUBMITTED
TO
THE PLAN SHOULD THEY SO DESIRE.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE CURRENT
REALITY AROUND
COMPLAINTS DISADVANTAGES
CONSUMERS
WHO SEE OR HEAR LITTLE WHILE
THEIR
COMPLAINT IS BEING REVIEWED.
HEALTH PLANS AND INSURERS, ON
THE OTHER HAND,
ENJOY FREQUENT AND REGULAR
COMMUNICATION
WITH REGULATORS.
WHILE HEALTH PLANS FAIL TO
FOLLOW THE LAW,
CONSUMERS SUFFER THE
CONSEQUENCES.
THESE COSTS FALL PARTICULARLY
HARD
ON UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES,
WHERE PATIENTS CANNOT AFFORD
TO PAY CARE
FOR CARE OUT OF POCKET WHILE
THEY WAIT
FOR HEALTH PLANS TO RESPOND
TO THEIR
CLAIMS OR RESOLVE THEIR
GRIEVANCES.
TAXPAYERS IN OUR COUNTIES ALSO
BEAR A COST,
BECAUSE MANY OF THESE SAME
PATIENTS WILL SEEK
CARE FROM PUBLIC SERVICES IN
THE MEANTIME,
AB 3260 HAS ENJOYED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT BECAUSE IT WILL
IMPROVE PROCESSES FOR ALL
MEDICAL SURGICAL ISSUES.
I'M ESPECIALLY EAGER TO SEE THE
IMPROVEMENTS
THIS MEASURE WILL MAKE FOR THOSE
SEEKING TREATMENT FOR BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS,
AS THESE ARE AMONG THE AREAS
WHERE PATIENTS STRUGGLE
MOST TO GET TIMELY AND
APPROPRIATE CARE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF AB 3260
IS DOCTOR KARIN SACCO AND LAUREN
FINK.
LAUREN FINK IS THE SENIOR
DIRECTOR
OF POLICY FOR THE KENNEDY FORUM.
BENJAMIN ECKERT FROM THE
NATIONAL
UNION OF HEALTH CARE
WORKERS IS ALSO HERE FOR ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD.
BEFORE YOU SPEAK.
I'LL LET YOU DECIDE WHO MOVES
FIRST.
AND REMEMBER, WE HAVE ABOUT
SIX MINUTES FOR THE SIDE.
>> OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
I'M DOCTOR KARIN MCINTOSH SACCO.
I AM A DUAL LICENSED MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL.
I'M LICENSED AS BOTH A MARRIAGE
AND FAMILY
THERAPIST AND AS A PSYCHOLOGIST.
I HAVE OVER 20 YEARS.
OF EXPERIENCE HELPING PEOPLE
WITH
A RANGE OF PRESENTING ISSUES,
FROM SITUATIONAL STRESSORS TO
SEVERE
MENTAL HEALTH CONCERNS.
AND I'VE WORKED IN A VARIETY
OF SETTINGS,
INCLUDING SCHOOLS,
COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH CENTERS,
GROUP HOMES, AND INTENSIVE
OUTPATIENT
TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
I CURRENTLY PROVIDE DIRECT
CLINICAL SERVICES TO
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS IN MY
OUTPATIENT PRACTICE.
THERE HAVE BEEN TIMES IN WHICH
MY PROFESSIONAL TRAINING
AND EXPERTISE LEAD ME TO
DETERMINE THAT A CLIENT
I'M SERVING MAY NEED A HIGHER
LEVEL OF CARE THAN MY
OUTPATIENT PRACTICE CAN PROVIDE,
IN SOME CASES,
ONCE OR TWICE WEEKLY OUTPATIENT
THERAPY DOES NOT PROVIDE
THE CARE NEEDED TO MANAGE SEVERE
MENTAL HEALTH SYMPTOMS,
AND WHEN THIS HAPPENS,
TRANSITIONING TO THAT HIGHER
LEVEL OF CARE IS URGENT AND
MEDICALLY NECESSARY.
WHEN SOMEONE IS MEETING CRITERIA
FOR
THIS ESCALATION OF TREATMENT,
THEY ARE OFTEN DEBILITATED BY
THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH SYMPTOMS SUCH AS MOOD
INSTABILITY,
ISOLATION, TEARFULNESS, SLEEP
DISTURBANCE,
HOPELESSNESS, LOSS OF INTEREST,
PANIC ATTACKS, INTENSE FEAR, AND
SUICIDAL IDEATION.
THEIR FUNCTIONING BECOMES
MODERATELY
TO SIGNIFICANTLY
IMPAIRED DUE TO THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH SYMPTOMS,
AND THEY EXPERIENCE A
DETERIORATION
IN THEIR PERFORMANCE
OF RESPONSIBILITIES AT HOME,
SCHOOL, AND OR WORK.
DUE TO THE SIGNIFICANT EMOTIONAL
DISTRESS
SOMEONE IS EXPERIENCING AT THE
TIME,
A RECOMMENDATION FOR A HIGHER
LEVEL OF CARE IS MADE.
IT'S ONLY MADE WORSE WHEN THEIR
HEALTH PLAN FAILS TO
AUTHORIZE THE REFERRAL FOR A
HIGHER LEVEL OF CARE,
OR WORSE, FAILS TO RESPOND TO
THAT REFERRAL AT ALL.
I HAVE WITNESSED MANY CLIENTS
LANGUISH OR EXPERIENCE
AN EXACERBATION OF THEIR ALREADY
HEIGHTENED
EMOTIONAL DISTRESS DUE TO
ATTEMPTING TO NAVIGATE
THEIR HEALTH PLANS REFERRAL
SYSTEM,
ONLY TO LEARN THAT THEIR HEALTH
PLAN HAS
NOT PROCESSED THE REFERRAL OR
WORSE,
HAS DENIED THE REFERRAL FOR
CARE.
AB 3260 WOULD ALLEVIATE THE
UNDUE HARDSHIP
FOR CONSUMERS BY REQUIRING
HEALTH PLANS TO INITIATE A
GRIEVANCE ON A CONSUMER'S
BEHALF WHEN THEY FAIL TO RESPOND
TO CLAIMS WITHIN THE TIME
PERIOD AND IN THE MANNER
REQUIRED BY EXISTING LAW.
AB 3260 WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
HEALTH
PLANS AND DISABILITY INSURERS
TO AUTOMATICALLY RESOLVE
GRIEVANCES
IN FAVOR OF THE CONSUMER
IF THEY DO NOT RESPOND WITHIN
THE LEGALLY REQUIRED TIME FRAME,
72 HOURS FOR URGENT CASES
AND 30 DAYS FOR NON URGENT
CASES.
THE AUTOMATIC INITIATION OF
AGREEMENTS WOULD
BE LIFE CHANGING FOR MANY
INDIVIDUALS,
AS CURRENTLY THIS RESPONSIBILITY
FALLS ON
THEM AND MANY DON'T HAVE THE
ENERGY OR
THE MENTAL CAPACITY REQUIRED TO
NAVIGATE THIS
ADMINISTRATIVE AND BUREAUCRATIC
PROCESS,
ESPECIALLY AT A TIME WHEN
THEY'RE DEBILITATED
BY THEIR MENTAL HEALTH SYMPTOMS.
ULTIMATELY, AB 3260, IN PRACTICE
TRANSLATES
TO CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
RECEIVING THE LEVEL OF CARE
THEY NEED AND THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
MR..
>> THANK YOU, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I'M LAUREN FINK,
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF POLICY AT THE
KENNEDY FORUM.
WE'RE PROUD CO-SPONSORS OF AB
3260.
CALIFORNIA HAS ROBUST CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS
FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
CARE,
BOTH IN SB 855 GROUNDBREAKING
PARITY LAWS
AND AN SB 221 TIMELY ACCESS
PROTECTIONS.
WHILE THESE LAWS ARE CLEAR AND
ROBUST,
THEY ARE PROTECTIVE.
STRENGTH IS DEPENDENT ON PLAN
COMPLIANCE
AND REGULATOR ENFORCEMENT.
AB 3260 STRENGTHENS PROTECTIONS
FOR PATIENTS
FACING DELAYS OR DENIALS IN
CARE,
ENSURING HEALTH PLANS ADHERE
TO STATE LAWS
AND THAT REGULATORS ENFORCE
THEM.
AS WE'VE HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE
TODAY,
COMMERCIALLY INSURED PATIENTS
OFTEN FACE DELAYS OR DENIALS
WHEN SEEKING MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION CARE.
HEALTH PLANS REGULARLY FAIL TO
APPROVE CARE WITHIN
LEGAL TIMELINES OR UNJUSTLY DENY
COVERAGE,
ALTHOUGH PATIENTS CAN SEEK
RECOURSE.
THAT PROCESS IS SLOW, OPAQUE,
AND OFTEN RESULTS IN DELAYED OR
DENIED TREATMENT.
THE TYPICAL PROCESS INVOLVES A
PATIENT OR PROVIDER
REQUESTING AUTHORIZATION FROM
THE HEALTH PLAN.
IF DENIED, PATIENTS CAN FILE
AN INTERNAL
GRIEVANCE WITH THEIR PLAN,
AND IF THAT FAILS, THEY CAN
ISSUE
A COMPLAINT WITH REGULATORS.
WHEN HEALTH PLANS DO NOT COMPLY
WITH LEGAL
TIMELINES AND NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS,
PATIENTS GET STUCK IN LIMBO
WAITING
FOR RESPONSES AND RESOLUTIONS.
LAST YEAR, IN A SETTLEMENT WITH
OUR
STATE'S LARGEST HEALTH PLAN,
THE DMHC FOUND THAT IN JUST A
FEW MONTHS,
THOUSANDS OF GRIEVANCES WERE
UNRESOLVED
WITHIN LEGALLY MANDATED TIME
FRAMES,
IMPACTING TIMELY ACCESS TO
BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SERVICES.
THESE PRACTICES MUST STOP.
AB 3260 AUTOMATES THIS
RESOLUTION
PROCESS FOR UNRESOLVED CLAIMS
AND GRIEVANCES WHEN HEALTH PLANS
EXCEED THE LEGAL TIME FRAMES.
IT ALSO IMPROVES TRANSPARENCY
BY PROVIDING CLEAR TIMEFRAMES
FOR RESPONSES DURING THE
GRIEVANCE PROCESS ITSELF.
AB 3260 OFFERS EFFICIENT
AND FAIR CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
TO ADDRESS RAMPANT HEALTH PLAN
VIOLATIONS,
WHICH WERE CITED AT LENGTH IN
LAST OCTOBER SELECT
COMMITTEE ON MENTAL HEALTH AND
ADDICTION HEARING.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE.
DAVID GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT PLEASE.
CRAIG PULSIFER, ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
UH, CHARLIE STONE,
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
ORTHOPAEDIC ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> JENNIFER ROBLES WITH HEALTH
ACCESS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT NEXT.
THANK YOU.
MEGAN LOPER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
>> SANDRA POOLE WITH WESTERN
CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS
AND ON BEHALF OF THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> TYLER INDY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
PSYCHOLOGICAL ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DYLAN ELLIOTT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS,
PLEASED TO BE CO-SPONSORS,
AS WELL AS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT
PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> LANGLEY.
ON BEHALF OF ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE.
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO, KELLY MACMILLAN, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY THERAPISTS.
THANK YOU.
>> HI, JULIE NIELSEN ON BEHALF
OF THE NATIONAL
UNION OF HEALTHCARE WORKERS.
PROUD SPONSOR AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> RAMON CASTIBLANCO ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR RETIRED AMERICANS
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> GRACE HARRISON WITH THE
STEINBERG
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT.
THANKS.
>> VANESSA KAHINA ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
AND THE CALIFORNIA ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
>> JENNIFER SNYDER ON BEHALF OF
THE PHYSICIANS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES.
FEEL FREE TO JOIN US AT
THE IN THE WELL AT THE TABLE.
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD
AND FLIP A COIN AS TO WHO GOES
FIRST.
>> UH, GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, UH, JET HAMPTON
WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS HERE.
REGRETTABLY, IN OPPOSITION TO
AB 3260.
UH, FIRST AND FOREMOST,
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR
AND HER STAFF FOR ENGAGING WITH
US INITIALLY ON THE BILL.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR FOR WORKING WITH US,
ENGAGING WITH US ON THE BILL
AS WELL.
I WILL SAY AT THIS POINT, WE,
UM, YOU KNOW,
ARE STILL REVIEWING THE
AMENDMENTS IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THAT WERE
INDICATED.
UH, THERE IS A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT TO GO OVER.
SO WE ARE WE ARE TAKING OUR TIME
TO ENSURE THAT, UH, YOU KNOW,
JUST TO GET A BETTER SENSE OF
WHERE OUR
MEMBER PLANS ARE ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
I WILL SAY IT DOES LOOK LIKE
SOME OF OUR CONCERNS
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN
ADDRESSED.
UM, I WOULD ALSO SAY THAT THERE
ARE SOME, UH,
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
ON, UH,
SPECIFICALLY RELATED TO SOME OF
THE COMMUNICATION PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL WITH BETWEEN HEALTH
PLANS AND THEIR ENROLLEES.
SO, AGAIN, SHOULD THE BILL MOVE
FORWARD TODAY?
UM, WE WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE
AND THE SPONSORS A LITTLE BIT
MORE JUST TO CLARIFY THAT.
BUT AGAIN, APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS.
WE'RE STILL REVIEWING THEM AND
HOPE TO FOLLOW
UP WITH WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSOR SOON.
BUT AS FOR THE BILL IN PRINT
TODAY,
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
AB 3260.
THANK YOU.
WELL, THANK YOU FOR TAKING A
LOOK,
AND THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING TO
WORK ON THOSE WITH THE AUTHOR.
WE APPRECIATE THAT.
YES, MA'AM.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
KATIE ANDREW WITH LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS OF CALIFORNIA.
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE HERE, WE ARE
STILL COMBING
THROUGH ALL OF THE AMENDMENTS.
UM, BUT AS IS, AS THE BILL IS
NOW IN PRINT,
UM, ARE GOING TO REMAIN OPPOSED.
BUT LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
AND TRYING TO GET THIS BILL
INTO A REALLY GOOD PLACE.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF,
UM, FOR THE AMENDMENTS.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
STAFF'S THE BEST.
YES.
THANK YOU FOR WORKING.
THANK YOU FOR WORKING THROUGH
THE AMENDMENTS.
THERE ARE A FEW AND FOR
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR TO MAKE THIS A BETTER
MEASURE.
SO THANK YOU.
YES, SIR.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN
WINGER,
ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS WITH.
JUST ECHO THE COMMENTS TO CAP.
THANK YOU.
YES, MA'AM.
CHLOE SHINN ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES?
SEEING NONE, I GUESS THERE'S
NOBODY TO BRING
IT BACK TO ON THE DAIS EXCEPT
ME.
SO IT'S YOUR LUCKY DAY, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
WELL, WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE.
LISTEN INTENTLY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND THANK YOU AGAIN TO YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF.
THEY WERE PHENOMENAL.
AND I WANT TO THANK MY STAFF
AS WELL,
RIHANNA AND DID INCREDIBLE WORK
ON THIS BILL.
AND WITH THAT, AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME
I ASKED FOR YOUR I VOTE AS SOON.
AS WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE
A MOTION AND WE WILL DO JUST
THAT.
THANK YOU ALL FOR PARTICIPATING.
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON I SEE.
LET'S.
WITH YOUR PERMISSION, WE'LL TAKE
ITEM NUMBER 12,
AB 2,301ST MEDICAL DEVICES DEHP.
PROCEED WHEN READY.
WELL, GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR,
AND SOON TO BE AT SOME POINT,
SENATORS.
UM, I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
THANKING
THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION YOU AND I HAD.
UM, IT WAS VERY THOUGHTFUL
AND HELPED GET US TO A GOOD
PLACE.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2300,
A BILL, UM,
THAT PROHIBITS THE MANUFACTURERS
SALE OR DISTRIBUTION
OF INTRAVENOUS SOLUTION
CONTAINERS AND TUBING
MADE WITH INTENTIONALLY ADDED
DEHP.
DEHP BELONGS TO A FAMILY OF
HORMONALLY
ACTIVE INDUSTRIAL CHEMICAL
CALLED.
AND I ALWAYS MESS IT UP PLATES.
I THINK THAT'S HOW IT SETS, UM,
WHICH ARE USED TO MAKE PLASTIC
SOFT AND PLIABLE AND CAN BE
FOUND
IN A MYRIAD OF PRODUCTS,
RANGING FROM GARDEN HOSES TO
SHOWER CURTAINS
TO VINYL FLOORING AND BUILDING
MATERIALS,
PARTICULARLY THOSE MADE FROM
PVC PLASTICS.
NOW, DEHP IMPACTS THE THYROID
AND IMMUNE SYSTEM.
RESEARCH INDICATES THAT DEHP
PROMOTES DRUG RESISTANCE
AND INHIBITS THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF BREAST CANCER DRUGS,
INTERFERES WITH THE ABILITY OF
CHEMOTHERAPIES
TO FIGHT BREAST CANCER,
AND THAT PATIENTS WITH HIGHER
LEVELS
OF DEHP IN THEIR SYSTEM
HAVE HAD HIGHER RATES OF RELAPSE
AND MORTALITY.
NOW, DEHP IS COMMONLY USED TO
IMPART FLEXIBILITY
TO IV BAGS AND IV TUBING.
SOME IV BAGS AND TUBING CAN
CONTAIN
UP TO 40% OF DEHP BY WEIGHT.
DEHP HAS BEEN SHOWN TO LEACH
OUT OF IV BAGS AND TUBING,
AND INTO THE MEDICATION AND
OTHER FLUIDS BEING
INFUSED INTO THE BLOODSTREAM
OF PATIENTS.
NOW, THE GOOD NEWS IS, IS THAT
SAFER ALTERNATIVES
EXIST AND ARE ALREADY BEING
ISSUED.
SORRY, BEING USED IN FDA
APPROVED DEHP FREE IV BAGS.
NOW, FOR EXAMPLE, SOME
MANUFACTURERS ARE ALREADY
EXCLUSIVELY MANUFACTURING DEHP
FREE IV BAGS
AND OTHER MANUFACTURERS ALSO
OFFER A LARGE PORTFOLIO
OF FDA APPROVED NON DEHP IV
BAGS.
SO THIS BILL WOULD CURRENTLY BAN
IV SOLUTIONS
CONTAINERS WITH INTENTIONALLY
ADDED DEHP BEGINNING 2030 AND
IV TUBING BY 2035.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ALLOW
FOR
FLEXIBILITY TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
ABOUT POSSIBLE SUPPLY CHAIN
SHORTAGES
AND ADMINISTRATIVE HOLD UPS,
SPECIFICALLY AS IT RELATES TO
THE FDA APPROVAL PROCESS,
WHICH IS COMPLETELY OUTSIDE OF
A COMPANY
OR A MANUFACTURER'S, UH,
CONTROL.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THE ROBUST CONVERSATIONS
WE'VE HAD,
UM, SINCE THIS BILL
INTRODUCTION.
NOW, WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT
IS DOCTOR CLAUDIA LYNN LOPEZ,
WHO IS A MEMBER OF ACOG, AND
KATRINA DUNN
WITH CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH
NETWORK.
WELCOME.
PLEASE PROCEED.
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR THE
RECORD FIRST, PLEASE.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS KATRINA DUNN AND I
REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA BLACK HEALTH NETWORK.
WE ARE ONE OF THE BILL SPONSORS
OF AB 2300,
ALONG WITH BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS
AND AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OB-GYN
DISTRICT NINE.
I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST THANK
THE AUTHOR AND THE STAFF,
AS WELL AS COMMITTEE CHAIR
AND THE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
US.
THE PRESENCE OF DEHP AND IV BAGS
AND TUBING
POSES A SERIOUS PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERN,
AS WELL AS A HEALTH EQUITY
THREAT,
PARTICULARLY FOR BLACK WOMEN.
BLACK WOMEN ALREADY FACE HIGHER
EXPOSURE
TO TOXIC CHEMICALS DUE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL,
OCCUPATIONAL AND CONSUMER
PRODUCT FACTORS,
EXACERBATING HEALTH DISPARITIES.
EMERGING SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
INDICATES
THAT CERTAIN CHEMICAL EXPOSURES,
INCLUDING DEHP, INCREASE THE
RISK
OF BREAST CANCER IN BLACK WOMEN.
DESPITE HAVING A LOWER INCIDENCE
OF BREAST CANCER,
BLACK WOMEN EXPERIENCE HIGHER
MORTALITY
RATES FROM THE DISEASE.
DEHP AND IV BAGS AND TUBING
WORSENS THE SITUATION,
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE WITH
TRIPLE
NEGATIVE BREAST CANCER.
A MORE AGGRESSIVE AND
CHALLENGING TO TREAT
SUBTYPE OF CANCER THAT
DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS BLACK WOMEN AT THREE
TIMES
THE RATE OF OTHER RACIAL ETHNIC
GROUPS,
HIGHLIGHTING THE URGENCY TO
ELIMINATE
DEHP FROM IV BAGS AND TUBING.
TO MITIGATE THIS DISPARITY AND
IMPROVE
HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
A OPPOSITION IS LED BY BAXTER
INTERNATIONAL,
THE LARGEST SUPPLIER OF THE
TOXIC DEHP,
CONTAINING IV BAGS AND TUBING,
AND THEY HAVE BEEN
SEEKING DELAYS IN IMPLEMENTING
THE BAN ON DEHP.
IT IS WORTH NOTING THAT OTHER
MANUFACTURERS OF
IV BAGS AND TUBING ARE NOT
REQUESTING DELAYS,
AND ARE PREPARED TO MEET
THE DEMAND FOR FDA APPROVED,
DEHP FREE IV BAGS IN CALIFORNIA.
AS A REGISTERED NURSE WITH OVER
26 YEARS OF EXPERIENCE,
I HAVE WITNESSED FIRSTHAND THE
IMPACT OF TOXIC
CHEMICAL EXPOSURES ON OUR
PATIENTS,
PARTICULARLY THOSE FROM
VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES IN RURAL HOSPITALS.
USING DEHP FREE MEDICAL DEVICES
IS NOT JUST A MATTER OF SAFETY,
IT'S A MATTER OF HEALTH EQUITY.
BY CONTINUING TO USE DEHP
CONTAINING IV BAGS,
WE ARE EXACERBATING EXISTING
HEALTH DISPARITIES
AND PUTTING OUR PATIENTS AT
UNNECESSARY RISK.
TRANSITIONING TO SAFER
ALTERNATIVES
NOW IS CRUCIAL FOR
PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND LIVES
OF ALL PATIENTS,
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO ARE ALREADY
AT A HIGHER RISK.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN I
VOTE AND OPPOSE ANY
UNNECESSARY DELAYS IN ITS
IMPLEMENTATION.
ENSURING THE TIMELY PHASEOUT OF
DEHP WILL PROTECT
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS FROM
POTENTIALLY
LIFE THREATENING EXPOSURE AND
IMPROVE
HEALTH ACROSS ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR.
NEXT DOCTOR.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
DOCTOR CLAUDIA LOPEZ, ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OB GYN'S DISTRICT
NINE,
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
2300,
THE TOXIC MEDICAL FREE DEVICES
ACT.
ACOG IS A PROUD CO-SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL AS A MATERNAL
FETAL MEDICINE FELLOW AND
PRACTICING OB GYN,
I APPLAUD THIS COMMON SENSE
LEGISLATION,
WHICH WOULD PHASE OUT THE USE
OF DEHP
IN IV BAGS AND TUBING IN
CALIFORNIA.
DEHP IS A TOXIC CHEMICAL KNOWN
TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO CAUSE CANCER AND
BIRTH DEFECTS.
ESPECIALLY CONCERNING ARE THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS
IT CAN HAVE ON THE DEVELOPING
FETUS.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC,
EXPOSURE DURING PREGNANCY MAY
LEAD TO PRETERM BIRTH.
DELAYED MENTAL HEALTH
DEVELOPMENT AND ALTERED
TIMING OF PUBERTY IN THE CHILD.
STUDIES OUT OF HARVARD HAD
DEMONSTRATED
THAT PATIENTS WITH HIGHER LEVELS
OF DEHP HAVE INCREASED RATES OF
MISCARRIAGE
AND GESTATIONAL DIABETES.
DEHP HAS NO PLACE IN IV BAGS
AND TUBING,
ESPECIALLY AS MULTIPLE MEDICAL
FACILITIES
INCLUDING LOMA LINDA,
CITY OF HOPE AND KAISER
PERMANENTE HAVE ALREADY
PHASED OUT THIS HARMFUL
ADDITIVE.
IN 2002, THE FDA ISSUED A PUBLIC
HEALTH NOTIFICATION
URGING HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS TO
REDUCE THE EXPOSURE OF
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
TO MEDICAL DEVICES CONTAINING
DEHP.
HOWEVER, THE FDA DID NOT BAN ITS
USE IN MEDICAL DEVICES OR
REQUIRE THEM TO LABEL WHETHER
THEIR DEVICES CONTAIN DEHP.
GIVEN THE WELL-ESTABLISHED
HEALTH CONCERNS ASSOCIATED
WITH EXPOSURE TO THIS TOXIC
CHEMICAL,
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
COMMON SENSE,
HEALTH PROTECTIVE LEGISLATION
AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US, BOTH
OF YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE?
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
YES, MA'AM.
HI.
NATALIE KNOX, ON BEHALF OF
BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS,
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF THE BILL
IN SUPPORT.
I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER
SUPPORT
ON BEHALF OF CLEAN WATER ACTION.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> WHITNEY FRANCIS WITH THE
WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MA'AM.
NEXT PLEASE.
LAN LI FROM ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE,
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
JENNIFER ROBLES WITH HEALTH
ACCESS
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON, KAREN AMIGONE
ON BEHALF OF
VOICE FOR CHOICE ADVOCACY AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
>> JULIE NIELSEN ON BEHALF OF
THE NATIONAL UNION
OF HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
>> READ AT US ON BEHALF OF BRAUN
MEDICAL
AND FRESENIUS KABI AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
LEAD WITNESSES, PLEASE.
WELL, YOU CAN SPEAK FROM
WHEREVER YOU LIKE.
I'LL BE QUICK.
MR.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS JOHN WINGER, ON BEHALF
OF THE ADVANCED
MEDICAL TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION,
ADVAMED, WE'RE THE NATIONAL
TRADE ASSOCIATION
FOR THE MEDICAL DEVICE INDUSTRY.
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR, STAFF
AND THE SPONSORS FOR
THE LONG CONVERSATIONS THAT
WE'VE
HAD OVER THIS PROCESS.
ALSO WANT TO APPRECIATE THE WORK
OF THE CHAIR
AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF ON THE
AMENDMENTS.
UH, WE DO PLAN ON REMOVING
OPPOSITION TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THANKS FOR COMING.
YES, SIR.
MR.
CHAIR, MEMBERS, DAVID GONZALEZ,
ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES AND
SINCERELY THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH THE
INDUSTRY
AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEE,
FOR THEIR GOOD WORK ON THIS
ISSUE.
IT'S COMPLICATED, BUT I THINK
WE COME TO
A POSITION WHERE WE CAN GO
NEUTRAL.
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT PLEASE.
>> HI, CLAIRE CONLIN ON BEHALF
OF BIOCOM, CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND THE
CHAIR.
WE ARE ALSO REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION
AND MOVING TO NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES?
ONE WAY OR THE OTHER?
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
>> MEG SNYDER ON BEHALF OF THE
VINYL INSTITUTE
WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU MA'AM.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION WITNESSES?
OKAY.
SEEING NONE, BRING THE MATTER
BACK TO THE DAIS.
I HAVE A COLLEAGUE HERE.
COLLEAGUE?
ANY COMMENTS?
QUESTIONS?
CONCERNS?
OKAY, SO REMEMBER YOUR LUCKY
DAY.
YOU GET TO CLOSE.
MY LUCKY DAY.
I ALMOST GOT EVERYBODY TO
NEUTRAL.
UM.
UH.
THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, THIS.
REALLY?
THIS BILL IS NEAR AND DEAR TO
MY HEART.
UM, AND IT'S A SMALL STEP
TOWARDS HELPING
TO REDUCE THE RISK OF CONTACT
WITH DEHP
AND SOME OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS,
INCLUDING THOSE WITH BREAST
CANCER.
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE, I VOTE.
WE WILL DO THAT.
AND I CERTAINLY WANT TO COMMEND
YOU
ON YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
MEASURE,
AND FOR WORKING WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS
TO ACHIEVE AN OBJECTIVE.
I THINK THAT'S EVIDENT BY THE
FOLKS
THAT ARE WITHDRAWING OPPOSITION.
YET THE BILL RETAINS ITS
OBJECTIVE,
WHICH IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
PATIENTS ARE SAFE.
SO YOU DID A GREAT JOB.
NICE PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
WHEN WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL TAKE
A MOTION.
WE'LL TAKE A VOTE AND WE'LL DO
JUST THAT.
THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE ONE MORE MEASURE.
ITEM NUMBER 13 AB 2319
CALIFORNIA DIGNITY
AND PREGNANCY AND CHILDBIRTH.
UM.
NO RUSH.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY, THOUGH.
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHTY.
UM, GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO MODIFY THE
ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS,
AND THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE AND THE SPONSORS
ON THIS BILL.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2319,
WHICH AIMS TO REDUCE
THE ALARMING AND
DISPROPORTIONATE
MATERNAL MORTALITY
RATE OF BLACK WOMEN AND OTHER
PREGNANT PERSONS OF COLOR
BY ENSURING SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION OF SB 464,
UM BY MITCHELL AND THE
CALIFORNIA DIGNITY
AND PREGNANCY AND CHILDBIRTH ACT
OF 2019 ACT,
A RECENT STUDY BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
UM, ALSO KNOWN AS CDPH, FOUND
THAT WOMEN OF COLOR,
IN PARTICULAR BLACK WOMEN,
DIE OF PREGNANCY RELATED
COMPLICATIONS AT MUCH
HIGHER RATES THAN WHITE WOMEN
IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS DISPARITY EXISTS ACROSS ALL
INCOME LEVELS.
NOW, TO ADDRESS THIS, THE
CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE ACT IN
2019,
WHICH REQUIRES HOSPITALS,
ALTERNATIVE BIRTH CENTERS,
AND PRIMARY CARE CLINICS,
WHICH ARE THE FACILITIES COVERED
UNDER THE ACT TO CONDUCT
EVIDENCE BASED IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAINING FOR ALL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WHO PROVIDE CARE
DURING A PERSON'S PREGNANCY,
CHILDBIRTH, AND IMMEDIATE
POSTPARTUM PERIOD.
IN AUGUST 2021, THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE, ALSO KNOWN AS DOJ,
LAUNCHED AN INVESTIGATION TO
ASCERTAIN
ASCERTAIN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
ACT.
WHILE SOME FACILITIES WENT ABOVE
AND BEYOND THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE ACT,
THERE IS STILL MORE WORK TO
BE DONE
TO ENSURE FULL COMPLIANCE.
DOJ'S INVESTIGATION REVEALED
THAT THERE
IS A NEED FOR AN ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM,
PUBLIC TRANSPARENCY OF
COMPLIANCE,
DATA FIRM COMPLIANCE DEADLINES,
AND ADDITIONAL SPECIFIC
SPECIFICITY
AND CLARITY SO THAT FACILITIES
ARE BETTER EQUIPPED TO KNOW
WHICH
PROVIDERS NEED TO BE TRAINED.
AND AB 2319 ACCOMPLISHED THIS.
I AM A MOTHER AND A GRANDMOTHER.
I HAVE SISTERS, AUNTS,
NIECES AND FRIENDS THAT LOOK
JUST LIKE ME.
AS A BLACK WOMAN.
THESE STATISTICS HIT WAY TOO
CLOSE TO HOME.
THEY ACKNOWLEDGED THE SOBERING
REALITY OF BEING
A PREGNANT WOMAN OF COLOR IN
THIS STATE,
AND HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED TO
CORRECT
THE COURSE WE'RE ON NOW WITH
ME TODAY.
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS TIFFANY
MATTHEWS WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
AND KIM TYAGI.
SAY IT AGAIN.
KAI.
SORRY.
UM.
A PROFESSIONAL AND COMMUNITY
DOULA WITH BLACK
WOMEN FOR WELLNESS ACTION
PROJECT.
TO SPEAK MORE ON THE IMPORTANCE
OF AB 2319,
AND TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD WHEN YOU BEGIN TO
SPEAK,
AND I'LL LET YOU CHOOSE WHICH
WHO GOES FIRST.
YES, MA'AM.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S YOU.
>> I'LL JUMP IN.
THANK YOU.
HI.
UH, TIFFANY BROKAW, MY LAST NAME
RECENTLY CHANGED.
UM, BUT ANYWAY, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
UM, GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
UM, TIFFANY BROKAW, DEPUTY
ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
AND I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROB BONTA,
WHO IS ONE OF THE PROUD
CO-SPONSORS OF THIS BILL,
ALONG WITH BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS
ACTION PRODUCT PROJECT,
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM FOR ALL,
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY,
THE CALIFORNIA NURSE MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION,
AND BLACK WOMEN'S COLLECTIVE.
WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON
AND DOCTOR WEBER FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP
ON THIS AND THE REST
OF THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS FOR MAKING
THIS BILL A PRIORITY, AND
THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS AS WELL.
SO THE UNITED STATES HAS THE
HIGHEST MATERNAL
MORTALITY RATE IN THE DEVELOPED
WORLD.
AND IN CALIFORNIA, PEOPLE OF
COLOR,
PARTICULARLY BLACK WOMEN,
CONTINUE TO DIE AT 3 TO 4 TIMES
THE RATE OF WHITE WOMEN.
AB 2319 AIMS TO REDUCE THE
ALARMING
AND DISPROPORTIONATE MATERNAL
MORTALITY RATES BY ENSURING
SUCCESSFUL IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE CALIFORNIA DIGNITY IN
PREGNANCY
AND CHILDBIRTH ACT,
WHICH WAS AUTHORED BY THEN
SENATOR
HOLLY MITCHELL IN 2019.
SO THE ACT REQUIRES HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES TO CONDUCT
EVIDENCE BASED IMPLICIT BIAS
TRAININGS FOR ALL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WHO PROVIDE CARE
DURING A PATIENT'S PREGNANCY,
CHILDBIRTH, AND IMMEDIATE
POSTPARTUM PERIOD.
SO IT'S ONE THING FOR A LAW TO
GET PASSED,
BUT IT'S ANOTHER TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S IMPLEMENTED.
SO IN AUGUST OF 2021, DOJ
LAUNCHED AN INVESTIGATION
TO ASCERTAIN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE ACT.
AND ONCE DOJ BEGAN ITS
INVESTIGATION,
WHEREBY THEY SENT LETTERS TO
ALL COVERED
FACILITIES TO SEE WHAT EFFORTS
WERE
BEING MADE TO COMPLY WITH THE
ACT.
UM.
BASED ON INFORMATION THAT WAS
PROVIDED
TO THEM BY RESPONDING
FACILITIES.
THEY FOUND THAT ABOUT 17% OF
FACILITIES
HAD BEGUN COMPLYING WITH THE
ACT,
AND NOT ONE EMPLOYEE HAD BEEN
FULLY TRAINED,
AND BY THE END OF THE
INVESTIGATION,
ABOUT 81% OF PROVIDERS HAD BEEN
FULLY TRAINED.
SO THE WHOLE GOAL OF THIS IS
TO JUST
CLOSE THAT GAP AND MAKE SURE
THAT 100% OF THE PROVIDERS
COVERED
IN THE ACT ARE BEING TRAINED,
BECAUSE THE GOAL HERE IS TO
REDUCE
BIAS IN OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
SO TO BETTER EQUIP HEALTH
FACILITIES TO COMPLY WITH
THE ACT AND ADMINISTER THESE
REQUIRED
ANTI-BIAS TRAININGS,
AB 2319 WILL PROVIDE CLARITY
ON WHICH
FACILITIES ARE MANDATED TO
ADMINISTER
THESE TRAININGS AND WHICH
PROVIDERS
NEED TO BE TRAINED.
IT WILL ESTABLISH FIRM DEADLINES
BY WHICH TRAININGS
MUST BE COMPLETED TO BETTER
GUIDE COMPLIANCE.
IT WILL ALSO CONFER ENFORCEMENT
POWERS UPON THE DOJ,
AND IT WILL AUTHORIZE THE DOJ
TO POST COMPLIANCE
DATA ONLINE SO THAT THE PUBLIC
CAN SEE WHICH FACILITIES DID
OR DID
NOT ADMINISTER THESE TRAININGS.
AND FOR THESE REASONS, WE
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
GREETINGS, SENATOR ROTH, AN
ESTEEMED
HEALTH COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS CHRIS GEORGI.
I'M A VETERAN DOULA OF 25 YEARS
OF NONSTOP PRACTICE,
WHICH KIND OF MAKES ME A UNICORN
IN THIS FIELD.
I TRAIN DOULAS IN THE COMMUNITY,
AND I'M A FOUNDER
OF CHILDREN OF THE SUN DOULA
PROJECT,
A NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO
INCREASING THE COMMUNITY
BASED BIRTH SUPPORT WORKFORCE.
I'VE SEEN LOTS OF CHANGES IN 25
YEARS OF BIRTH WORK.
I'VE SEEN THE MODERNIZATION OF
MEDICAL FACILITIES.
I'VE SEEN THE MEDICATIONS
OFFERED IN MEDICAL
MANAGEMENT OF LABOR AND BIRTH
CHANGE.
I'VE EVEN SEEN THE QUALITY OF
THE FOOD SERVED
IN THE HOSPITAL CAFETERIAS
IMPROVE.
THE ONE THING THAT HASN'T
CHANGED IS THE IMPACT
OF BIAS ON MEDICALLY RESPONSIVE
CARE.
BECAUSE I HAVE SERVED SO MANY
OF THE FAMILIES REPRESENTING
THE INCREDIBLY DIVERSE
POPULATION IN THIS REGION,
I HAVE HAD A FRONT ROW SEAT AND
THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN CARE OF BIPOC FAMILIES
AND WHITE
PRESENTING FAMILIES WHEN BIAS
IS UNRECOGNIZED
AND UNCHECKED ARE DEMORALIZING.
LET ME SHARE A FEW BRIEF
STORIES.
THERE WAS A BIRTH WITH A YOUNG
MOM
AND DAD HAVING THEIR FIRST BABY,
AND THEY WERE ATTENDING AN OB
WHO
HAD QUITE SOME TIME IN THE
FIELD.
AND HE MADE IT VERY CLEAR THAT
HE PREFERRED
TO BE AT A DIFFERENT BIRTH.
SO MUCH SO THAT WHEN THE SECOND
BIRTH WAS PROGRESSING
MORE QUICKLY THAN THE ONE THAT
HE WAS ATTENDING,
HE LEFT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
BIRTH WITH
HIS RESIDENT'S HAND INSIDE OF
THE MOM,
HOLDING AN INCISION THAT HE HAD
CREATED TO RUSH HER THROUGH
DELIVERING THE BABY AND NOT
FINISH SUTURING.
THAT'S ONE STORY.
ANOTHER COUPLE HAVING THEIR
SECOND BABY.
PROFESSIONAL MIDDLE CLASS PEOPLE
VERY EXCITED ON THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE A BABY AND ONE OF THEIR
REGULAR SCANS.
DURING THEIR CARE, IT WAS
DISCOVERED THAT MOM'S BODY
MIGHT BE OPENING A LITTLE EARLY
FOR THIS BABY.
THIS HAPPENS OFTEN, AND THERE IS
A REGULAR COMMON PROCEDURE THAT
HAPPENS TO HELP MOM'S BODY STAY
CLOSED SO BABY CAN STAY INSIDE.
SOMEHOW, DURING THIS PROCEDURE,
THERE WAS A CATASTROPHIC ERROR,
AND ONLY HALFWAY THROUGH THE
PREGNANCY,
HER WATER BAG WAS RUPTURED.
SHE WAS BROUGHT BACK TO HER
ROOM,
LEFT IN THE HOSPITAL ROOM ALL
NIGHT BY HERSELF WITH ONLY HER
HUSBAND,
NO MONITORING, NO CARE.
LEAKING FLUID, NOT EVEN KNOWING
IF HER BABY WAS STILL ALIVE.
THE NEXT MORNING.
THEY ARE ON THE PHONE WITH ME
AND THE NURSE THAT COMES IN.
THE FIRST THING SHE SAYS IS
WE DON'T
DO TERMINATIONS OF PREGNANCY
HERE.
AND BASICALLY SAID, GO HOME.
UM, IT TOOK A LOT OF ADVOCACY
TO GET SOME CARE.
THE CARE FINALLY HAPPENED, BUT
AT THIS POINT THERE
WAS AN INFECTION THAT OCCURRED
FROM THE PROCEDURE.
AND TWO DAYS LATER,
THEIR BABY WAS BORN AND PASSED
AWAY.
THE LAST STORY A MOM MARRIED
HAVING
A HISTORY OF SOME MISCARRIAGES
WHICH IN HER OWN RESEARCH,
SHE DISCOVERED WERE PREVENTABLE.
HAD THERE BEEN PROACTIVE CARE
WHEN
THE PREGNANCY THAT SHE WAS
EXPERIENCING,
UM, GOT TO THE SECOND TRIMESTER,
THE BABY PASSED AWAY.
SHE REACHED OUT FOR CARE THAT
MADE SENSE
FOR HER BODY TO HER PROVIDERS,
UH, CHECKING MULTIPLE PROVIDERS,
MULTIPLE FACILITIES.
SHE REACHED OUT TO SUPPORT OF A
BIRTH PROFESSIONAL,
AND I WENT WITH HER TO THESE
APPOINTMENTS
WHERE MULTIPLE TIMES PEOPLE
CAME IN,
NOT EVEN HAVING READ HER CHART.
HEY, WHAT ARE YOU HERE FOR
TODAY?
WHERE?
SHE HAD TO SAY REPEATEDLY.
MY BABY DIED.
IT TOOK FIVE MONTHS.
FIVE MONTHS OF CARRYING HER
DECEASED
BABY INSIDE OF HER BODY TO
FINALLY
GET CARE THAT COULD RESOLVE WHAT
THEY CALL A MISSED MISCARRIAGE,
SO THAT SHE COULD MOVE ON WITH
HER PHYSICAL HEALTH
AND BEGIN THE PROCESS OF
GRIEVING HER BABY.
AND EVEN AT THAT POINT OF CARE,
ALL I DID WAS GO TO THE CAR
TO DRIVE
HER HOME BECAUSE HER HUSBAND WAS
HOME WITH THE OTHER CHILDREN.
AND IN THE COURSE OF THAT, THEY
GAVE HER SOME SORT
OF ANTIBIOTIC WHERE SHE HAD A
POOR REACTION TO IT.
WHEN I CALLED AND ASKED SOME
QUESTIONS JUST ABOUT
HOW SHE WAS DOING, THE NURSE
SNAPPED AT ME.
SO I CAME BACK IN TO WAIT.
THEY TRIED TO SEND ME OUT AGAIN,
AND I REFUSED BECAUSE I SAID
THE LAST TIME I LEFT SHE
CRASHED.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO THAT.
I'M GOING TO WAIT HERE.
WE GOT HER HOME AND SHE'S OKAY.
BUT ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE NOT.
NOT BECAUSE THERE WAS A PERSON
WHO
WAS UNCOMPLIANT WITH THEIR CARE,
NOT BECAUSE THEY WERE
UNDESERVING,
NOT BECAUSE YOU KNOW ANY OF
THE THINGS THAT SOMEBODY MIGHT
SAY,
WELL, THIS WAS INEVITABLE.
THEY WEREN'T THEY WERE
PREVENTABLE.
SO.
THAT'S THE TESTIMONY I'M
OFFERING,
AND I'M TREMENDOUSLY GRATEFUL
TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WILSON FOR PRESENTING
THIS BILL AND OFFERING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
ON AN ISSUE THAT I'M SO
PASSIONATE ABOUT,
AND I HOPE YOU LEAN HEAVILY
INTO THE IDEA OF ACCEPTING,
SUPPORTING AND ULTIMATELY
PASSING THIS BILL.
BECAUSE NO MATTER WHAT ELSE
HAPPENS IN A CHILD'S LIFE,
THEIR FIRST ACE SHOULDN'T BE THE
DAY THEY WERE BORN.
AB 2319 IS ONE WAY TO PROTECT
THEM FROM IT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY
AND FOR PROVIDING YOUR
TESTIMONY.
YOU DO HAVE A GREAT AUTHOR, BY
THE WAY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURE, PLEASE?
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SANDRA POOLE,
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY.
PROUD CO-SPONSOR IN SUPPORT.
CRAIG PULSIPHER ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
>> NICOLE WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT.
HELLO.
GENESIS GONZALES.
ON BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MARTIN RADOSEVICH ON BEHALF OF
REPRODUCTIVE FREEDOM FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
NURSE MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION.
PROUD CO-SPONSORS.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS
JONATHAN MUNOZ ON BEHALF OF
FIRST FIVE CALIFORNIA AND FIRST
FIVE LA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
JENNIFER ROBLES WITH HEALTH
ACCESS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DON A WORD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION
OF THE NATIONAL COUNCIL OF NEGRO
WOMEN.
I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF MORE THAN
WOMEN IN SUPPORT OF AB 2003 19.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
NEXT, PLEASE.
KATRINA DUNN IN CALIFORNIA BLACK
HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
KELLY BROOKS ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS HERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NOR LYNN WITH CHILDREN NOW IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
LAND LAY ON BEHALF OF ASIAN
AMERICANS.
ADVANCING JUSTICE, SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT, PLEASE.
BETH MALINOWSKI, THE SEO
CALIFORNIAN SUPPORT.
>> THANK YOU.
KELLY MACMILLAN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON
THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS
AND MARCH OF DIMES IN SUPPORT.
SIR.
DYLAN ELLIOTT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRISTS
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS,
BOTH IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
GEORGE PARAM2 ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
VANESSA GIGENA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK HERE
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CATHY.
CATHY MOSSBERG WITH THE FIRST
FIVE
ASSOCIATION IN SPORT ALONG
WITH ESSENTIAL ACCESS HEALTH
AND AIDS PROJECT LOS ANGELES.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR COMING.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
FIRST LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, IF ANY.
OR ANY OTHERS, SIR.
JOIN US AT THE TABLE.
PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF FOR
THE RECORD.
PROCEED WHEN READY.
RIGHT.
HOW ABOUT NOW?
PERFECT.
GREAT CHAIR.
MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS GREG BURT AND I AM
REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL
AS THE VICE PRESIDENT HERE TO
VOICE
OUR OPPOSITION TO AB 2319.
OUR CONCERNS RELATE TO THE
TRANSGENDER IMPLICIT
BIAS TRAINING THIS BILL
REQUIRES,
WHICH HASN'T REALLY BEEN BROUGHT
UP.
THIS BILL FUNDAMENTALLY
MISCONSTRUES THE CONCEPT
OF IMPLICIT BIAS AND IMPOSES
DAMAGING
CONSEQUENCES ON MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS
FOR ADHERING TO BIOLOGICAL
TRUTHS.
IT IS NOT IMPLICIT BIAS TO
BELIEVE
THAT ONLY FEMALES CAN GIVE
BIRTH.
THIS IS A BIOLOGICAL FACT
CONSISTENTLY
OBSERVED AND CONFIRMED BY
SCIENCE.
THIS BILL PENALIZES MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS
FOR RECOGNIZING SUCH FUNDAMENTAL
TRUTHS.
IT UNDERMINES THE INTEGRITY OF
THE MEDICAL PRACTICE AND RISKS
PATIENT
CARE BY FORCING PROFESSIONALS
TO DENY BIOLOGICAL REALITIES.
FURTHERMORE, AB 2319 USES
POLITICAL PRESSURE
AND EVEN SHAME TO COMPEL MEDICAL
STAFF TO
GIVE UP THEIR SCIENTIFIC AND
PERSONAL RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS ABOUT MALE AND FEMALE
BODIES.
SADLY, THIS REMINDS ME OF
THE TECHNIQUES USED BY THE RED
GUARD DURING THE CULTURAL
REVOLUTION
IN COMMUNIST CHINA,
WHERE ITS CITIZENS WERE FORCED
TO GO THROUGH RE-EDUCATION
TO GET RID OF THE FOUR OLDS, AS
THEY CALLED THEM.
OLD IDEAS, OLD CULTURE, OLD
CUSTOMS, AND OLD HABITS.
AND LASTLY, RECOGNIZING
MOTHERHOOD AS A BIOLOGICAL,
BIOLOGICALLY BASED UPHOLDS THE
DIGNITY OF WOMEN.
MOTHERHOOD IS A UNIQUE ASPECT
OF FEMALE FEMALE BIOLOGY,
AND ACKNOWLEDGING THIS FACT
RESPECTS
AND CELEBRATES THE ROLE OF WOMEN
IN SOCIETY.
DENYING THE BIOLOGICAL BASIS OF
MOTHERHOOD DIMINISHES THIS,
THE SPECIAL CONTRIBUTIONS OF
WOMEN
AND ERODES THE FOUNDATIONAL
UNDERSTANDING OF FAMILY AND
COMMUNITY.
AND FOR THESE REASONS,
WE URGE YOU TO OPPOSE AB 2319.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE.
LET'S BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE DESK.
COLLEAGUES, ANY QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS?
CONCERNS?
I JUST WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR.
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND THANK.
THE WITNESSES FOR SHARING, UM,
PARTICULARLY OUR DOULA FROM
BLACK WOMEN
FOR WELLNESS IN MY DISTRICT.
I JUST WANT TO SAY, UM, WHAT AN
EDUCATION YOU SHARED
WITH US IN TERMS OF WHAT WOMEN
ARE FACING.
AND THIS IS A SMALL STEP,
COMPLIANCE IS A SMALL STEP
TOWARD ADDRESSING
THE EVILS OF INSTITUTIONALIZED
RACISM
THAT PREVENT OUR MOST IMPORTANT,
PRECIOUS, UM, BEINGS FROM COMING
INTO THE WORLD.
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COURAGE,
FOR SHARING THE STORY.
AND I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL
WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT.
THANK YOU, SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I'M SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GREAT JOB.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS.
UM, FROM MY COLLEAGUE AS A PART
OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS,
WHO IS ALSO A CO-AUTHOR ON THIS
BILL,
AND AS IT WAS NOTED, IT WAS A
PRIORITY, I THINK, UM,
DEPUTY AG BROCK HALL AND DOULA
GYÖRGY,
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY.
AND AS IT WAS STATED, VERY
ENLIGHTENING.
UM, AND JUST TO CLEAR UP, UH,
AND MY CLOTHES,
JUST TO CLEAR UP ANY
MISINFORMATION,
UM, AROUND THIS BILL, AS IT
WAS NOTED
BY THE OPPOSING TESTIMONY,
IS THE THE ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM
RELATED
TO THIS BILL IS TRULY RELATED
TO, UM,
WHETHER OR NOT, UH, THESE
ENTITIES HAVE CREATED
HAVE COMPLETED THEIR IMPLICIT
BIAS PROGRAM.
UM, THIS BILL DOES NOTHING TO
ERASE MOTHERHOOD,
UM, TO ERASE WOMEN.
UM, IT IS AN EXPANDING BILL,
AN INCLUSIONARY BILL TO ENSURE
THAT
ANYONE WHO IS GIVING BIRTH,
WHETHER THEY ARE NON-BINARY,
WHETHER THEY TRANSGENDER, IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
UM, THE REQUIREMENT IS TO REMOVE
IMPLICIT BIAS, UM,
AGAINST ANYONE WHO HAS A WOMB
AND COMING IN TO RECEIVE CARE.
UM, BECAUSE WHETHER YOU IDENTIFY
AS A WOMAN,
IDENTIFY AS NON-BINARY, IDENTIFY
AS TRANSGENDER,
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO COME IN,
RECEIVE QUALITY CARE,
AND BOTH YOU AND YOUR BABY BE
ABLE TO BE DELIVERED SAFELY.
AND IF THERE IS AN ISSUE WITH
THE BABY
BEING ABLE TO BE DELIVERED
SAFELY,
THAT YOU AS A PERSON, NO MATTER
WHO YOU ARE,
UM, ALSO COME OUT OF IT
SUCCESSFULLY.
AND THAT IS THE INTENTION OF
THIS BILL,
IS TO PROTECT THOSE PEOPLE WITH
WOMBS TO
ENSURE THAT THEY ARE CARED FOR
PROPERLY,
UM, WHEN THEY RECEIVE CARE
WITHOUT BIAS,
UM, WHEN APPROPRIATE.
UM, I ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE, AND
I THANK
YOU AND APPRECIATE ALL THAT'S
WENT IN TO MAKE THIS BILL BRING
THIS BILL TO WHERE IT IS TODAY.
THANK YOU.
AS SOON AS WE ACHIEVE A QUORUM,
WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND WE'LL
DO JUST THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
WE'RE GOING TO JUMP AROUND A
LITTLE BIT BECAUSE
OF TIME ISSUES AND CALL ITEM
NUMBER 23 AB 3275.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SORIA HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE,
CLAIM REIMBURSEMENT.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
I DON'T BLAME YOU.
PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH, CHAIR AND
SENATORS.
UH, FIRST.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU AND
ALL OF YOUR.
STAFF FOR THE COUNTLESS HOURS
SPENT ON MAKING.
THIS BILL BETTER.
UH, I DO WANT TO START BY SAYING
THAT I ACCEPT.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TO.
REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS TO.
PAY.
CLEAN AND UNCONTESTED.
CLAIMS IN 30.
CALENDAR YEARS.
YEARS, DAYS.
EXCUSE ME.
THE AMENDMENTS WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTH CARE TO DEFINE
CLEAN.
CLAIMS WITH.
STAKEHOLDER INPUT.
AND THEN LASTLY, I'M.
ALSO ACCEPTING.
THE CONSUMER PROTECTION
AMENDMENTS TO TREAT CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS ABOUT CLAIMS AS A
GRIEVANCE.
UH, THE SPEAKER AND I INTRODUCED
THIS BILL BECAUSE
WE KNOW FIRSTHAND THAT MANY
SMALL AND RURAL
HOSPITALS ARE DESPERATE TO BE
PAID ON TIME FOR
THE SERVICES THEY PROVIDE TO
CONSUMERS.
FOR EXAMPLE.
IN MY DISTRICT, I HAD TO REACH
OUT TO HEALTH PLANS TO
PAY TO PAY A PROVIDER IN THE
SPEAKER'S DISTRICT.
HIS DISTRESSED HOSPITAL HAD $4
MILLION
IN OUTSTANDING CLAIMS AGAINST
A HEALTH HEALTH PLAN FROM AUGUST
TO DECEMBER OF 2022.
OFTEN, THESE HOSPITALS ARE THE
SAFETY NET PROVIDERS
OR THE PROVIDERS OF LAST RESORT.
IN MANY STRUGGLING RURAL
COMMUNITIES.
IN CALIFORNIA, NINE RURAL
HOSPITALS
HAVE CLOSED SINCE 2005,
AND 16 HOSPITALS ARE CURRENTLY
AT RISK OF CLOSING.
AS YOU GUYS WELL KNOW,
MY HOSPITAL IN THE COUNTY OF
MADERA,
THE ONLY HOSPITAL ENDED UP
CLOSING
IN DECEMBER OF 2022.
FINANCIAL DISTRESS IS THE MAIN
REASON FOR
THESE CLOSED OR DISTRESSED
HOSPITALS.
TO THESE PROVIDERS IN THE BATTLE
TO
REMAIN OPEN AND SERVE
CALIFORNIANS,
EVERY SINGLE PENNY COUNTS.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES HEALTH
PLANS
TO PAY PROVIDERS UNCONTESTED
CLAIMS WITHIN 30 DAYS FOR POS,
OR 45 FOR HMOS, 45 DAYS.
HOWEVER, NOT ALL HEALTH PLANS
ARE
MEETING THIS LEGAL OBLIGATION.
THESE PRACTICES ARE SIMPLY NOT
SUSTAINABLE,
AND I BELIEVE THE TIMELINES IN
THIS BILL WOULD
HELP RELIEVE THE FINANCIAL
PRESSURES THAT MANY
SMALL AND RURAL HOSPITALS ARE
EXPERIENCING,
EXPERIENCING WITH ME HERE TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
UM, IT IS MARY CASILLAS,
CEO OF HAZEL HAWKINS HOSPITAL,
AND DOCTOR ELAINE BATCHELOR
FROM CEO
OF THE MARTIN LUTHER KING
HOSPITAL.
WELCOME.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
IDENTIFY YOURSELVES.
FOR THE RECORD, THOUGH, PLEASE.
HELLO, I AM MARY CASSEUS.
I AM A LIFETIME RESIDENT OF SAN
BENITO COUNTY.
I HAVE BEEN IN HEALTH CARE FOR
NEARLY 30 YEARS AND I AM
CURRENTLY THE CEO AT HAZEL
HAWKINS MEMORIAL HOSPITAL.
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FORUM.
HAZEL HAWKINS HOSPITAL IS PART
OF
SAN BENITO HEALTH CARE DISTRICT.
IT IS A 25 BED CRITICAL ACCESS
HOSPITAL,
AND IT IS THE ONLY
HOSPITAL AND EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT
IN SAN BENITO COUNTY.
THE DISTRICT ALSO RUNS TO SIX
RURAL HEALTH CLINICS
AND TWO SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES.
THE RESIDENTS IN OUR COMMUNITY
RELY ON US TO PROVIDE
LIFE SAVING SERVICES ON A DAILY
BASIS.
MANY OF OUR PATIENTS ARE
UNDERSERVED,
WORKING IN AGRICULTURE AND
MANUFACTURING
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
WE ARE SAVING LIVES.
WHETHER IT IS TREATING PATIENTS
IN OUR HOSPITAL AND CLINICS,
OR STABILIZING THE PATIENTS AND
FLYING THEM OUT
TO A TERTIARY CARE CENTER IN
THE BAY AREA.
18 MONTHS AGO,
OUR HOSPITAL WAS IN FINANCIAL
DISTRESS.
WE WERE PROJECTED TO HAVE 1.5
DAYS CASH ON HAND AT THE END OF
DECEMBER OF 2022.
WE WERE UNSURE HOW WE WERE GOING
TO MAKE
PAYROLL AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
THE ISSUE WE WERE EXPERIENCING
AT THE TIME WAS
NOT A DEBT ISSUE, IT WAS A CASH
FLOW ISSUE.
WE WERE IN A PERFECT STORM THAT
PUT
OUR SERVICES AT RISK OF CLOSURE.
THE CURRENT LAW REQUIRING HEALTH
PLANS AND HEALTH INSURERS
TO PAY PROVIDER CLAIMS IN 30
TO 45 WORKING
DAYS WAS PASSED IN A TIME WHEN
WE WERE STILL
USING PAPER TO FILE CLAIMS IN
HEALTHCARE.
IN THIS DAY OF ELECTRONIC FILING
AND THE PROGRESS
WE HAVE MADE IN ELECTRONIC
RECORDS,
THERE IS NO REASON FOR HEALTH
INSURERS AND HEALTH
PLANS TO TAKE THIS LONG TO PAY
HEALTH PROVIDERS.
HAZEL HAWKINS CURRENTLY HAS
NEARLY $59 MILLION IN
OUTSTANDING CHARGES DUE TO OUR
LITTLE HOSPITAL.
OUR CURRENT DAYS OF CASH
RECEIVABLE
IS NEARLY 53 DAYS.
THAT MEANS FROM THE TIME WE DROP
A BILL TO THE TIME WE GET PAID.
IT IS TAKING AN AVERAGE OF 53
DAYS.
SOME OF OUR PAYERS ARE ABLE
TO PAY US IN 15 TO 17 DAYS,
SO WE KNOW IT'S POSSIBLE.
WE KNOW THAT A TIGHTER TIME
PERIOD TO PAY
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS IS
POSSIBLE.
WE FIND SOME PAYERS TAKE AN
ENTIRE
30 DAYS TO RESPOND TO A CLAIM,
AND THEN ANOTHER 30 DAYS TO PAY
THE CLAIM.
OBVIOUSLY, ACCORDING TO OUR DAYS
OF CASH RECEIVABLE,
SOME ARE TAKING MUCH LONGER TO
PAY US.
THIS BOTTLENECK IN CASH FLOW CAN
BE DETRIMENTAL
TO SOME HEALTH PROVIDERS.
THIS BILL CAN CHANGE THE
FINANCIAL
LANDSCAPE OF HOSPITALS,
AND WE URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON
AB 3275.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
NEXT, PLEASE.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
PROVIDE INPUT ON THIS BILL.
I'M ELAINE BATCHELOR, I'M THE
CEO OF MLK COMMUNITY
HOSPITAL AND HEALTH SYSTEM IN
LOS ANGELES.
I LEAD A SMALL, INDEPENDENT
PRIVATE
SAFETY NET HOSPITAL IN LOS
ANGELES.
WE ARE FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED
AND STRUGGLING TO MAINTAIN
HEALTH SERVICES FOR OUR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITY,
REDUCING THE TIME BETWEEN WHEN
WE INCUR COSTS
TO PROVIDE SERVICES FOR HEALTH
PLAN MEMBERS
TO WHEN WE GET REIMBURSED FOR
THOSE COSTS
IS IMPORTANT FOR US AND OTHER
SMALL,
FINANCIALLY STRESSED HOSPITALS
BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE FINANCIAL
RESERVES.
AS YOU HEARD FROM MY COLLEAGUE,
WE DON'T HAVE CASH ON HAND.
WE OPERATE CLOSE TO THE EDGE
OF NOT
BEING ABLE TO PAY OUR BILLS.
WE DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
FINANCE
ONGOING CARE FOR PATIENTS.
IF WE DON'T GET TIMELY
REIMBURSEMENT FOR
THE COSTS WE'VE ALREADY
EXPENDED,
MANAGED CARE PAYMENT DELAYS AND
DENIALS PROLONG
THE TIME IT TAKES FOR US TO
GET PAID,
EXACERBATING OUR FINANCIAL
JEOPARDY AND PUSHING
US THAT MUCH CLOSER TO THE EDGE.
THE TACTICS HEALTH PLANS USE TO
DELAY AND DENY
PAYMENTS HAVE BECOME MORE
AGGRESSIVE.
THEY RANGE FROM DEMANDING MORE
INFORMATION
FOR CLAIMS THAT CLEARLY MERIT
PAYMENT,
TO OUTRIGHT REFUSALS TO
AUTHORIZE OR
PAY FOR CARE THAT IS CLEARLY
NEEDED.
I'LL SHARE A FEW EXAMPLES.
A WOMAN IN ACTIVE LABOR
PRESENTED
TO OUR EMERGENCY ROOM,
THE MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATION
REFUSED TO AUTHORIZE
THE DELIVERY AND THEN DENIED
PAYMENT.
WHEN WE SUBMITTED THE CLAIM,
ANOTHER MANAGED CARE
ORGANIZATION REFUSED TO
AUTHORIZE ADMISSION
FOR A PATIENT WHO CAME TO OUR
EMERGENCY ROOM
SO SICK SHE WAS PLACED ON A
VENTILATOR.
WHEN SHE LATER DIED IN OUR ICU,
THEY DENIED PAYMENT BECAUSE
THE ADMISSION WAS NEVER
AUTHORIZED.
ABOUT A THIRD OF OUR CLAIMS ARE
NOT PAID TIMELY
OR ACCORDING TO WHAT WE
SUBMITTED.
OVER A THIRD OF THE DENIALS
WE APPEAL ARE OVERTURNED,
BUT THE TIME AND EFFORT WE
EXTEND TO GET PAID
CREATES AN ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
BURDEN.
WE'RE FORCED TO EXPEND BOTH
RESOURCES AND TIME
GOING BACK AND FORTH WITH
MANAGED CARE PLANS
AS WE ATTEMPT TO GET PAID FOR
SERVICES WE'VE
ALREADY DELIVERED TO THEIR
MEMBERS.
WE EMPLOY AN ARMY OF CARE
MANAGERS AND WHAT WE
EUPHEMISTICALLY CALL REVENUE
CYCLE EXPERTS,
TO INTERACT WITH PLANS AND
OVERCOME
THE MANY BARRIERS TO GETTING
PAID.
AB 3275 WOULD WOULD EXPEDITE
PAYMENTS AND PROVIDE RELIEF
FOR HOSPITALS LIKE OURS THAT ARE
ALREADY STRUGGLING.
I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR COMING TO TESTIFY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE.
HELLO, BRIAN MIRAMONTEZ WITH
THE FCC.
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
JESSICA MORAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
SARAH BRIDGE, ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE DISTRICTS
AND SUPPORT.
THANKS.
NEXT.
BETH MANOWSKI WITH.
SEO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
BRANDON MARKEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SIR.
TIM MADDEN WAS NAMED THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SPORT.
THANK YOU.
MARK FAROOQ, CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
CONNIE DELGADO, ON BEHALF OF
THE DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FORUM AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NASET SHORT ON BEHALF OF SAINT
AGNES MEDICAL CENTER.
PEACH, REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S
HOSPITAL
SAFETY NET AND ADVENTIST HEALTH.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
YES, MA'AM.
JENNIFER SNYDER ON BEHALF.
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH FACILITIES IN.
SUPPORT.
THANKS FOR.
JOINING US.
VANESSA KAHINA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS HERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE, LET'S TURN TO
OPPOSITION
WITNESSES FIRST.
LEAD OPPOSITION.
WITNESS WITNESSES.
PLEASE JOIN US DOWN IN FRONT
IF YOU.
WOULD LIKE TO DO SO.
AND IDENTIFY YOURSELVES FOR
THE RECORD AGAIN BEFORE
SPEAKING.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, THOUGH.
UH, THANK YOU FOR WELCOMING ME
BACK, MR.
CHAIR.
UM.
ALWAYS WELCOME.
UH, JED HAMPTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS
HERE,
UH, REGRETTABLY, IN OPPOSITION
TO AB 3275.
UH, WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND HER STAFF.
UM, WE HAVE HAD NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS BILL.
UM, REALLY, REALLY APPRECIATE
NOT ONLY
THE SUBSTANTIVE CONVERSATIONS,
BUT THE AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS
TO ENGAGE
WITH US ON OUR CONCERNS WITH
THE BILL.
UM, YOU KNOW, I WANT TO I WANT
TO START BY SAYING THAT HEALTH
PLANS OBVIOUSLY HAVE A VERY
STRONG AND VESTED INTEREST
IN MAKING SURE THAT HOSPITALS
STAY OPERATIONAL SO THAT THEY
CAN CONTINUE TO PROVIDE QUALITY
CARE TO OUR ENROLLEES.
UM, HEALTH PLANS HAVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO OUR PART
TO ENSURE THAT EVEN THE MOST
DISTRESSED HOSPITALS.
UM, CAN, CAN STAY AFLOAT.
UH, TO THAT END, I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO NOTE,
FIRST OF ALL, THAT, UM,
JUST SOME OF THE WAYS THAT
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLANS
HAVE HELPED FINANCIALLY
DISTRESSED HOSPITALS.
THIS IS JUST IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS HERE.
UH, FIRST AND FOREMOST,
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS
RECEIVE APPROXIMATELY $4.5
BILLION EVERY SINGLE MONTH FROM
HEALTH
PLANS VIA CAPITATED PAYMENTS.
NOW, THESE PAYMENTS ARE NOT TIED
TO PATIENT
VOLUME OR CLAIM SUBMISSIONS,
AND THEY PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT
FUNDING SOURCE
AND MECHANISM FOR HOSPITALS TO
STAY AFLOAT.
IN ADDITION TO THE CAPITATED
PAYMENT SYSTEM,
HEALTH PLANS ALSO RECENTLY
SUPPORTED
THE REAUTHORIZATION
OF THE MANAGED CARE ORGANIZATION
TAX,
A TAX THAT FALLS DIRECTLY ON OUR
MEMBERS, UH, TO,
UH, ENSURE IMPROVEMENTS IN THE
MEDI-CAL PROGRAM.
THE DISTRESSED HOSPITAL LOAN
PROGRAM, UM,
RECEIVED $150 MILLION FROM THAT
TAX,
AS WELL AS $300 MILLION OVERALL
IN GENERAL FUND SPENDING.
SO THAT'S ANOTHER WAY THAT
CALIFORNIA
HEALTH PLANS, UM, YOU KNOW,
HAVE HAVE DONE OUR PART TO HELP
DISTRESS HOSPITALS.
I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT I HAVE
INDIVIDUAL
MEMBER PLANS IN SPECIFIC
DISTRICTS
WHO HAVE PROVIDED DIRECT
FINANCIAL
BENEFIT TO DISTRESSED HOSPITALS,
SPECIFICALLY IN THEIR IN THEIR
GEOGRAPHIC REGION,
IN ORDER FOR THEM TO STAY
AFLOAT.
SO I JUST WANT TO BE CLEAR FROM
FROM
THE HEALTH PLAN PERSPECTIVE.
I MEAN, I THINK WE'VE REALLY
DONE QUITE
A BIT IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS,
AND THIS DOESN'T EVEN GO INTO
WHAT WAS DONE DURING
COVID TO ENSURE THAT THESE
HOSPITALS STAY AFLOAT.
SO I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO TO POINT OUT.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
POINT OUT AS WELL,
THAT WE WE RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE
WITH
THE PREMISE THAT SPEEDING UP THE
CLAIMS PAYMENT
TIMELINE WILL ACTUALLY KEEP
THESE HOSPITALS.
UM, YOU KNOW, WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING
FINANCIAL DISTRESS AFLOAT.
UH, REGARDLESS OF THAT, WE ARE
WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR IN GOOD FAITH,
AND WE HAVE SUBMITTED SOME
AMENDMENTS
TO TO HELP ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS AROUND DISTRESSED
HOSPITALS IN GENERAL.
UM, WE SUBMITTED A SERIES OF
THESE AMENDMENTS
THAT INCLUDE A MEANINGFUL
REDUCTION
IN THE AMOUNT OF DAYS THAT THE
HEALTH
PLANS WOULD HAVE TO PAY CLAIMS,
AS WELL AS ADDRESS THE AUTHORS
VALID CONCERNS AROUND
THE CONCERNS AROUND DISTRESSED
HOSPITALS.
THAT BEING SAID, WE HAVE REMOVED
THE THE,
UH, WE HAVE REVIEWED,
EXCUSE ME, THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
UM, AND DID FEEL LIKE THE BILL
WAS
MOVING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
HOWEVER, WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERN
WITH
THE INCLUSION OF AN AMENDMENT
ADDRESSING THE EXISTING HEALTH
PLAN GRIEVANCE PROCESS,
AS THIS PROVISION WAS NOT
PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED WITH US,
AND WE ONLY FOUND OUT ABOUT IT
YESTERDAY
WHEN REVIEWING THE AMENDMENT.
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE FURTHER
CONVERSATION WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE TO DISCUSS
THAT PARTICULAR AMENDMENT.
HOWEVER, WE FEEL THAT THE REST
OF THE AMENDMENTS,
GENERALLY SPEAKING,
ARE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION
SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO HOPE,
UH, HOPE TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS, UM,
YOU KNOW, AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID,
AND FOR THE REASONS I PREVIOUSLY
STATED,
WE ARE CURRENTLY OPPOSED TO
AB 3275.
BUT AGAIN, LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
YES, MA'AM.
KATIE ANDREW WITH LOCAL HEALTH
PLANS OF CALIFORNIA.
I WANT TO FIRST ECHO MY
COLLEAGUES APPRECIATION
TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE
AUTHORS OFFICE.
UM, WE HAVE HAD NUMEROUS
CONVERSATIONS
TRYING TO WORK
THROUGH THE THE ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE WITH THIS BILL.
SO APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT HAS
GONE INTO IT.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE AMENDMENTS
ARE MOVING
THE BILL IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THERE IS SOME, AS MY COLLEAGUE,
UH, SUGGESTED,
THERE'S SOME NEW LANGUAGE THAT
WE ARE, UH,
SORT OF THINKING ABOUT AND
MULLING OVER, UM,
TRYING TO ASSESS THE IMPACT
AND RUN IT BY OUR MEMBER PLANS.
UM, BUT WITH THAT BEING SAID,
YOU KNOW,
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE ON THIS
BILL.
UM, AND APPRECIATE AGAIN,
APPRECIATION FOR FOR THE WORK
THAT HAS GONE INTO IT SO FAR.
UM.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR ON THIS.
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
WE NEED TO TRY TO GET IT
RESOLVED.
AND THANKS FOR WHAT YOU DO.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION?
I SEE SOME IN THE WINGS.
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE.
MR.
CHAIRMAN, MATT.
BACK REPRESENTING THE.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF DENTAL
PLANS.
WE APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
AS WELL
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT PLEASE.
CHLOE SHIN, ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANY.
MANY OF OUR CONCERNS PARALLEL
THOSE OF CAP.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE.
COLLEAGUES BACK ON THE DAIS.
QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS.
CONCERNS.
LOOKING LEFT.
LOOKING RIGHT, SENATOR
SMALLWOOD.
I JUST WANTED TO RECOGNIZE
MARTIN
LUTHER KING HOSPITAL
FOR BEING HERE AND FOR SHARING
THOSE COMMENTS.
THAT FACILITY IS TREMENDOUSLY
IMPORTANT
TO OUR LOS ANGELES AREA.
IT'S ALWAYS GOOD TO SEE DOCTOR
BAXTER HERE,
AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT
THE BILL WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
SOME.
REMEMBER, YOU GET THE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU.
UH, SENATOR CHAIR AND SENATORS,
UM,
LET ME CLOSE BY STATING AGAIN
MY COMMITMENT
THAT I'VE EXPRESSED EARLY ON
TO TO
THE HEALTH PLANS AND TO ALL
OF YOU,
THAT WE THERE'S MY COMMITMENT
TO WORK WITH ALL OF YOU
TO ENSURE THAT WE CREATE A
PROCESS THAT ISOLATES.
I KNOW THAT THE CONSUMERS PIECE,
WHICH WAS RECENTLY ADDED
FROM THESE CLAIM DISPUTES AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD.
SO THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I ALSO WANT TO JUST THANK THE
WITNESSES
THAT TOOK TIME OUT OF THEIR BUSY
DAYS TO BE HERE THIS AFTERNOON
TO JUST
TALK ABOUT HOW NECESSARY THIS
IS.
AND THANK YOU AGAIN, UH, CHAIR,
AND TO YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US,
AS THIS IS A VERY CRITICAL ISSUE
TO ENSURE THAT CRITICAL ACCESS
HOSPITALS LIKE THE ONE THAT WE
LOST IN MY COMMUNITY,
THAT THEY DON'T, YOU KNOW,
EXPERIENCE THE SAME CHALLENGES
THAT WE HAVE.
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK AND
I VOTE WHEN THE TIME IS RIGHT.
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
NICE JOB.
AS SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM,
WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND WE'LL
DO JUST THAT.
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING.
WE'RE GOING TO RETURN TO OUR
BATTING ORDER HERE.
ITEM NUMBER 11.
AB 2169 ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER
KAHAN.
PRESCRIPTION DRUG DRUG COVERAGE.
DOSE ADJUSTMENTS.
PROCEED WHEN READY.
SOMETHING IS GOING ON.
FIVE.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR AND SENATORS, PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 2169,
WITH WHICH AUTHORIZES
PRESCRIBERS
TO ADJUST UP TO TWO TIMES
THE DOSE OR FREQUENCY OF A DRUG
WITHOUT PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
OR SUBSEQUENT UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT,
AS LONG AS THE DRUG HAS BEEN
APPROVED
FOR COVERAGE BY THE PLAN,
AND THE PLAN'S PRESCRIBING
PROVIDER
CONTINUES TO PRESCRIBE IT.
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE, 38% OF
RESIDENTS ARE CURRENTLY
LIVING WITH ONE OR MORE CHRONIC
MEDICAL CONDITIONS.
FOR INDIVIDUALS BATTLING CHRONIC
DISEASES,
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATIONS ARE
OFTEN A LIFELINE.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
HOWEVER, THE ROAD TO FINDING
EFFECTIVE
TREATMENT IS FRAUGHT WITH
CHALLENGES.
PROVIDERS MAY NEED TO ADJUST
MEDICATION
DOSAGES OVER TIME TO OPTIMIZE
RESULTS.
THE ARBITRARY DENIALS CREATE
PERILOUS
DELAYS IN TREATMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY, EACH ADJUSTMENT
CURRENTLY
REQUIRES APPROVAL FROM HEALTH
PLANS,
A PROCESS THAT ALL TOO OFTEN
ENDS IN
DENIALS AND NECESSITATES
APPEALS,
WHICH TAKES OUR DOCTORS PRECIOUS
TIME OUT
OF THEIR PATIENTS AND INTO THIS
PROCESS.
THIS IS WHY HB 2169 IS CRITICAL,
AS IT ENSURES
PATIENTS HAVE ACCESS TO
MEDICATION AT
THE APPROPRIATE STRENGTH AT THE
RIGHT TIME,
IN CONSULTATION WITH THEIR
PROVIDER.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS
LISA LUM,
A MOTHER WHOSE CHILD HAS CROHN'S
DISEASE
AND HAS PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED
THE DEBILITATING DENIALS OF
TREATMENT,
AND RYAN SPENCER, REPRESENTING
THE CROHN'S AND COLITIS
FOUNDATION.
BEFORE YOU START, LET ME.
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THE
ASSEMBLY'S
GOING BACK ON THE FLOOR AT 5
P.M..
YES, SIR.
AND WE HAVE, UM.
WHAT ARE YOU?
THREE MORE OF YOU.
UM.
TO PRESENT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW WE'RE GOING TO
MANAGE THIS.
AND WE GO ON THE FLOOR AT SIX.
SO WHAT I WOULD ASK OF YOU ALL
HERE
AT THE TABLE IS TO BE, UM,
AS BRIEF AS HUMANLY POSSIBLE,
BECAUSE YOU SEE THE LINE UP
BEHIND YOU.
UM, AND WE'LL ALL BE COMING
BACK.
OH.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR..
MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, MY NAME.
IS LISA LUM.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK
TODAY
ON BEHALF OF MY SON TREVOR,
WHO WAS DIAGNOSED WITH CROHN'S
DISEASE
TWO YEARS AGO AT THE AGE OF
NINE.
ON NOVEMBER 1ST, 2022,
TREVOR WAS PLACED ON REMICADE.
OUR INSURANCE APPROVED THE FIRST
THREE INFUSIONS,
WHICH WERE ONLY A FEW WEEKS
APART,
FOLLOWED BY A MAINTENANCE
INFUSION
EVERY EIGHT WEEKS.
WITHIN THOSE FIRST WEEKS, WE
WERE EXCITED
TO SEE IMPROVEMENT IN HIS
CONDITION,
SHOWING MINIMAL BLEEDING.
THIS HADN'T HAPPENED SINCE HE
BEGAN SYMPTOMS
IN MARCH EARLIER THAT YEAR.
ALTHOUGH WE SAW PROGRESS,
TREVOR DID NOT HAVE THE OPTIMAL
LEVELS
OF REMICADE IN HIS SYSTEM AFTER
THE THIRD INFUSION,
SO THE DOCTOR REQUESTED TO
CHANGE MAINTENANCE
FROM EVERY EIGHT WEEKS TO EVERY
FOUR.
ON DECEMBER 20TH, THE FIRST
INSURANCE DENIAL
STATED LACK OF MEDICAL
NECESSITY.
HIS DOCTOR APPEALED, RESUBMITTED
CLINICAL
TRIALS TO SUPPORT HER HER
REQUEST,
AND ASKED FOR AN EXPEDITED
REVIEW,
WHICH WAS ALSO DENIED.
ON JANUARY 21ST, A SECOND DENIAL
CAME,
STATING AGAIN,
LACK OF MEDICAL NECESSITY EVEN
AFTER MULTIPLE PHONE CALLS,
EMAILS AND SUBMITTED DOCUMENTS
FROM THE DOCTOR AND MYSELF.
THIS WAS NOW SIX WEEKS AFTER
TREVOR'S LAST INFUSION,
AND HE HAD BEEN HOME FROM SCHOOL
WITH INCREASED BLOODY STOOLS
AND HAD TO START ON STEROIDS
BECAUSE OF ALL THE WAITING.
WE MADE A THIRD AND LAST ATTEMPT
TO ASK FOR AN INCREASED
DOSAGE AMOUNT AT THE EIGHT WEEK
INFUSION,
AND AGAIN DENIED ON JANUARY
25TH.
I SUBMITTED AN INDEPENDENT
MEDICAL
REVIEW COMPLAINT TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE ON JANUARY 28TH.
AFTER JUST TWO DAYS OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S INVOLVEMENT,
THE INSURANCE FINALLY APPROVED
THE FOUR WEEK INTERVAL DOSE,
ADMITTING THAT IT WAS INDEED A
MEDICAL NECESSITY
AND TREVOR IS NOW RECEIVING A
DOSE EVERY FOUR WEEKS.
THIS WAS A VERY EMOTIONAL AND
FRUSTRATING
TIME IN OUR LIVES.
SEEING OUR YOUNG SON IN PAIN
AND BLEEDING.
WE WERE WORRIED, DESPERATE AND
AT
THE MERCY OF THE INSURANCE
COMPANY.
WE WERE ON THE EDGE OF OUR
SEATS,
HOPING JUST FOR THE OPPORTUNITY,
THAT ONE OF THE LIMITED
MEDICATIONS
AVAILABLE FOR HIS AGE WOULD
WORK.
LUCKILY, I'M A STAY AT HOME
MOTHER AND COULD DEVOTE
MY TIME TO THIS EXHAUSTING
SITUATION IF HIS MEDICAL
TEAM AND I DIDN'T ADVOCATE SO
FIERCELY FOR TREVOR,
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH LONGER HE
WOULD HAVE SUFFERED.
SO I'M HERE TODAY HOPING
TREVOR'S STORY COULD
PROVIDE ANOTHER PERSPECTIVE
ON THIS
MATTER AND COULD MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN FORWARDING
THE TREATMENT OF THIS DISEASE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR COMING AND THANK
YOU
FOR SHARING YOUR STORY, MA'AM.
THANK YOU.
BRIAN SPENCER.
ON BEHALF OF THE CROHN'S AND
COLITIS FOUNDATION,
THE SPONSORS OF AB 2169,
I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE A FEW
THINGS.
ONE, FIRST OF ALL IS AB 2169 IS
A MUCH MORE NARROWED
SURGICAL APPROACH TO THIS ISSUE
THAN YOU'VE
SEEN AND APPROVED IN PREVIOUS
YEARS IS SPECIFIC
TO CHRONIC CONDITIONS AND CANCER
ONLY.
IT DOES NOT APPLY TO OPIOIDS
OR CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
AND IS LIMITED TO TWO DOSE
ESCALATIONS.
AS WAS STATED, THERE WILL BE
COMMENTS BY
THE OPPOSITION OF THE ISSUE OF
PATIENT SAFETY,
BUT I CAN TELL YOU WHAT IS NOT
SAFE,
AND THAT'S MOVING A PATIENT OFF
OF A DRUG THAT WE KNOW WORKS.
AND THE PATIENT WAS STABLE.
THE REALITY IS THERE'S A LIMITED
SUPPLY OF
DRUGS AVAILABLE THAT MAY OR MAY
NOT WORK.
SO IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
PROVIDERS ARE ABLE
TO OPTIMIZE THE ONE DRUG THAT
DOES.
IT'S NOT SOME EXPERIMENTAL DRUG
THAT THE PLAN HAS NEVER SEEN.
IT'S A DRUG THAT THEY HAVE
CURRENT
THAT THEY ARE CURRENTLY COVERING
AND CURRENTLY PRESCRIBED BY THE
PROVIDER,
WHO ALONG WITH THE PATIENT,
KNOW WHAT IS THE BEST CARE,
IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT
WILL HELP SO MANY PEOPLE, YOUNG
PEOPLE LIKE TREVOR.
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ONLY PLEASE.
TIM MADDEN, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA
RHEUMATOLOGY ALLIANCE AND SPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
DAVID GONZALEZ, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES AND SUPPORT.
THANKS.
NEXT.
JENNIFER ROBLES WITH HEALTH
ACCESS
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT NEXT.
SARAH NOCITO ON.
BEHALF OF THE.
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DYLAN ELLIOTT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS
IN SUPPORT.
HI.
KELLY MCMILLAN.
ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN'S
SPECIALTY
CARE COALITION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
JENNIFER SNYDER ON BEHALF OF
THE PHYSICIANS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
NEXT, PLEASE.
HI.
CHARLIE DONLON WITH STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ORTHOPAEDIC
ASSOCIATION.
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
NEXT, PLEASE.
ARJUN KRISHNA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
VANESSA KAHINA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY
OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS HERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
LET'S TURN TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
FIRST LEAD OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
YOU HEARD MY.
REQUEST.
THANK YOU SIR.
I DID HEAR YOUR REQUEST, MR.
CHAIR, SO I WILL KEEP IT BRIEF.
ALSO, CONSIDERING I THINK THIS
IS THE THIRD ITERATION
OF THIS RULE THAT WE'VE WORKED
ON.
I THINK I CAN KEEP IT AS
ESPECIALLY BRIEF.
SO JET HAMPTON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH PLANS
HERE,
REGRETTABLY, IN OPPOSITION TO
AB 2169.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, WANT TO
THANK, YOU KNOW,
THE AUTHOR, HER STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS.
AGAIN, WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS
BILL FOR QUITE SOME TIME NOW.
UH, WANT TO GIVE A SPECIAL
THANKS
TO THE AUTHOR FOR MEETING WITH
US
LAST WEEK TO DISCUSS SOME
POTENTIAL
PATHWAYS FORWARD ON THIS BILL.
UM, YOU KNOW, THE THE BULK OF
OUR CONCERN
IS AROUND THE PROVISIONS IN
THE BILL
THAT NOT ONLY REMOVE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION
TO INCREASE THE DOSAGE OF A
DRUG,
BUT IT'S REMOVING THE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION
AND ALLOWING THAT THAT TREATING
PROVIDER
TO PRESCRIBE ABOVE AND BEYOND
FDA APPROVED
LABELING AS WELL AS OFF LABEL.
SO IT'S THE COMBINATION OF
REMOVING
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION AND ENABLING
THE TREATING PROVIDER TO
PRESCRIBE
BEYOND FDA APPROVED LABELING.
THAT'S REALLY KIND OF THE CRUX
OF
THE ISSUE WITH THIS BILL FOR US.
UM, AGAIN, YOU KNOW,
WE'VE HAD WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
DISCUSSIONS
AROUND THIS AND AGAIN WITH THE
AUTHOR,
UM, YOU KNOW, WHERE WE ARE
WORKING ON
SOMETHING OR TRYING TO GET
SOMEWHERE.
SO AGAIN, REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT.
BUT AGAIN, THE THE GENESIS OF
OUR,
OF OUR CONCERN IS AROUND,
AROUND THAT WHAT WE CONSIDER TO
BE A PATIENT SAFETY ISSUE.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WE ARE
OPPOSED.
BUT AGAIN, HAPPY TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
AND THE SPONSORS OFFICE MOVING
FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION?
NAME, AFFILIATION, POSITION ON
THE MEASURE ONLY, PLEASE.
CHLOE SHIN, ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
JACKIE, ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS,
WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH CAP.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
NO OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
COLLEAGUES.
QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS.
CONCERNS.
SEEING.
NONE.
MA'AM, YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
I JUST WANT TO SAY,
AS A MOM WITH A SON WITH A
CHRONIC CONDITION,
I MYSELF HAVE FACED THESE
DENIALS.
AND IT WAS NOT THE INSURANCE
COMPANY
THAT WAS TRYING TO KEEP MY SON
SAFE.
IT WAS HIS INCREDIBLE PROVIDERS.
WITH THAT, I WOULD REQUEST THEY
ASK FOR.
I VOTE.
AS SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM,
WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND WE WILL
TAKE A VOTE.
OKAY, LET'S TURN TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ORTEGA.
ITEM NUMBER 15 AB 2446 MEDI-CAL
DIAPERS.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU.
SENATOR.
I WILL KEEP IT BRIEF.
THIS BILL, AB 246, IS ABOUT
DIAPERS.
BABIES NEED THEM.
THERE IS AN ESSENTIAL ISSUE, AND
I HAVE A WITNESS
HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT WHY THERE'S
SUCH A NEED.
HI, CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
GABBY DAVIDSON WITH THE
CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS.
CURRENTLY, OVER A QUARTER OF
CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS WITH CHILDREN ARE
FOOD INSECURE WITH DEEP
DISPARITIES
FOR BLACK AND LATINO HOUSEHOLDS.
AND WE KNOW THAT HOUSEHOLDS THAT
ARE FACING FOOD INSECURITY
ALSO FACE TROUBLE MEETING OTHER
BASIC NEEDS.
DIAPERS ARE ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON
NON-FOOD ITEMS REQUESTED
BY FAMILIES WHO VISIT FOOD BANKS
AND FOOD PANTRIES.
AND YOU KNOW, MY MOM RAISED
TRIPLETS ON HER OWN,
SO SHE ALSO KNOWS HOW EXPENSIVE
THEY CAN BE.
AND THE DECISION FOR FAMILIES
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE OR
PAYING
THEIR BILLS OR BUYING DIAPERS
IS ONE
THAT NO FAMILY SHOULD HAVE TO
MAKE.
WE ARE PROUD CO-SPONSOR
CO-SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL, AND WE URGE YOUR
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
PLEASE STATE YOUR.
NAME.
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
WHITNEY FRANCIS WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY IN SUPPORT.
NICOLE BERTLEMANN ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT.
VANESSA, SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA
ACADEMY OF FAMILY PHYSICIANS
HERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION?
ANY ONE WOULD LIKE TO STATE AN.
OPPOSITION.
POSITION SEEING NONE.
COLLEAGUES.
QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS?
I'LL MOVE THE BILL WHEN THE TIME
IS RIGHT.
THANK YOU.
UM, MADAM ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR.
I VOTE WHEN THE TIME COMES.
THANK YOU.
AND, UH.
AS SOON AS WE HAVE A QUORUM,
WE WILL TAKE.
WE WILL TAKE UP THE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THAT WAS QUICK.
THAT WAS PROBABLY THE FASTEST
ONE.
YEAH.
THANK YOU.
UH.
LAST ONE.
NO, WE HAVE TWO MORE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN.
CALDERON.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
WE HAVE ONE MORE AFTER THIS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR.
MEMBERS.
UM, I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
THANKING YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE
ON LANGUAGE FOR THIS BILL TO
STRIKE A BALANCE
AND ADDRESS OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AND IT WAS A HEAVY LIFT.
THEY DID A REALLY GOOD JOB.
SO THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3030 REQUIRES
HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS DEPLOYING
GENERATIVE ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE, OR GEN AI,
FOR PATIENT COMMUNICATION TO
DISCLOSE
THE TECHNOLOGY'S USAGE WHEN
IT IS NOT REVIEWED BY A LICENSED
HEALTH CARE PROFESSIONAL.
ACROSS THE STATE, PILOT PROGRAMS
ARE TESTING THE USE OF GEN AI
AS A TOOL TO ASSIST CLINICIANS
WITH PATIENT COMMUNICATIONS.
FOR EXAMPLE, UC SAN DIEGO HEALTH
CURRENTLY
HAS A PILOT PROGRAM INTEGRATING
GEN AI INTO MYCHART AS HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS DEPLOY GEN I.
PATIENTS SHOULD BE AWARE OF WHO
THEY ARE COMMUNICATING WITH TO
MAINTAIN CONFIDENCE IN THE
HEALTH
CARE THEY ARE RECEIVING.
AB 3030 IS A GOOD GOVERNANCE
BILL SEEKING TO ENSURE
THE ETHICAL USE OF GEN AI IN
HEALTH CARE.
WITH ME IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
IS ERIN BOWEN,
CHIEF OF LEGISLATION AND PUBLIC
AFFAIRS
FOR THE MEDICAL BOARD OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MEMBERS.
ERIN BOWEN WITH THE.
MEDICAL BOARD OF CALIFORNIA.
AB 3030.
PROMOTES PATIENT AWARENESS.
OF HOW THEIR HEALTH CARE IS
DELIVERED
AND HELPS TO EMPOWER
CONSUMERS AS THEY MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT THEIR CARE.
THIS BILL HELPS FOSTER TRUST IN
THE PATIENT
AND THE HEALTH CARE SYSTEM BY
MAKING IT CLEAR
WHEN PATIENTS ARE COMMUNICATING
WITH A HUMAN
PROVIDER OR WITH A SOFTWARE
PROGRAM,
INCLUDING HOW THEY CAN CONTACT
A PERSON WHEN THEY WISH TO DO
SO.
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THIS
BILL
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
I VOTE.
ANY OTHER.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COME ON DOWN.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND.
MEMBERS, MARK FAROOQ.
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION.
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
ACCEPTED,
WE WILL BE REMOVING OUR
OPPOSITION.
REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
AND THE TIME OF HER STAFF,
AS WELL AS THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN RESOLVING
OUR ISSUES.
THANK YOU.
EXCELLENT WORK.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
BRANDON MARTY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION,
WANT TO ECHO MY COMMENTS OR ECHO
THE COMMENTS
OF MY COLLEAGUE AT THE HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION?
THANK YOU AND WE ARE NEUTRAL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
OKAY, SEEING NO OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION.
BACK TO THE DAIS.
COLLEAGUES, ANY COMMENTS,
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS?
SEEING NONE.
SO, MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE.
UH, MR.
CHAIR, THANK YOU.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
I VOTE.
AS SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM,
WE'LL TAKE A MOTION AND WE'LL
DO JUST THAT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
GIVE ME OUT OF TROUBLE, OKAY?
SENATOR ROTH IS GOING TO BE
PRESENTING
FINAL ITEM 19 AB 2899
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL.
SENATOR, YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU.
UM, I GUESS, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS,
PLEASED TO PRESENT THIS BILL,
WHICH IS GOING TO BRING GREATER
TRANSPARENCY IN THE WAY THAT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE TO COMPLAINTS REGARDING
THE VIOLATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIO LAW.
AS YOU MAY KNOW, SINCE THE
PASSAGE
OF KEY STAFFING RATIO LAWS,
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH HAS HELD THE IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY OF ENFORCING
THESE
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS.
DESPITE THE LAWS ON THE BOOKS,
NURSES HAVE PERSISTENTLY RAISED
CONCERNS
ABOUT CONTINUOUS VIOLATIONS OF
THE LAW WITHIN THEIR WORKPLACES.
THESE CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
CAREFULLY
DOCUMENTED THROUGH
THE SUBMISSION OF THOUSANDS OF
STAFFING COMPLAINTS TO CDPH.
THIS BILL WILL SUPPORT WORKPLACE
SAFETY EFFORTS
AND IMPROVE TRANSPARENCY BY
REQUIRING CDPH
TO CONCURRENTLY NOTIFY BOTH THE
HOSPITAL
AND THE INDIVIDUAL WHO REPORTED
THE VIOLATION,
ALONG WITH THEIR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING
AGENT OR REPRESENTATIVE,
REGARDING THE ACTION TO BE TAKEN
FOR SUBSTANTIATED VIOLATIONS.
SAFE NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS
ARE CRUCIAL
FOR ENSURING THAT PATIENTS
RECEIVE THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
CARE AND ATTENTION.
FAILURE TO ADHERE TO RATIOS
LEADS TO ERRORS,
MAY LEAD TO DELAYS IN CARE
AND COMPROMISED PATIENT SAFETY.
IT'S OUR EXPECTATION THAT WITH
MORE TRANSPARENCY,
HOSPITALS WILL ADHERE TO THE
STAFFING
LAW IN ORDER TO MAINTAIN
HIGH QUALITY CARE FOR PATIENTS
AND AVOID NURSE BURNOUT.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY NURSES
AND LABOR UNIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA,
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE ARE
ALICIA AMBRIZ,
IF I PRONOUNCE THAT CORRECTLY.
CLOSE.
I HATE TO MISPRONOUNCE NAMES.
EUNUCH SECRETARY AT SAINT
FRANCIS MEDICAL CENTER,
AND MATT LEGGETT, SEIU ADVOCATE.
WITNESS.
YOU HAVE TWO.
MINUTES.
OKAY.
CAN YOU HEAR ME?
IS IT ON?
YES.
IT'S ON.
HI.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR ROTH AND MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2899.
MY NAME IS ALICIA AMBRIZ.
I AM A REGISTERED NURSE AND A
MEMBER
OF THE UNITED NURSES
ASSOCIATIONS
OF CALIFORNIA UNION OF HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS.
I'VE BEEN AN ACUTE OBSTETRICS
NURSE CARE FOR 30 YEARS,
AND I HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE
CHALLENGES
THAT THE UNDERSTAFFING CREATES,
INCLUDING THE LONG TERM IMPACT
IT HAS ON THE WORKING NURSE.
WHEN A NURSE CONSISTENTLY WORKS
IN AN UNDERSTAFFED UNIT,
IF NOT ONLY PLACES TREMENDOUS
STRAIN ON THE NURSE WHO
IS NOW RESPONSIBLE FOR MANAGING
MORE PATIENTS,
BUT IT ALSO DISRUPTS THE OVERALL
FUNCTIONING OF THE UNIT.
OVER TIME, THESE PERSISTENT
VIOLATIONS
OF NURSE TO PATIENT
RATIOS ERODE TRUST IN THE
REGULATORY SYSTEM.
BECAUSE THE LAWS ESTABLISHED
TO SAFEGUARD BOTH NURSES
AND PATIENTS ARE NOT EFFECTIVELY
ENFORCED.
AFTER COVID 19, THOUSANDS OF
NURSES
LEFT THE PROFESSION BECAUSE
OF UNSAFE STAFFING ASSIGNMENTS
THAT LED TO BURNOUT,
A CHRONIC ISSUE ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES IN NURSING.
AS A NURSE LEADER IN MY UNION
AND HOSPITAL,
I HAVE SUBMITTED COMPLAINTS TO
CDPH NOTIFYING
THE DEPARTMENT OF VIOLATIONS OF
THE STAFFING RATIO.
UNFORTUNATELY, COMMUNICATION
HAS PROVEN TO BE CHALLENGING
AND THE OUTCOMES OF MY
COMPLAINTS,
AS WELL AS THOSE FROM OTHER
NURSES LACK TRANSPARENCY.
THESE OUTCOMES HAVE BEEN
PERSISTENT
FOR 20 YEARS AND MORE RECENTLY,
WHEN FINES WERE INTRODUCED,
HARDLY ANY HAVE BEEN ISSUED TO
THESE FACILITIES.
AB 2899 BRINGS SUNLIGHT TO A
COMPLAINT INVESTIGATION
PROCESS THAT CURRENTLY CREATES
A LOT OF SUSPICION AND DISTRUST
AMONG
THE NURSING STAFF AT HOSPITALS.
CURRENTLY, WHEN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH DPH
FINDS A SUBSTANTIATED VIOLATION
OF NURSE STAFFING RATIOS,
IT IS REQUIRED TO SEND
INFORMATION
TO THE GENERAL ACUTE CARE
HOSPITAL
REGARDING THE ACTION TO BE TAKEN
BASED ON THAT VIOLATION,
BUT THE PARTY FILING A REPORT OF
A STAFFING VIOLATION, TYPICALLY,
AN OVERWORKED NURSE IN THE
HOSPITAL,
IS NOT ALERTED AS TO ANY ACTION
TAKEN BY A CDF.
AB 2899 WILL CHANGE THAT BY
REQUIRING CDF TO PROVIDE
THE SAME INFORMATION THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO THE HOSPITAL,
TO THE PERSON MAKING THE
COMPLAINT OR THEIR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
REPRESENTATIVE.
THIS WAY.
WRAP IT UP.
OH, SORRY.
OKAY, SO IT IS IMPORTANT TO NOTE
THAT AB
DOES NOT ESTABLISH ANY NEW
VIOLATION,
PENALTIES OR ENFORCEMENT
REQUIREMENTS.
IT JUST MERELY REQUIRES THE
DISSEMINATION
OF INFORMATION
ABOUT THE CURRENT PROCESS
REGARDING VIOLATIONS.
MOREOVER, IT IS LIMITED IN SCOPE
TO IMPOSE ANY REQUIREMENTS
IN CASES WHERE THERE IS NO
SUBSTANTIATED VIOLATIONS.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I THINK THEY'LL DO IT FOR YOU.
DON'T TOUCH.
THEY'LL DO IT.
WE WERE.
DOING THE.
OPENING, THE CAR DOOR LOCK.
SO I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MATT LEGGETT, ON BEHALF OF SEIU
CALIFORNIA,
AND I APPRECIATE THE CHAIR
PRESENTING
THE BILL AND THE AUTHOR
FOR CARRYING THIS IN THE WORK
OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
JUST VERY QUICKLY ON THIS BILL,
AS WE'RE LOOKING AT ENFORCING
NURSE TO PATIENT RATIOS,
OFTEN THERE ARE STEPS THAT CDPH
WOULD ASK HOSPITALS TO TAKE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE EVENTS ARE
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN AGAIN.
SO IT COULD BE A CALL LIST.
IT COULD BE A NUMBER OF OTHER
ACTIONS MAKING SURE THAT
THE UNION AND THE NURSES ON THE
GROUND ARE AWARE.
MAKE SURE ALLOWS US TO HELP THE
HOSPITALS
AND COME TO COLLABORATIVE
SOLUTIONS,
OFTEN TO MAKE SURE THAT NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIOS ARE NOT VIOLATED.
AGAIN.
SO FOR US, WE THINK THIS IS A
REALLY STRAIGHTFORWARD
BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERYONE
ON
THE FRONT LINES IS MADE FULLY
AWARE OF THE STEPS
THAT NEED TO BE TAKEN TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANY ONE WOULD LIKE TO COME UP
AND STATE A POSITION OF SUPPORT.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME,
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION.
BRIAN MIRAMONTEZ WITH SB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
BENJAMIN EICHER.
NATIONAL UNION OF HEALTHCARE
WORKERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANY LEAD WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION,
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE.
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO COME
AND STAY A POSITION OF A POST.
PLEASE COME FORWARD.
SEEING NONE.
COLLEAGUES.
QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS.
HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL WHEN THE
TIME IS RIGHT.
THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE?
WELL, THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR.
I'M A BIT DISAPPOINTED.
I LOST MOST OF MY AUDIENCE.
I DON'T KNOW WHETHER THAT'S
A STATEMENT OF MY ABILITIES
AS THE PRESENTER OR CHAIR OF
THIS COMMITTEE,
BUT IT CERTAINLY IS A PRIVILEGE
TO PRESENT
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL.
HE'S A FINE AUTHOR, AND AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME,
I'D RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
I VOTE.
>> THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GROVE IS ON HER WAY.
YES SHE DID.
OKAY, LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
IF WE CAN DO THAT, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH.
HERE.
ROTH.
WEN.
HERE.
GLASER.
GONZALEZ.
HERE.
GROVE.
HURTADO.
HERE.
LIMON.
MENGIBAR AND GUEVARA.
HERE.
RUBIO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
HERE.
WIENER.
YEAH.
WE GOT.
SEVEN.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
SO LET'S START AT THE TOP OF
THE.
INNING BATTING ORDER.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
THERE ARE NINE OF THEM ON
THE PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR.
DO YOU NEED ME TO READ THEM?
NO.
OKAY.
WHO MOVED IT?
SORRY.
WHEN SENATOR NGUYEN MOVED THIS
CONSENT CALENDAR,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH.
I.
ROTH I WHEN I WHEN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
GROVE.
I HURTADO.
HURTADO I LIMON.
MENGIBAR.
I.
RUBIO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I.
WIENER.
VOTE IS SEVEN ZERO.
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
THAT'S ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
236 BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN.
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE PROVIDER
DIRECTORIES.
IS THERE A MOTION.
SO MOVE.
BY SMALLWOOD SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
A MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR ROTH A ROTH I WHEN
GLAZER
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
HURTADO I.
LIMON.
LEMON.
I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I.
RUBIO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I WIENER.
OH.
NO.
DO YOU WANT TO?
MR.
CHAIRMAN, THERE'S TWO MORE THAT
JUST SHOWED UP.
WE JUST.
WE VOTED.
WE JUST NEED TO SEE IF RUBIO
WANTS TO.
YEAH.
WE'RE ON ITEM NUMBER TWO.
AB 236.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, HOLDEN HEALTH
CARE
COVERAGE PROVIDER DIRECTORIES.
CALL THE ROLL AGAIN, PLEASE.
SENATOR.
WHEN?
GLASER.
PETRA RUBIO.
I RUBIO.
I WIENER.
THE VOTE IS 7 TO 1.
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 4AB
3129.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOOD HEALTH
CARE SYSTEM CONSOLIDATION.
UM, IS THERE A MOTION?
HURTADO.
SENATOR HURTADO MOVED THE BILL
AND THE MOTION IS.
DO PASSES AMENDED AND RE REFER
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH.
I ROTH.
I WHEN.
NO.
WHEN.
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
HURTADO I.
LIMON.
MENGIBAR RUBIO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
WIENER.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 2.
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 5AB
3218.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WOOD ON FLAVORED TOBACCO.
LIST.
THE MOTION IS DUE, PASS IS
AMENDED AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
IS THERE A MOTION?
SENATOR HURTADO AGAIN, GOOD
FOR YOU.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH, A ROTH I.
WHEN.
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
HURTADO I.
LEMON.
LEMON I.
MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I.
WEINER.
CURRENT VOTE, 7 TO 1 WILL HOLD
THE DOOR OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB 1830.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ARAMBULA.
CORN.
MASA.
FLOUR.
MOTION IS DUE.
PASS AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATION.
IS THERE A MOTION?
WHO DID THAT?
SENATOR TOTH AGAIN.
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THE PRIZE.
YEAH.
PLEASE CALL THE.
ROLL.
SENATOR, THE MOTION IS DUE PASS,
AND WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH I.
ROTH I, WHEN I WHEN I GLASER.
GONZALEZ.
I.
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
HURTADO I LIMON.
LEMON.
I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I RUBIO.
RUBIO.
I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WIENER.
CURRENT VOTE 8 TO 1 WILL HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 9AB
35 93059.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
HUMAN MILK MOTION DO PASS.
AND WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
I DO NEED A MOTION.
MOTION.
SENATOR HURTADO AGAIN.
OKAY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH A.
ROTH I.
WHEN I WHEN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
THAT MEMBERS.
HUMAN MILK.
THE HUMAN MILK.
NO.
GROVE.
HURTADO.
A LEMON.
LEMON A MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR A RUBIO.
RUBIO A SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS A WIENER.
CURRENT VOTE 8 TO 1 WILL HOLD
THE ROLL.
MR.
CHAIR, JUST BECAUSE OF THE WAY
THAT
THE DAY HAS RUN OF US BOUNCING
BACK AND FORTH BETWEEN THE
COMMITTEES,
CAN THERE CAN WE.
CLARIFY THAT ON THE HUMAN.
MILK BILL?
WAS THERE AMENDMENTS TAKEN?
NOT IN NOT IN COMMITTEE.
THE BILL WAS.
AMENDED.
WE'RE VOTING ON THE INPUT ONE.
THE VERSION THAT'S IN PRINT.
BUT IT REMOVED ALL.
THE OPPOSITION, THE AMENDMENTS
THAT ARE IN PRINT,
THAT THE WAY THE BILL WAS
WRITTEN AT FIRST,
IT EXCLUDED ANOTHER NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION
THAT PROVIDED THE MILK.
UM, AND THEY GOT INCLUDED.
THE NON PROFIT THAT WAS EXCLUDED
BY THE WAY THEY GOT INCLUDED.
I BELIEVE SO, BUT LET ME, LET
ME I'M RIGHT HERE.
I'M RIGHT HERE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
SORRY.
I'M IN, I, I APOLOGIZE.
SO LET'S.
SO IT'S SO GROVE.
GROVE.
NO TO I.
YES.
OKAY.
GROVE.
NO TO I.
THE CURRENT VOTE COUNT IS NINE
ZERO.
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 11
AB 2169
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER-KAHAN.
PRESCRIPTION DRUG DRUG COVERAGE
DOSE ADJUSTMENTS.
MOTION TO PASS REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
I DO NEED A MOTION BY SENATOR
HURTADO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH I.
ROTH I.
WHEN GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
NO.
HURTADO.
HURTADO I.
LIMON.
LEMON.
I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WIENER.
CURRENT VOTE 7 TO 1.
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 12.
AB 2300 ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WILSON MEDICAL DEVICES DEHP.
THE MOTION TO PASS IS AMENDED
AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
I NEED A MOTION.
SENATOR HURTADO AGAIN.
SHE'S GOING TO GET THE PRIZE.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH I.
ROTH I.
WHEN GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
HURTADO.
HURTADO I LIMON.
LEMON I MENGIBAR.
SORRY.
MENGIBAR I.
I GOT IT, RUBIO.
OH, SORRY.
RUBIO I.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I.
WEENER.
I NEED TO COME BACK TO.
I NEED TO COME BACK.
UH, SENATOR GROVE I.
WHEN I.
SENATOR WHEN I.
CURRENT VOTE IS NINE ZERO,
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 13,
AB 2319 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WILSON AND
WEBER,
CALIFORNIA DIGNITY AND PREGNANCY
AND CHILDBIRTH ACT.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS, WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE
THE MOTION?
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED,
AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH I.
ROTH I.
WHEN.
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
NO.
GROVE?
WHAT NUMBER?
I'M SORRY, YOU GUYS.
WE'RE 13 AB 2319.
THANK YOU SIR.
WHAT'S.
WHAT'S THE VOTE?
NO.
GROVE?
HURTADO.
HURTADO I LIMON.
LEMON I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I RUBIO.
RUBIO I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WEENER.
WHEN I AM.
NO.
WHEN?
7 TO 2.
IS THAT WHAT YOU GET?
YES.
CURRENT VOTE.
7 TO 2 WILL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 14 WAS
PULLED.
ITEM NUMBER 15 A B 2446.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ORTEGA MEDICAL
DIAPERS.
MOTION DO PASS.
WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
I DO NEED A MOTION.
SO MOVED.
OKAY.
WHO WAS THAT NOW?
SENATOR MORGAN.
OKAY.
SENATOR LIMON, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH I.
ROTH I.
WHEN I WHEN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I GROVE.
GROVE.
I HURTADO.
HURTADO I LIMON A LEMON.
I MENGIBAR.
I RUBIO.
RUBIO.
I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WEENER.
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO WILL HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
18 OR 19.
1919.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 19
AB 2899.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL GENERAL.
ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS.
LICENSED NURSE TO PATIENT
RATIOS.
MOTION DO PASS.
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
I NEED A MOTION.
SO MOVED BY SENATOR MENGIBAR,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH.
AYE.
ROTH I.
WHEN.
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
HURTADO.
HURTADO I.
LIMON.
A LEMON I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I RUBIO I RUBIO.
I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WEENER.
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO WILL
HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 20
AB 3030.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CALDERON HEALTH CARE SERVICES
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED.
WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
I DO NEED A MOTION.
ANYONE?
SENATOR GONZALEZ MAKES THE
MOTION.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH I.
ROTH I.
WHEN I WHEN I GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
I HURTADO.
HURTADO I LEMON.
LEMON.
I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I RUBIO.
I RUBIO.
I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WEENER.
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO HOLD WILL
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER 22 AB 3260.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN.
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE, REVIEWS
AND GRIEVANCES.
MOTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED.
WE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
I NEED A MOTION.
ANY TAKERS?
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
OH, SENATOR NEWMAN.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH I ROTH I WHEN
GLAZER.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ, I GROVE.
HURTADO.
I HURTADO I LEMONY, LEMONY I
MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I RUBIO I RUBIO I
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WEENER.
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO WILL
HOLD
A ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 23
AB 3275.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS SORIA AND RIVAS
HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CLAIM REIMBURSEMENT
MOTION TO PASS,
AS AMENDED, REFERRED TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
I NEED A MOTION.
SENATOR IMAN, AGAIN,
YOU'RE GOING TO CATCH UP WITH
SENATOR HURTADO.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR ROTH.
I ROTH.
I WHEN I, WHEN I GLASER.
GLASER.
I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I.
GROVE.
GROVE I HURTADO I HURTADO I
LEMON.
I MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR.
I RUBIO.
I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I WEENER.
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO WILL HOLD
ARE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR ROLL.
TO CHANGE YOUR VOTE ON ONE OF
THE MEMBERS
NEED TO CHANGE MY VOTE ON ONE.
I DON'T THINK THAT'S OKAY.
YEAH.
YOU NEED A RAISE AFTER TODAY.
I'M NOT GOING TO ARGUE WITH YOU
ABOUT THAT.
NO.
11.
WHICH IS WHAT NUMBER?
IT'S NUMBER FOUR.
NUMBER 11.
80, 21, 69.
LET'S OPEN THE ROLL ON ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB 3129.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD.
UH, HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION.
LET'S OPEN THE ROLL AND CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
WE GO.
SENATOR GLAZER.
LYMAN.
MENGIBAR.
RUBIO.
SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS.
CUEVAS I.
NO WIENER.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 2.
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO VOTE ON ITEM
NUMBER 11 2016.
OKAY.
LET'S OPEN THE ROLL ON.
UM, WELL, LET'S DO THIS.
UM, SENATOR GLAZER IS HERE AND
HE NEEDS
TO VOTE ON AT LEAST HAVE THE.
WE'RE IN THE SAME HEARING.
I DON'T WANT TO WAIT FOR SCOTT
OR NOT TO.
SAVE YOU TIME, BUT WE BOTH
MISSED EVERYTHING.
I'M READY TO VOTE ON EVERYTHING.
WELL, LET'S TAKE IT.
WE'LL JUST TAKE IT.
LET'S OPEN THE ROLL.
AND WE'RE GOING TO START AT
THE TOP WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
UM, THOSE OF YOU WHO NEED TO
CHANGE VOTES,
PLEASE SPEAK UP.
UH, THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS.
DO YOU NEED ME TO READ THE
CONSENT?
NOPE.
OKAY, GOOD.
THE CURRENT VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS SEVEN ZERO.
CHAIR VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR GLASER.
GLASER I LEMONY LEMONY I.
RUBIO.
RUBIO I WIENER.
CURRENT VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS TEN ZERO.
WILL HOLD OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB 236 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER,
HOLDEN HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
PROVIDER DIRECTORIES.
CURRENT VOTE IS 7 TO 1 CHAIR
VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR NGUYEN.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
WIENER.
CURRENT VOTE, 8 TO 1 WILL HOLD
A ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER.
WE JUST DID ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
UH, YES.
DO YOU NEED INFORMATION?
WHY NOT?
IT WOULD BE.
THE.
THE AMENDMENTS WERE TO TAKE OUT
NUMBING NUMBER ONE.
AND I'M.
YOUR AMENDMENTS.
THEY WERE REQUESTED.
YES WE WILL.
AND I NEED TO GET THEM.
I NEED TO GET THE.
I APOLOGIZE.
DON'T BE.
DON'T.
NO.
THAT'S GOOD.
I THINK I JUST NEED TO GET THE
BILL.
THE ONLY THING YOU WERE MISSING.
YEAH, I THINK THAT'S THE ONLY
THING.
OKAY.
THERE'S RIGHT HERE.
THAT'S PRETTY.
WE JUST WANT OUR.
I JUST.
OKAY.
WE'RE ON ITEM NUMBER FIVE.
AB 3218.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WOOD UNFLAVORED TOBACCO LIST.
CURRENT VOTE IS 7 TO 1.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR NGUYEN.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
WEINER.
OKAY.
CURRENT VOTE 8 TO 1 WILL HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
CAN YOU OPEN THE ROLL ON ITEM
FOUR?
OKAY.
WHY NOT?
LET'S GO BACK TO, UH, FILE ITEM
FOUR AND REOPEN
THE ROLL FILE ON FOUR IS AB 3129
ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WOOD HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION.
THE MOTION WAS MADE BY SENATOR
HURTADO,
AND THE MOTION WAS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 2.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SENATOR GLAZIER.
LEMON.
MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR I.
RUBIO.
WIENER.
CURRENT VOTE 5 TO 2.
WE'LL HOLD THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
UM.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER SIX,
AB 1830.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA.
CORN.
MASA.
FLOUR.
CURRENT VOTE IS 8 TO 1.
MOTION TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SEN.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
WEINER.
CURRENT VOTE 9 TO 1 WILL HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER NINE.
AB 3059.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WEBER.
HUMAN MILK.
CURRENT VOTE NINE.
9 TO 0 CHAIR VOTING I MOTION
IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
WEINER.
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO WILL HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER 11.
AB 2169.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BARKER AND
PRESCRIPTION
DRUG COVERAGE.
DOSE ADJUSTMENT.
MOTION TO PASS AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 7 TO 1 CHAIR.
VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR NGUYEN.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
WEINER.
NO.
TO I.
GROVE.
NO TO I.
CURRENT VOTE 9 TO 0 WILL HOLD
THE ROLL OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 12.
AB 2300.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WILSON.
MEDICAL DEVICES DEHP MOTION DO
PASS AS AMENDED.
WE REFER THE COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
CURRENT VOTE IS 9 TO 0.
CHAIR VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SEN.
GLASER.
I.
WEINER.
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO.
WILL HOLD THE ROPE.
AND FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM NUMBER 13 IS NEXT.
AB 2319 ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WILSON
AND WEBER,
CALIFORNIA DIGNITY AND PREGNANCY
AND CHILDBIRTH
ACT MOTION DO PASS, AS AMENDED.
WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY.
CURRENT VOTE 7 TO 2.
CHAIR VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SEN.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
WEINER.
WEINER I.
CURRENT VOTE IS 9 TO 2.
THAT MEASURE IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER 14, AB 2376 WAS
PULLED.
NEXT ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER 15 AB
2446 ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ORTEGA MEDI-CAL DIAPERS.
MOTION TO PASS.
WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO.
CHAIR VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE.
ROLL.
SEN.
GLASER.
GLASER I.
WEINER.
WEINER I.
CURRENT VOTE 11 TO 0.
THAT MATTER IS.
MEASURE IS OUT.
NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER 19 AB 2899.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL.
GENERAL.
ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS.
LICENSED NURSE PATIENT RATIOS.
MOTION TO PASS.
WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 7 TO 0.
CHAIR VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR NGUYEN.
GLASER.
I.
GROVE.
WEINER.
WIENER I CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO.
UH.
THAT MATTER IS OUT.
NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER.
EXCUSE ME.
20 AB 3030 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON CALDERON.
HEALTH CARE SERVICES, ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE.
CURRENT VOTE MOTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED.
WE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 9 TO 0.
CHAIR VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SEN.
GLASER.
GLASER I WIENER I WIENER I.
CURRENT VOTE 11 TO 0.
THAT MATTER IS OUT.
UM.
NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER 22 AB 3260.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN.
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE, REVIEWS
AND GRIEVANCES.
MOTION TO PASS, AS AMENDED.
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 7 TO 0.
CHAIR.
VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR NGUYEN.
GLASER.
GLASER, I.
GROVE.
WEINER.
WIENER I CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO.
THAT MATTER IS OUT.
FINAL ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER 2523 AB 3275.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
SORIA AND RIVAS HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE CLAIM
REIMBURSEMENT MOTION DO PASS
AS AMENDED.
WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE 9 TO 0.
CHAIR VOTING I.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER I CURRENT VOTE 11 TO 0.
THAT MATTER IS OUT.
I GET LETTER OF CONSENT.
I THOUGHT SOMEBODY WANTED TO.
CHANGE A VOTE.
OH, SHE DID, SHE DID, SHE DID.
THANK YOU SIR.
OKAY, LET'S OPEN THE ROLL AGAIN
TO PICK UP AN ABSENT MEMBER.
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH ITEM
NUMBER ONE,
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
CURRENT VOTE.
DO YOU NEED US TO READ THE ITEMS
ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR, SENATOR?
OKAY.
NO.
UM, CURRENT VOTE IS, UM, 10 TO
0 CHAIR VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER I CONSENT CALENDAR IS
OUT.
NEXT ITEM, ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
236.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN HEALTH
CARE
COVERAGE PROVIDER DIRECTORIES.
MOTION TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
BE REFERRED TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 8 TO 1.
CHAIR VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR NGUYEN.
WIENER.
WIENER I.
CURRENT VOTE 9 TO 1.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB 3129
ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
WOOD HEALTH CARE SYSTEM
CONSOLIDATION.
MOTION TO PASS, AS AMENDED.
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
CURRENT VOTE IS 5 TO 2.
CHAIR VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR GLAZER.
LEMON.
RUBIO.
WIENER.
WIENER I 6.62.
CURRENT VOTE IS 6 TO 2.
THAT MEASURE IS OUT.
NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER 5AB 3218.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
WOOD.
UNFLAVORED TOBACCO.
LIST.
MOTION TO PASS AS AMENDED.
WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 8 TO 1.
CHAIR.
VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR NGUYEN WIENER A WIENER
A CURRENT.
VOTE 9 TO 1.
THAT MATTER IS OUT.
NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER 6AB 1830.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ARANMULA CORN MASA.
MOTION TO PASS.
WE REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE IS 9 TO 1.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR WIENER A WIENER.
I VOTE 10 TO 1.
THAT MATTER IS THAT MEASURE
IS OUT.
NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER 9AB3059.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER.
HUMAN MILK MOTION DUE PASS.
WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO.
CHAIR VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER.
I VOTE 11 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
NEXT ITEM.
ITEM NUMBER 11 A B 2169.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BARKER AND
PRESCRIPTION
DRUG COVERAGE DOSE ADJUSTMENTS.
MOTION TO PASS.
WE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
CURRENT VOTE NINE ZERO CHAIR
VOTING I.
PLEASE OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR NGUYEN WIENER WIENER
A CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
UH, ITEM NUMBER 12 AB 2300
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON
MEDICAL DEVICES DEHP MOTION TO
PASS, AS AMENDED.
REFER TO COMMITTEE ON
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO.
CHAIR VOTING I PLEASE.
OH, PLEASE.
OPEN THE ROLL.
SENATOR WIENER A WIENER A.
CURRENT VOTE 11 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
NEXT ITEM, ITEM NUMBER 13 AB
2319.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WILSON AND
WEBER,
CALIFORNIA DIGNITY AND PREGNANCY
AND CHILDBIRTH ACT.
THAT'S OUT.
RIGHT?
EXCUSE ME.
I THINK THAT'S IT.
15 IS OUT.
16 IS ON CONSENT 1718 CONSENT
1920 BOTH OUT 21.
CONSENT 22 IS OUT AND 23 IS OUT.
WE'RE FINISHED.
RIGHT?
YES, SIR.
THAT CONCLUDES THE SENATE
COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH HEARING FOR TODAY.
GOOD.